Bewegung erfordert Kraft, Zeit, Nerven. Manuelle Hausarbeit kostet ihre Kraft, ihre Zeit, ihre Nerven. Öffnen sie ihre Wohnung der modernen Technik. Und alles wird leichter, alles geht schneller. Alles wird mühelos sauber. Machen sie es sich doch auch leichter, durch moderne Technik aus ihren Konsum-Verkaufsstellen.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 160. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und nach langer, langer Pause geht es jetzt hier wieder weiter im Programm, wie es auch sein soll. Und ich dachte mir so zum Aufwachen nach der langen Sommerpause, müsste man jetzt vielleicht noch nicht gleich wieder so die Hardcore-Technik aus dem Schrank ziehen, sondern könnte sich vielleicht auch mal so ein bisschen mit gesellschaftlichen Dingen auseinandersetzen, die schon etwas länger zurückliegen. Nebenbei sind hier irgendwelche Schornsteinfäge am Werk, das ignorieren wir jetzt einfach mal. Thema soll sein die Deutsche Demokratische Republik, DDR, die wir alle kennen und schätzen, beziehungsweise eigentlich wissen wir nicht so richtig genau Bescheid, seitdem wir kommen von da. Was mich betrifft, ich bin ja so ein Westkind und habe von daher eigentlich so recht keine Ahnung. Ich hatte zwar so meine Berührungen auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise, aber vielleicht ist es doch besser, man fragt mal die Experten. Ich begrüße im Studio Frank, Frank Rieger. Martin Schramm, hallo. Ja, ihr seid so richtige Ostlava. Ostler habe ich nämlich. Das ist zum Beispiel eines der ersten Worte, die ich so gelernt habe. Es gab ja so diese Wessi-Ossi-Konfusion. Also da könnt ihr mich auch gleich mal korrigieren, ob meine Sichtweise richtig war. Aber ich habe so gelernt, es gab keine Ossis. Das ist sozusagen die Kurzvariante. Es wurde immer so von Ossi und Wessi geredet. Aber eigentlich ist dieses Wort Ossi eine totale Medienerfindung. Die hat so keiner benutzt. Sondern die Leute aus dem Osten, haben die Leute aus dem Osten als Ostler bezeichnet? Nein, aber in Berlin habe ich das mehrfach gehabt.
Das war dann aber erst später.
Wann später?
Na so in den 90ern.
Na ja, so nach der Winde halt. Das meinte ich jetzt.
Also Wessis gab es dann sehr früh, so alt. Eigentlich hat man eher gesagt, kommt aus dem Osten. Man hatte nicht diese Verkürzung.
In Westberlin gab es ja auch noch so einen Slang, da gab es vor allem Bundis.
Bundis?
Ja, Bundis sind Leute aus Westdeutschland, wie der Westberliner sagte.
Bezog sich das nur auf die Leute, die vor der Bundesrepublik Deutschland waren.
Westberlin gehörte ja nicht dazu.
Bezog sich das nur auf die Leute, die vor der Bundeswehr geflohen waren?
Alle in Berlin sind vor der Bundeswehr geflohen.
Da haben wir schon wieder viele Leute vergessen, dass der eleganteste Weg an der Bundeswehr vorbeigekommen war.
Richtig. Und auch der eleganteste Weg war günstige Telefonverbindungen zur Internetkommunikation herzubekommen, weil man ja nur eine Einheit abdrücken musste pro Verbindung.
Wie war so schön.
Pro 24 Stunden.
Nee, nee, nee. Wie die Vause schon sagte, damals das Hauptproblem an einer einmonatigen Verbindung zur Mailbox ist, dass man 19 Freiheiten verschwendet. Ach so, das waren mehr als 24 Stunden, ich versteh ja auch. Man hatte ja 20 Freiheiten und die Verbindungen lieben bestehen. Wie sollten sie auf einem Hebtrieb werden?
Donnerwetter, ja.
Die haben wir nicht. Die alle 24 Stunden. Das ist eine Erfindung der Neuzeit mit dem Reboot, die alle 24 Stunden.
Na ja, das kriegen wir jetzt wohl nicht geklärt, wenn die Aussies und den Wessis, oder was gab es denn für, oder wie nannte man denn so den Westmenschen?
Na die hießen schon Wessis, ja.
Wessler, naja.
Na das meine ich doch, Wessler.
Ja, das war so der Slang und naja, so viel hat man ja auch nicht gesehen, also in Berlin schon eher, aber so im Rest vom Land irgendwie war der doch eher ein seltener Anblick.
Wo kommen die denn so her?
Berlin?
Berlin.
Das wird man auch gleich an der Sprache hören. Es gab kurz nach der Wende irgendwie so eine Karikatur, da war irgendwie so ein Truck von Sielern im Wilden Westen und hinter irgendeinem Bergvorsprung standen irgendwelche Indianer und du hast halt die Sprechblasen da gesehen an den Indianern, stand dann dran Wessler und an dem Planwagen der Trucker da irgendwie dann Oztlar, also so diese Geschichte mit Aussies, Wessis und so eine Konfrontationssache. So war es dann irgendwann, als es offen war, schon. Aber da kommen wir später noch zu, denke ich, wie es dann irgendwann war.
Aber vorher war das irgendwie anders. Also ich meine im Westen, das mag bei manchen auch anders gewesen sein, aber vor allem hat man sich eigentlich mit dem Osten gar nicht so viel beschäftigt. Man hatte da immer seine regelmäßige Unterhaltungssendung, die aktuelle Kamera. Die hat man dann so von Zeit zu Zeit mal eingeschaltet, um sich irgendwie eine amüsante Stunde zu machen. Aber ansonsten war das ja irgendwie dann doch im wahrsten Sinne alles irgendwie hinter einer Mauer. Was seid ihr für Baujahre? Das müssen wir vielleicht nochmal hier einbringen.
71.
68.
So, das heißt, ihr habt das sozusagen das Vorwendegeschehen ja auch alle noch ganz gut mitbekommen. Und wie war das so?
Das ist auch sehr gut so.
Wie war das so in der DDR?
Im Wesentlichen hatte man mehr Zeit.
Man hatte mehr Zeit.
Ja, und zwar so richtig deutlich viel mehr Zeit. Es hat auch einfach mit der Zeit zu tun. Wir blicken auf eine Zeit, in der es irgendwie, keine Ahnung, fünf Fernsehprogramme gab.
Keine Handys?
So, keine Mobiltelefone, keine Pager. Genau, kein Internet, nicht mal Mailboxen. Also in der DDR gab es zwar hier und da ein paar Modem-Experimente, aber richtige Mailboxen oder so gab es halt nicht. Also diese ganze vernetzte Kommunikation war halt nicht da und dementsprechend war halt auch diese ganze Informations-, also informiert sein Business war eine sehr viel mehr persönliche Anlegenheit. Also du hast sehr viel mehr interessante Informationen und persönliche Gespräche bekommen. Die Medien waren halt, naja, da muss man halt irgendwie, also das war für uns halt auch im Wesentlichen Ambitionen, ja, also das war halt irgendwie so, gut, bei irgendwelchen großen Nachrichten, wenn Tscharnobyl war oder so, aber im Wesentlichen haben wir dann halt West-Fernseh geguckt oder Westradio gehört, so, weil im Osten war halt nun ja, die Nachrichten waren halt eher so ein bisschen, ja, dürftig.
Aber wann, ab wann hat man denn das mitbekommen, dass man dem keinen Glauben schenken durfte? Also ich meine, wie real war sozusagen der Verwirrtheitszustand des Staates?
Also die allermeisten Leute im Osten haben sich um den Staat nicht gekümmert. Also die haben sich, also wirklich die allerallermeisten Leute haben sich wieder um Politik noch, um den Staat noch, um irgendwas in dieser Richtung gekümmert, sondern die haben halt in ihrer Privatheit-Nische gelebt und sich da irgendwie eingerichtet so und haben halt irgendwie gesoffen und gefögelt und irgendwie, was man sonst noch so tut im Leben.
Außer sie mussten sich eben damit beschäftigen. Also zum Beispiel beim ersten Mai, wenn dann irgendwie die Abteilung sowieso jetzt mal wieder die festgelegten Demonstrationsteilnehmerzahlen bringen musste, dann wurde halt der Kollege sowieso delegiert, morgen zur Demonstration zu gehen oder so und dann mussten sie sich halt mit all diesen Sachen beschäftigen.
Aber das war auch dann mehr so eine Ritual-Affüllung und also kritisch war das halt erst, wurde das halt erst so verlangt von dir, dass du dich damit befasst war, wenn du was werden wolltest. Also wenn du halt irgendwie nicht doof warst und irgendwie studieren wolltest oder halt irgendwie sonst irgendwie irgendwas mit dir anfangen wolltest und nicht halt irgendwie dein Leben irgendwie mit einer Flasche schlechten Wodka vergammeln wolltest, dann haben sie schon von dir erwartet, dass du dich darum kümmerst und dann fing die Indoktrination auch schon relativ früh an. Aber ich war halt in meiner Schulzeit, war ich halt Agitator in meiner Klasse. Ach du auch? Ja, das blieb halt nicht aus. Also Agitator war halt so eine Funktion in der Klasse, dafür zu sorgen, dass die Klasse politisch informiert bleibt und dann zu verteilen, wer regelmäßig, also wer die Wandzeit umzumachen hat über irgendein Thema und dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Da wird man dann offiziell als Agitator gewählt oder bestimmt?
Gewählt, war natürlich so ein...
Aus der Klasse heraus, ganz demokratisch.
Ganz demokratisch, genau.
Du bist Agitator geworden.
Den Gruppenrat, ja, lag mir wohl nahe, glaub ich. Ich hab auch mal in der sechsten Klasse den Berliner Agitatoren-Preis gewonnen im Wettbewerb. Aber kurz danach bin ich auch ein bisschen zynischer geworden, glaube ich.
Aber was heißt denn das? Ist man dann schon irgendwie im Establishment? Hat man sich dann irgendwie schon so mit der schlimmen Sache so gemeingemacht, dass man danach eigentlich gehängt werden muss?
Naja, das Problem ist diese schlimme Sache, also wo zieht man halt die Grenzen? Also du lebst halt in einem Gesellschaftssystem und so wie hier, irgendwie ein Frevel ist, die Marktwirtschaft in Frage zu stellen, weil das ist ja nun mal die geheiligte Sache, der man halt sich irgendwie...
Die soziale Marktwirtschaft fragt.
Die soziale Marktwirtschaft, genau, so wenig hat man halt einfach die... Also wenn man sich damit nicht kritisch was einleitet, so wenig hat man halt irgendwie in seiner Jugend halt irgendwie dann das politische System da in Frage gestellt. Das fing halt eigentlich erst dann bei den kleinen Sachen an, dass er im Zeugs erzählt haben, was offensichtlich nicht stimmte, dass man irgendwie das Maul halten sollte über Sachen, die irgendwie ähnlich in den Kram passten, dass irgendwie man gesehen hat, dass Statistiken gefälscht wurden, zum Beispiel bei der Altstoff-Sammlung. Altstoff sammeln kennt man heutzutage gar nicht mehr so, aber es stimmte halt einen wesentlichen Teil der Jugendfreizeit im Osten, loszugehen und halt Altstoffe zu sammeln. Nee, prima Flaschen, Flaschenpapier und Schrott. Schrott war am effizientesten, weil das hat am meisten Geld gebracht.
Also wohl gemerkt, man hat da Sachen hingebracht und hat dafür Geld bekommen. Es ist also nicht so, dass man das jetzt in die Tonne tut, in die Wertstoff-Sammeltonne oder in die Papiertonne, sondern es gab Geld dafür. Das heißt, du konntest halt sogar, wir haben dann irgendwann, ich glaube, in der 6. angefangen, Ageboten zu sammeln oder Eicheln zu sammeln, die man natürlich nicht zur Sekundärrohstoffverwertung gebracht hat, sondern zum Förster oder zu anderen Sammelstellen. Du konntest Kamille sammeln oder Hopfen sammeln, das ist zur Apotheke gebracht worden und dort verkaufen die Eicheln und die Kastanen.
Aber da würde man dazu angehalten, das zu tun, oder wie? Nee, das war einfach so eine Idee.
Also es gab halt zwei Systeme. Das eine war in der Schule, da gab es halt die Altstoff-Sammellei als Wettbewerbselement. Also da musste es da halt irgendwie so ein gewisses Kontingent mitbringen. Da hat man natürlich immer das Zeug mit hingebracht, was halt nicht so viel Geld gebracht hat.
Das war was?
Naja, ich glaube, Papier hat aber nicht so viel gebracht.
War das mal mit Altpapier in die Schule gelatscht, oder was?
Ja, so einmal.
Tagessetung, Kinderbindel.
Genau.
Und was haben die dann damit gemacht?
Papier. Also es war halt tatsächlich ein richtig großes System des Recyclings.
An den Schulen selbst.
Das war nur eine Sammelstelle. Also das wurde dann natürlich regelmäßig irgendwo abgeholt. Aber natürlich gab es immer irgendwo Kellerräume, wo ein Monat lang für irgendetwas Platz war. Und dann kam irgendwann der dreieinhalb oder siebenhalb Tonner und hat das abgeholt.
Verstehe. Genau, und das funktionierte dann so, dass das Geld, was dann dafür gut geschrieben wurde, ging dann an die Solidarität. Also für irgendwie Kuba oder... Mozambique oder was auch immer. Und das war dann halt das Wettbewerbsziel der Schule, war halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 200 Mark oder so im Jahr für Mozambique zusammenzukratzen. Und dann gab es dann halt noch so Altstoff-Sammeldrives, wenn es halt irgendwie ein bisschen knapp wurde. Aber die meisten Leute haben dann, wenn sie sich irgendwie dieses Hobby schon mal zugelegt hatten, mit dem Altstoff sammeln, dann haltet doch lieber zum Zero gebracht und das Geld selber eingesteckt.
Zero ist dieser Sekundär-Rosstoff-Handel. Das waren halt genau diese Stellen, wo man das normalerweise hingebracht hat und ist, wie es ich finde, ein Kilopapier irgendwie 40 Pfennig gekriegt hat. Für wenige?
Für 9 Pfennige oder so.
9 Pfennige? Ach, ich weiß es nicht mehr. Mistverdammt, Alter.
Nee, das war also wirklich wenig für Papier. Schrott hingegen war relativ effizient. Also insbesondere, als sie dann angefangen haben, das Gassystem umzustellen. Es war ja so, dass Ostberlin lief ja auf Stadtgas, also auf einem Kohle-basierten Gas. Und das war relativ feucht und sehr giftig. Und deswegen haben sie das irgendwann umgestellt, als dann die Erdgas-Pipeline aus der Sowjetunion da war, die Freundschaftspipeline, wurde Berlin umgestellt auf Erdgas. Und bei der Gelegenheit flogen halt überall die Herde raus. Und dann standen halt die Straßen voll mit Herden. Immer da, wo sie sozusagen gerade die Straße umgestellt haben, haben sie halt die Herde rausgerissen und abgestellt. Und wenn man dann fix war, konnte man sich halt den Bundmetall-Anteil aus dem Herd ausbauen. Meistens halt die Fühler, also die Bimetall-Fühler, oder was sonst noch so an etwas wertigeren Metallen war und dann in seinen alten Kinderwahn geladen und dahin gekarrt.
Für Glas gab es relativ viel, kann ich mich jetzt entzünden. Also jenseits von Pfandflaschen, praktisch jedes Glas wurde verwertet. Du konntest natürlich Bruchglas dahin bringen und was weiß ich, solche Sachen. Das ist interessant, was du gerade sagst, mit diesem selber den Transporter dahin zu organisieren. Also einerseits kennzeichnet die DDR ja irgendwie so den Vorwurf der Mangelwirtschaft. Und jetzt sieht man an so Sachen natürlich ziemlich genau, es waren keine Autostar, die diese Sachen dann dort hingebracht haben zum Sekundär-Rustaufhandel. Also haben die Leute das natürlich gemacht, weil sie sich damit noch eine kleine Marke verdienen konnten.
Heute nennt man das Crowdsourcing.
So ist es, ganz genau. Der Staat hat es also sozusagen in seine Infrastruktur rein sublimiert, dass die Leute sowieso etwas machen wollten oder gar mussten, weil es halt vorne und hinten nicht erreicht hat. Da so kann man Staatswesen natürlich rufbauen.
Die Verkehrsmangel, das ist ja auch so eine der Sachen, die ich wirklich erstaunlich fand. Also so die unfassbare Abwesenheit von Fahrzeugen im Vergleich zum besten.
Also das Interessante war, das war halt langsamer. Wenn du von A nach B wolltest, hast du dafür Zeit eingeplant, weil entweder bist du Fahrrad gefahren oder öffentliche Verkehrsmittel. Und die funktionierten halt okay. Also es war jetzt irgendwie nicht richtig scheiße. Es war auch nicht richtig gut, aber es ging halt so meistens. Man kam schon da hin, wo man hin wollte. Aber wenn du nach Thüringen wolltest, warst du halt einen Tag unterwegs, mit Bummelzug und Umsteigen und noch einen Bus und so. Dann die Ostsee, da hast du eigentlich auch meistens so einen halben Tag zugebracht, bis du da warst. Also nicht mal eben wie jetzt mal schnell in den Regional-Express hüpfen und dann drei Stunden später bist du an der Strasse. Das war dann doch ein bisschen länglicher. Wohl gut, die Strecke ausgerechnet, die ging, weil die war gut ausgebaut. Dementsprechend gab ja auch Telefon, war ja eine Sache, die relativ limitiert war. Es gab halt kaum Telefonleitungen. Und wenn, dann waren die meistens geteilt. Also mit diesen lustigen Gums, diesen Umschaltern. Na ja, ein Gerät, um eine Telefonleite zu splitten.
Was heißt denn Gum?
Du hast ein Gerät umschaltern. Was das Ding tut, ist halt, wenn du den Hörer abnimmst, bei dir, dann ist die Leitung bei dir. Und dann kann der andere halt auch nicht angerufen werden und auch nicht telefonieren.
Und wenn er abnimmt, kriegt er?
Nichts.
Eine Totenleitung.
Lichtsausschuss, dann Haltstelle. Und auf den Dörfern haben sie das teilweise mit Zehnergums gemacht. Also da waren dann Zehnanschlüsse an einer Leitung. Und dann haben die sich lustige Tabellen gemacht, wer dann telefonieren darf und so. Aber hat noch relativ wenige Leute telefoniert. Es war halt so, dass man ist zu Leuten zum Telefonieren gegangen, wenn man kein Telefon hatte. Und das führt aber auch dazu, dass man sehr viel spontaner einfach losging und irgendwie, wenn man Leute besuchen wollte, man sich einfach irgendwie losgeschwungen und ist vorbeigegangen. Und jeder hatte eigentlich einen Notizblock an der Tür, so um eine Nachricht hinzuhinterlassen, wenn man gerade irgendwie niemanden angetroffen hat, so, okay, ich war gerade da, okay, komm nochmal vorbei oder ruf mal an, weil ich dich nicht finde.
Das war sozusagen der Anrufbeantworter.
Ja, der Anrufbeantworter war der Notizblock an der Tür. Das ging auch, das hat man tatsächlich dann auch noch ziemlich weit nach der Wende gesehen, wo es ja in Ostberlin immer noch nicht so richtig Telefon gab. Da konnte man dann die zugezogenen Wessis erkennen. Die hatten dann keinen Notizblock an der Tür, weil die waren so richtig.
So eine Sache gab es nämlich ab und an, dass man so eine Registrierkassenrollen hinter dieser Bleistift durchsteht.
Das musste man auch erstmal verstehen und so. Also Telefon war ja nun Ende der 80er Jahre einfach schon überall da. Ja, und Mobilfunk war jetzt auch noch nicht so da, aber auch Anrufbeantworter sahen schon so langsam ihren Einzug in die Privatsphäre und von daher war das einfach echt merkwürdig.
Solche Kommunikationsmedien wie ein Telefon sind natürlich ausschließlich für den individuellen privaten Bereich sozusagen. Solche Sachen stehen in einem realsozialistischen Staat, will ich es mal nennen, nicht in vorderster Tagesordnung. Da geht es darum, das Gemeinwesen auszubauen, das geht also darum, die öffentliche Infrastruktur auszubauen, den öffentlichen Personennahverkehr oder irgendwelche Transporten, Netze, entzinnere mich an diese, wie heißt es, die Erdgas- und Erdölfördertrasse und diese Aktionen. Solche Aktionen oder über Land-Stromleitungen sind Sachen, die sind durch die Presse jagen. Das war ganz wichtig, dass da jetzt eine 220-KV- oder 380-KV-Leitung durch diese Gebiet geht.
Also Infrastruktur war noch sehr viel präsenter als Challenge. Das war nicht so wie, hups, hier haben wir jetzt gerade mal so einen neuen Staudamm und irgendwie ein Minister erst bei der Öffnung, sondern das war dann so jahrelang irgendwie, das Kollektiv hat jetzt wieder irgendwie eine neue Fuhre Sand und so. Das war halt richtig so Topic in den...
Wurde alles gefeiert.
Dadurch, dass du die Leute mit einer öffentlichen Wahrnehmung, also durch die Berichterstattung, daran auch teilnehmen lässt, ist das natürlich auch so ein Ding, wo jeder für sich sagen kann, naja, irgendeinen Teil werden wir daran ja haben. Wenn wir keine Südfrüchte nächsten Winter wieder haben, dann wissen wir wieso. Dann geht das halt jetzt in diese Talsperre. Neulich hat irgendjemand gesagt, am Ende jeder Nachrichtensendung gab es immer irgendwas Gutes. Dieses große Feldgebiet ist jetzt wieder abgeerntet und da ist der Mais eingebracht worden.
Also zur Erntezeit war stundenlang, gab es irgendwie Reportagen aus den LPGs, mit irgendwie, was sie wieder für Herausforderungen hatten und wie sie den Plan über erfüllt hatten. Damit haben die richtig Zeit zugebracht. Das Problem war halt, also eigentlich denkt man ja, so Lokalnews ist ja manchmal ganz lustig und spannend, das Problem war, dass sie das halt so formalisiert haben. Also du konntest dann schon vorhersehen, was als Nächstes kommt. Was dann als Nächstes sagt. Jetzt kommt der Schnitt auf den Mähdrescher, dann kommt der Schnitt auf den Brigadier, dann kommt irgendwie der Schnitt auf den vollen Getreidesilo so und dann kommt irgendwie wieder der Nachrichtensprecher. Also diese Ritualisierung, schon bis in die Schnittfolge rein, war halt irgendwie so, dass die müssen das im Schlaf gemacht haben, da mit halb zugekniffenen Augen, so schneid mal. Da passiert ja dann halt auch optisch nichts. Es gab halt keine Überraschungen in dem Sinne. Das war halt, also Überraschungen waren halt negativ konnotiert. Ja und noch ein...
LPG, also LPG ist die Landwirtschaftliche Produktionsgenossenschaft. Ja, das war ja auch immer alles so kollektiviert. Also wie präsent war denn überhaupt so privatwirtschaftliches? Es gab ja auch so den kleinen Gemüseladen und so. Den hat doch auch ein Einzelner geführt oder waren auch die auf der Ebene alle kollektiv?
Also richtig Privatbetriebe gab es eigentlich nur im Handwerk. So als Schwestern und so was. Im Präsent. Und selbst die waren in der Regel dann in so genannten PGHs organisiert, so genannten Produktionsgenossenschaften des Handwerks, wo man dann halt mehr oder minder zwangsweise Mitglied war oder so. Und also gerade die ganzen Läden und so, die waren in der Regel mehr, ja, irgendwelchen Handelsorganisationen, also entweder HO oder Konsum oder was gab es noch?
Gab es noch irgendetwas anderes?
Die Gemüse-Läden waren noch häufig noch irgendetwas anderes, total gefeiert, oder was war das?
Globus war so ein, nee, quatsch, das war diese ungarische Marke, Eingereckter Paprikas, klar.
Also Delikat gab es noch als Handelsorganisation, genau da gab es dann irgendwie so ein bisschen Luxusgüter.
Das war ja dann auch alles schon kurz vorm Ende.
Oder Intershop.
Na, das ist ja nur noch ganz eigene Qualität von Sachen gewesen, ja, das stimmt. Ja, mit der Privatgeschäfte ist jetzt so eine Sache, in den 50er-Jahren oder Ende der 40er-Jahre, als die Bauern dazu gedrängt wurden, sich dann in den LPG zusammenzuschließen. Und ja, man hat da vielleicht mal ab und an Filme gesehen, dass der Gustav noch nicht so entschlossen ist und seine Kollegen, ehemalige Bauern überzeugen ihn jetzt, und jetzt wird er doch Mitglied der LPG werden. Und das ist doch zu seinem Vorteil, die Traktoren können doch alle verwenden. Und wenn einer eine Spezialmaschine hat, darf das doch der andere verwenden und so weiter. Na ja, natürlich lief das darauf hinaus, dass den Leuten das Land erstmal weggenommen wird und sie letztlich Lohnarbeiter auf ehemals ihrem eigenen Land werden. Und das haben natürlich einige durchschaut und je nachdem, welchen Widerstand sie dem entgegengesetzt haben, desto mehr Repressionen haben sie natürlich erlitten. Nun sind das Dinge, die sind vor meiner Zeit, das habe ich also so auch nur erzählt bekommen. Ich habe später die Sachen im Handwerk miterlebt, wie also Firmen, die sich zum Beispiel seltene Maschinen aus der Tschechoslowakei zum Beispiel bestellt haben, für Werkzeugherstellung oder so weiter. Wie also das natürlich durch das Außenhaltsministerium oder durch die entsprechenden Wirtschaftsstellen registriert wurde und die natürlich wussten, was jetzt in diesem noch bis dahin privaten Betrieb für eine Maschine stand oder so. Und dann entsprechende Anfragen kamen. Wir wissen, dass sie so eine Rede haben. Wir haben aber das Planziel sowieso für die Region, das und das zu schaffen. Und da sind wir darauf angewiesen, dass auch diese Maschine damit zu verwendet wird. Wie stehen sie dazu? Und deshalb, um das herauszufinden, werden wir uns mal mit Ihnen zu einem Gespräch treffen. Eine Woche später ist der Parteikreter des Ortes vorbei gekommen und dann noch der, ach was weiß ich, da gab es dann verschiedene Chargen. Und meistens immer noch einer, der nicht vorgestellt wurde.
Der saß so rum.
Der saß so da.
Und verhinderte, dass die Decke runterfiel.
Ja, diese Privatisierung, das ist eine komische Sache. So ein Privateigentum an Produktionsmitteln ist ein Merkmal des Kapitalismus. Und es ist nichts sein kann, was nicht sein darf sozusagen. Das ist ein zentraler Ding dabei, wenn du dich, sagen wir mal, relativ unauffällig verhalten hast. Ich hatte zwei Klassenkameraden, deren Eltern hatten einen Betrieb. Wenn die also zu sagen für das Volkswohl gearbeitet haben, also zum Beispiel Medizintechnik hergestellt haben, was an der Charité verwendet wurde, dann gab es keine Frage. Dann ist das ein Betrieb gewesen, der ist einfach volkswirtschaftlich wichtig gewesen. Egal wie klein der gewesen ist, dann wurde so ein Ding natürlich nicht gefährdet. Na ja, bei anderen Sachen sah es dann schon wieder anders aus. Je nachdem, wie viel man von denen wollte, oder wenn die Leute außerdem noch Westverwandtschaft hatten, oder irgendwie sich im, es gab ja auch in der DDR neben der SED andere Parteien, so wie die LDPDs zum Beispiel, die Ostliberalen, die Handwerker.
Die sogenannten Blockflöten.
Die Block, später sogenannten Blockflöten, genau. Und wenn man sich dann sozusagen als lokaler Handwerker in so was stark gemacht hat, dann ist man denke ich mal für die entsprechenden Stellen auch eher interessant geworden. Dann haben die geguckt, was hat denn der jetzt für einen Grund sich zu engagieren? Kriegt der nicht schon genügend Geld? Hat der nicht schon genügend Privilegien oder so? Das alles führt dir ja noch nicht dazu, dass du dann zu Weihnachten mehr Apfelsinen bekommen hast. Du hast halt auch nur das Angebot gehabt, weil du den Konsum eben hier habt, oder? Ich hab.
Na ja, und dazu kamen dann natürlich auch noch diese Mechanismen, die sie dann halt hatten. Der Steuer zum Beispiel. Also dass hier halt, wenn niemand nicht wollte, dann gab es halt eine richtige Steuerprüfung. Du konntest halt Handwerker im Osten. Ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendjemand steuerärlich gearbeitet hat. Das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt wie hier mit den Baufirmen so, ja. Und da gab es dann halt auch immer Mittel und Wege, dich zur Kooperation zu drängen, wenn du dich dann zu weit rausgesteckt hast. Und deswegen war halt so viel halt auch so privat. Also war halt so, dass irgendwie so viel halt unter der Hand gemacht wurde, dass irgendwie sich gegenseitig geholfen wurde.
Also privat nicht im Sinne privatwirtschaftlich, sondern eigentlich so jenseits.
Also halt nicht im offiziellen Wirtschaftskreislauf, sondern halt...
Was man heute Schwarz nennt.
Ja, aber auch nicht nur Schwarz im Sinne für Geld, sondern eben auch sich gegenseitig zu helfen, sodass man halt einfach offizielle Strukturen nicht in Anspruch nehmen musste.
Das ist ein wichtiger Unterschied. Wenn Geld nicht konvertibel ist, dann nützt dir das Geld dafür, was du bekommst oder bekommen könntest, überhaupt nicht.
Man hat sich einfach mehr geholfen.
Ja, weil das war halt auch einfach sehr sinnvoll wirtschaftlich, weil wenn du was konntest, was andere Leute interessant fanden, dann hattest du Zugriff auf deren Handwerkskraft oder was auch immer. Und so, wie es halt heute immer noch im Land ist, wenn der Bauer ein Dach decken will, dann ruft er halt seine Kumpels an und deckt mit denen ein Dach. Und wenn einer von denen mal ein Dach decken will, dann hilft er bei dem halt, mit dem Dach zu decken. Das ist halt so der typische Modus operandi gewesen, in dem Moment, wo die Leute anfingen gierig zu werden und dann zum Beispiel für irgendwelche seltenen Dienstleistungen Westgeld zu nehmen. In dem Augenblick waren sie dann auch schon mal wieder relativ gefährdet so, also in dem Sinn, dass sie dann halt Aufmerksamkeit erregten und dann von der Stasi halt irgendwie oder wie man auch immer in Beobachtung kam. Und deswegen haben die Leute halt alle versucht, sich möglichst so…
rauszuhalten aus dem Wirtschaftsbetrieb.
Ja, genau. Also es gab halt kein echtes Incentive, außer du wolltest halt wirklich so. Und dann wusstest du aber dann auch am Ende, was du dafür riskierst im Sinne, dass du halt dich dann entweder mit denen kooperieren musst oder halt dir ein dickes Feld zulegen musst.
Aber Essen kaufen, das hat man natürlich trotzdem gemacht. Supermärkte, haben wir ja schon angesprochen, was gab es so Schönes? Den Konsum?
Na, es gab halt Konsum, Kaufhalle und HO.
Und wie waren die drei so positioniert?
Na, Kaufhallen waren halt so Supermärkte, die waren halt meistens von HO oder Konsum betrieben. Und das sind halt diese alten Klötzer, die man heute immer noch so kennt. Das ist aber meistens so ein Spar oder so drin, das ist manchmal auch ein Kaisers.
Ja, die sind Kaisers, die haben es ja gekauft.
Und Konsum war halt tatsächlich aus der alten Konsumorganisation entstanden. Das heißt, da gab es noch diese Konsummarken, die man für jeden Einkauf, den du da getätigt hast, bekamst du halt so kleine Klebemarken.
Was war das mit die alten Konsum?
Na, die entstanden aus der Konsumbewegung, die ja irgendwie in, keine Ahnung, 20er oder so was entstanden ist.
Oh, das kann gut sein. Da wusste ich gar nicht, wie lange das zurückreicht.
Pré, DDR.
Ja, also die Idee dabei war halt so, heute würde man sagen Rabattmarken, ja? Du bekommst halt, ich glaube, zwei Prozent oder ein Prozent oder so von deinem Einkauf bekommst du also eine Konsummarken und dann kannst du die am Jahr auszahlen lassen, also so ein Leu-Etatsprinzip-Ding. Davon gab es halt verschiedenste Abwandlungen. Und das war halt das eine, das andere war halt HO, das stand für Handelsorganisation. Und das war halt so mehr so das staatliche Ding. Die Konsums waren meistens noch so ein bisschen, also manchmal noch so ein bisschen liebevoller. Also da haben die sich manchmal noch so ein bisschen gekümmert, irgendwie Kram ran zu kriegen und HO war halt so rein raus, halt so, also einfach nur so, die saßen da halt nur. So und dann, das war denen so scheißegal, ob jetzt der Kram vergammelt ist oder nicht oder ob die Milchtüten jetzt noch dicht waren oder nicht. Die Konsum waren immer noch so ein bisschen, so meistens auf dem Dorf zum Beispiel war es halt häufiger so, dass es noch Konsum war, der sogenannte Dorfkonsum, der kommt halt da her und in der Stadt war es halt so Hälfte, Hälfte so und man hat halt immer versucht, dass man sich so im Lauf- oder Fahrradreich weiter halt so mehrere Läden hatte und die man dann so für seinen Einkauf so abgeklappert hat, damit man halt irgendwie alle so zusammen bekam. In Berlin ging es eigentlich meistens auch nur so, auf dem Land war es auch schon ein bisschen drastischer teilweise. Da muss man dann schon eher ein bisschen weiterfahren oder sich einsortieren, dass wenn einer in der Stadt arbeitet, dass der dann halt so Sachen mitbringt und so.
Stimmt es, dass an den Grenzen Berlin so Schilder standen, wo EDV drauf stand?
Da habe ich mal gehört.
Sagt euch das irgendwas?
Nee, wofür soll das stehen oder was?
Ich weiß nicht, wofür es wirklich stand, wenn es die überhaupt gab. Ich habe nur gehört, dass es welche gab und die den Gemeinden als Ende der Versorgung interpretiert wurden. Habe ich, glaube ich, mal in Leipzig gehört. Deswegen weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, ob das nicht einfach nur so eine lebende Legende war.
Würde ich vermuten. Also gerade in Sachsen sind die Legenden über Berlin sehr vielfältige. Also das ist halt so, dass die traditionelle preuß-sächsische Animosität hat da irgendwie auch ihre…
Ich muss die Sendung sozusagen nochmal machen mit Sachsen.
Nee, das muss man schon sagen. Da war schon, was die Versorgung angeht, halt irgendwie etwas privilegierter. Also hier gab es halt schon durchaus mal Hamilch und Cornflakes und so. Das halt irgendwie woanders echt schwierig war. Und Obst und Gemüse und so war halt in Berlin auch tatsächlich vorhanden gelegentlich so. Also durchaus zwar jetzt nicht ihr riesiger Ausfall, aber ging dann halt so. Und woanders war ja gerade richtig auf dem Land draußen, war halt nicht, da muss es sicher, dann muss es den Gemüse halt beim Bauern besorgen.
Aber warum war es denn diesen HO-Leuten so egal?
Also sie konnten ja eh nichts ändern. Es gab halt genau das, was es gab und das war es dann. Und wenn es das nicht mehr gab, dann waren die Regale halt leer. Da gab es, kannst du dich an diese 1000 Tele-Tipps erinnern, in der DDR gab es Werbesendungen. Da war irgendwann so dieser Weißkohl so gesund und als der Weißkohl in alle war, war das dieses Rotkohl so gesund. Also es ist das selbe.
Also das war tatsächlich so ein bisschen problematisch. Also gerade wie gesagt, in Berlin kann man eigentlich nicht meckern. Es gab auch ordentliche Bäcker, das muss man mal sagen. Irgendwie nicht nur irgendwie diese Aufblasverbrecher von heute, sondern richtige Bäcker, die halt irgendwie ordentliche Brote und ordentliche Brötchen gebacken haben.
Da gibt es auch in der Mitte irgendwie noch so einen Laden, ne?
Es gibt noch ein paar. Zum Beispiel in Prenzlauer Berg, zum Beispiel direkt neben Stagado Bühl, der Bäcker Hacker. Der ist auch noch so ein richtiger Bäcker Hacker, so richtiger Bäcker.
Ja, das ist noch ein richtiger Hacker Bäcker, so zu sagen.
Also interessant ist auch bei diesen Bäckern, dass die sich eigentlich immer teilt haben, unterteilt haben in Brotbäcker und Kuchenbäcker. Also die haben zwar immer beides gehabt, aber es gab Bäcker, da musste man nach zwei Versuchen den Kuchen, lasst ihn da lieber liegen, aber der hat super Brot und Brötchen. Und dann gab es die Bäcker, die hatten zwar auch Brot und Brötchen, aber die lässt man lieber da und nimmt nur den Kuchen.
Also die eigentliche Unterscheidung zwischen Bäcker und Konditor, ne?
Naja, klar, aber die mussten halt beides haben, weil vor Sortiment und so. Aber interessant war halt auch, dass die öffentliche Infrastruktur sich ja mehr so auf Vertrauen beruht. Also ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel die Straßenbahnen. Ich glaube die Busse auch noch eine Weile. Die Fahrkarten und Automaten, die es da gab, hast du sie noch mal gesehen?
Ich kann mich noch erinnern, ich bin irgendwann mal der U-Bahn gefahren und es bestand im Wesentlichen daraus, dass man so eine Kette von Zetteln aus so einem Automaten einfach rauszog.
Weil man den Hebel gar nicht mehr bedient hat, die kam eh von alleine.
Ja, genau.
Man hat doch gar keine gekauft, sondern man hat sich einfach welche genommen.
Genau, das war interessant, das war sozusagen nur durch Transparenz. Also in der Straßenbahn funktioniert das noch halbwegs gut, weil du hast halt deine Münze da reingeworfen.
Hast du dieses Schauglas mit diesen sechs oder acht Fächern Unterteilung?
Genau.
Du hast die letzten Bezahlvorgänge gesehen.
Also es gab dann halt da drin so einen Rotor, der mehrere Fächer hatte, da fiel deine Münze rein in ein Fach. Und das war sichtbar. Das war sozusagen einer Seite Glas, so dass du sehen konntest, was da reingeworfen wurde. Und dann hast du halt da dein Geld reingeworfen und dann in den Automaten gezogen, um dir dann den Zettelabriss da rauszubekommen.
Das war sozusagen soziale Kontrolle. Man hat einfach darauf gesetzt, dass die Leute schon das Richtige reinschmeißen. Das ist auch heute noch in Toronto so, in der Straßenbahn.
In München funktioniert das ja auch mit den Zeitungen.
Ja, wobei es sind andere Beträge. Also für die Straßenbahnfahrt, da musst du aber auch wirklich schon so mehr Euro teilweise da reinwerfen und irgendwie trotzdem... Hauptsache es klingelt irgendwie richtig und so. Das ist völlig absurd.
Ihr findet das total toll eigentlich. Eigentlich sollte öffentliche Infrastruktur ja genauso betrieben werden. Also de facto ist es ja ein Spendenprinzip mit ein bisschen sozialer Kontrolle.
Aber nochmal beim Essen zu bleiben. Restaurants waren ja auch dann vom selben Mangel...
Draußen nur Kenntchen.
Draußen nur Kenntchen. Sie werden platziert.
Genau, sie werden platziert. Das war dann so eins meiner Erlebnisse. Es war halt auch so wirklich diese klassische Hammernicht-Situation. Man kriegt da halt irgendwie so eine Karte, da standen so verschiedene Sachen drauf. Aber eigentlich gibt es das gar nicht.
Ich war im Osten originale höchst selten in Restaurants mit meinen Eltern oder so. Sehr populär waren halt diese Selbstbedienungsteile, weil da eben genau diese ganze, sie werden platziert, Ideologie halt nicht stattfand. Sondern das halt so Kantinen-Style mit irgendwie Tablett vorbeischieben und nehmen und vorne bezahlen Geschichten war. Und das war eigentlich der größere Teil der Versorgungseinrichtungen, also der öffentlichen S-Einrichtungen, waren halt irgendwie solche Dinge. Also entweder in den Urlaubsgebieten halt, da haben die meisten Leute ja in so einer FDGB-Heimurlaub gemacht und in Betriebsferien-Einrichtungen. Also FDGB stand für Freier Deutscher Gewerkschaftsbund. Und das waren ja so meistens so eine großen Betonbogen oder halt so Bungalowfelder. Und da gab es dann halt so Essenszeiten, wo dann halt dich zum Essen einzufinden hattest. Also dann der Essenszeit-Slot war halt von irgendwie 18, 15 bis 19 Uhr. So und dann bist du dann dahin gegangen, hat das dann so unterschiedlich bunte Pappkärtchen für irgendwie deine Essenszeit, die du dann halt vorne vorgezeigt hast. Und dann gab es dann halt da so, naja, Buffet, würde man heute sagen. Und dann hast du da halt ja dein Essen besorgt. Und dann jeweils zum Wechsel der Essensslot-Zeiten wurde dann das Buffet erneuert. So, das war halt dann so sozusagen so die Einteilung, mit der sie halt halt die Massen bewältigt bekommen haben. Und das Prinzip ist eigentlich auch in ganz Osteuropa so, dass extrem viele Restaurants, auch zum Balticum oder Polen oder so, waren halt so eine Selbstbildungs-Dinger und so. Und richtige Restaurants mit hinsetzten und Kellner kommt und Karte und so eine Sache waren deutlich selten halt so und die hatten, waren auch nicht viele. Also hingegen so, also sowas wie so Boiler-Beratereien gab es halt auch viele. Aber das war halt auch genau wieder dieses Selbstbildungsprinzip. So gehst halt da hin, holst ja dein Boiler, setzt dich hin. So das war halt so diese Kantine-Style war eigentlich so der DINORM und so Restaurant mit irgendwie Kellner und so war halt eigentlich eher so die Ausnahme. Was doch damit zu tun hatte, dass sich niemand, also wenn du Hunger hast, dann willst du eigentlich nicht nur noch zwei Stunden rumstehen, bis der Kellner mal so genährlich ist, dich an einen von den 50 leeren Tischen zu setzen.
Was ich ja so erstaunlich finde, ist, dass das so dem Osten so über die Zeit einfach übergestürpt wurde. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt so zurückschaut, DDR hat gerade mal 40 Jahre gelebt, das ist ja so viel Zeit eigentlich gar nicht. Also klar, das ist jetzt schon ein signifikanter Teil, aber dass sich dann eben so die Kultur dann auch wirklich so massiv in so eine Richtung bewegen lässt, wo es doch ja auch schon mal ganz anders gelaufen ist. Ich meine, Deutschland war natürlich jetzt ein Sonderfall, diese Kriegssituation vorher ist ohnehin einiges zerstört worden und gerade in diese Verirrung ließ sich natürlich der eine oder andere Wahnsinn noch implantieren, weil es mit dem Wahnsinn vorher dann auch schon eigentlich mehr zu vergleichen war. Trotzdem ging es ja auch schon mal anders. Also was mich zum Beispiel immer so gefragt hat, ist so diese lauernde Ineffizienz in allem. Das muss doch eigentlich der Gesellschaft auch bewusst gewesen sein. Das Handwerk, das geht ja nun auch weit zurück und dann wird es genug alte Leute gegeben haben, die es auch anders kann.
Diese Sache mit der Ineffizienz, wir hatten das vorhin mit den Erntezielen. Und jetzt hat die LPG sowieso wieder ihr Feld abgeerntet, was dann sogar bis in die Nachrichten sich Wort gebracht hat. Da gab es so einen alten Witz, dass der Staatsratsvorsitzende dann wissen will, wie viele Schweine denn produziert werden. Und dann wird natürlich auf unterster Ebene angefragt. Und dann fragt der Ortsvorsitzende, Bauer, wie viele haben wir denn eigentlich? Und dann wissen wir, wir haben zwei Schweine. Ja, wir haben zwei Schweine gemacht. Er meldet seinen Bezirkssekretär, wir haben zehn Schweine. Und man stelle sich das über mehrere Ebenen vor. Und zum Schluss wurde die Zahl dann irgendwie, naja, wie man das in Witzen so macht, den kann ich nicht mehr ganz genau sagen. Dann wurden halt die dreifache Anzahl daraus.
Klingt nach Snafu-Prinzip.
Ja, Peter-Prinzip oder was auch immer. All diese Dinge. Umso mehr du, umso älter du wirst, umso mehr du aus bestimmten Sachen solche Beobachtungen entweder selber machst oder mitgeteilt bekommst. Dass irgendjemand, der eine tolle Idee hatte, der in seinem Betrieb versuchen wollte, diese oder jene Sache zu verbessern oder so. Und das aber jetzt nicht als Neura-Vorschlag mit 120 Ostmark und einem weichen Händedruck vergütet wurde und da gleich produktionswirksam wurde, sondern der einfach abgebügelt wurde, von dem brauchen wir nicht. Oder hat der große Bruder, also die Sowjetunion, sowieso schon entwickelt. Und so eine Maschine kriegen wir im nächsten Jahr. Aber nur bedulde dich mal noch und bleib mal noch in unserer Firma hier. Wenn Leuten häufig solche Dinge passieren, dann haben sie irgendwann natürlich keine Lust mehr, sich zu engagieren. Und so ist es sicherlich auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr vielen Leuten passiert einfach.
Das Problem war eigentlich die Frechie?
Nee, das Problem war einfach, dass die Art und Weise, wie individuelles Engagement frustriert wurde, war halt systemisch. Du hast es halt einmal, zwei Mal probiert. Und dann stellt es sich halt raus, dass es für dich persönlich nichts bringt. Und dann hast du es halt gelassen. Es gab halt ja noch immer wieder eine Menge Versuche, immer mal wieder so kampagnenartig das irgendwie so ein bisschen anzukurbeln. Also zum Beispiel die Neurobewegung oder die Rationalisierungsbewegung waren halt so Sachen. Also da ging es halt darum, in den Betrieben zu sagen, wo können wir dann noch irgendwie mit einfach ein bisschen nachdenken und vielleicht ein bisschen ein paar Abläufe ändern oder so, noch ein bisschen mehr Effizienz rauskitzeln. Und bei der Rationalisierungsbewegung dann halt eben darum, mehr Roboter-Fu oder was auch immer zu machen. Und das war dann halt teilweise extrem absurd. Also dann war halt der Plan, wir müssen fünf Roboter haben in den Betrieb und das führte dann halt dazu, dass die sich halt, weil es halt keine Roboter gab und sie auch keine zuguteilt bekommen haben, aber sie halt irgendwie sich Roboter ausdenken mussten, dann haben sie halt so simple Sachen mit einem Motor, mit einer Wippe, die halt einen Teil aus einer Maschine in den Ölbad schleuderte, zum Roboter erklärt. Also das war halt mit Gang und Gebel. Da haben sie dann versucht, irgendwie ginge nur noch über Geld so, also dazu sagen, da kriegst du eine Prämie dafür, wenn du halt einen Neurovorschlag machst, der halt irgendwas bringt, oder einen Rationalisierungsvorschlag, der halt irgendwas bringt, dann gibt es halt eine Prämie dafür. Das Problem war nur, du konntest dich für die Prämie halt auch nicht mehr wirklich viel kaufen. Also auf Autos hast du halt irgendwie plus zwölf Jahre, glaube ich, oder so weit gewartet, oder 15?
Na, 15 auf die größeren Dinge, sonst sind es drei wie zehn, zwölf oder so.
Der Geld war so recht kein Incentive. Das war ja auch für die Westbesucher immer so krass. Man musste ja immer diese 25 Mark Zwangsumtausch machen, und dann lief man in 25 Mark in der Tasche rum.
Und kriegste die nicht alle.
Es gab einfach keine Möglichkeit, die in irgendetwas umzusetzen, was man haben wollen würde. Also gut essen, klar, aber das war ja auch immer alles so wichtig. Bücher, genau, das war nämlich das Einzige. Also ich hab mir dann immer so Partiturbücher gekauft, weil die waren erstklassig. So Mozart und so weiter, komplette...
Durfte es die überhaupt ausführen?
Ich denke schon, ja. Aber das war auch eine der wenigen wirklich hochwertigen Dinge, die ich überhaupt gestoßen bin.
Bücher war dann tatsächlich noch der letzte Konsum, die waren halt vergleichsweise billig.
War doch genug über danach.
Am Ende war es halt so, wenn du halt darauf angelegt hast, Geld zu verdienen, dann konntest du dir das Leben halt schon ein bisschen angenehmer machen. Und dann war es halt besser als weniger Geld zu haben, schon klar. Aber jetzt nicht in einer Art und Weise, dass du halt irgendwie so dramatische Unterschiede, wie jetzt hier so im Westen hast, wo halt irgendwie der Unterschied zwischen irgendwie kaum Geld und richtig viel Geld halt so himmelweit ist. Und dementsprechend waren halt auch die, die meisten Leute haben sich halt dann eher, wenn sie irgendwie Ambitionen hatten, haben sie halt eher Sachen gemacht, die sie persönlich interessant fanden. So, also deswegen gab es halt auch diese irren Bastelbewegungen, die halt dann aus nichts irgendwie Kram gemacht haben. Also neulich bin ich wieder an so einer Satellitenschüssel vorbeigekommen. Da unten in Sachsen. Und zwar gab es keine Satellitenschüssel, da hast du doch keine bekommen. Also Satellitenfernsehen, als das losging Ende der 80er. Dann haben die Leute sich tatsächlich die Krümmung von dem Spiegel ausgerechnet, haben sich daraus eine Holzform gebaut und haben die in Beton gegossen mit der richtigen Neigung. Sie hatten sozusagen nur eine Holzform, die die richtige Neigung hatte, und haben die dann mit Blech ausgekleidet. Dann haben sie sich dann irgendwo von Oma noch einen LNB schmuggeln lassen, also diesen kleinen Konverter aus dem Westen. Und haben sich dann mit Amateurfunktechnik Satellitenempfänger gebaut, mit Transistoren, die irgendwo aus dem Werk rausgeschmuggelt wurden. Es gab da die ersten Sachen, die Leute haben sich ihre Nische irgendwie so ausgebaut, wie es irgendwie ging. Da habe ich doch immer wieder Leute getroffen, das geht doch gar nicht. Wie kann denn der das irgendwie mit nichts machen? Gerade Technikgeschichten zum Beispiel. Es gab halt in der DDR 5 oder 6 Bastelläden, wo man so Elektronikkomponenten bekam, die sich dann irgendwie erschnort haben oder sonst irgendwie aus den Werken beschafft haben. Für individuelle Bastler, also wenn du mal einen Transistor brauchst oder ein paar Widerstände. Da gab es halt hier in Berlin zwei, den in der Copernicusstraße. Oder in der Greifswalde. Da hatte er zum Schluss noch ziemlich wenig Elektronik.
Ach, und in der Kastanenallee.
Stimmt, und die Kastanenallee, genau. Das waren die drei Läden, die man halt immer, einmal die Woche seine Abklapperrunden gehabt hat, und dann halt irgendwie noch so ein bisschen Elektronik-Bastelkram brauchte. Wenn man sich mal seinen Computer ein bisschen pimpen wollte oder überhaupt mal einen bauen wollte, hat man so ein paar Wochen damit zugebracht, sich die Teile zu beschaffen, dann noch ein bisschen getauscht mit anderen, bis man dann irgendwie so seinen Set zusammen hatte. Und wenn man sich dann da irgendwie einen Transistor gebraten hat, weil man irgendwie zu doof war und den falsch angelötet hat, war schon schmerzlich so, weil dann musstest du wieder losziehen und dann irgendwie Kram besorgen. Also das war halt doch einfach eine andere Wirtschaft in dem Sinne. Das individuelle, materielle Gut hatte halt einen höheren Wert, nicht wegen seines Geldwertes, sondern wegen seiner schweren Wiederbeschaffbarkeit.
Persönlich im Engineering, würde ich sagen. Das war ziemlich interessant durch diese Tatsache, dass bestimmte Sachen entweder nur schwer erhältlich waren oder gar nicht erhältlich waren. Manche aber, sofern man Westfernsehen geguckt hat, und ich behaupte immer, das hat irgendwie überwiegende Teil der Leute einfach getan, egal was sie den nächsten Tag an der Arbeit erzählt haben, ist es einfach so gewesen, dass du durch diese Tatsache Fertigkeiten entwickelt hast, die du unter anderem Umständen bei einer normalen Versorgungslage überhaupt nicht hättest entwickeln können. Dadurch, dass an vielen Stellen einfach eine Mangelwirtschaft herrschte, bist du also auch gezwungen gewesen, dir Lösungen auszudenken, die letztlich zu diesem Ziel führen, was du jetzt anstrebst, also sei es irgendwie, ein selbstgebaute Surfbrett zu bauen und damit nach Polen zu fahren. Auf der Ostsee durftest du nicht fahren wegen Abhauen usw. Oder was weiß ich, diese kleine Patriot, oder wie heißen denn diese komischen Segeljollen, was ich da gesehen habe. Also selbst aus Plakatpappe und Tapetenkleister in 20 oder 15 Schichten selbst die leimte Boote oder so. Das hält. Wenn du das wasserfest lackierst, ist so ein Kahn haltbar. Heute lacht man drüber. Der Verbundwerkstoff eines Trabanten ist ja an sich auch etwas sehr Fortschrittliches. Von der Art der Korseriematerialien und wie man solchen Kompositwerkstoff baut. So ähnlich ist es in vielen individuellen Nischenbereichen, um z.B. ein Hobby nachzugehen oder bestimmte Ersatzteile nachzubauen, für Sachen, die es nicht gab. Du bist natürlich nicht in den Laden gegangen, wenn du ein Auto hattest. Und hast dann mal eben eine neue Zündspule, die musstest du wahrscheinlich wirklich kaufen. Aber einen Zündverteilerfinger hat man so lange repariert, bis er auseinandergefallen ist. Oder wenn du irgendwelche Grafitkohlen in kleinen Elektromotoren brauchst, hast du dir einen großen Zimmermannsbleistift genommen, den zerhackt und hast dir daraus die Kohlen gebaut. Das sind Fertigkeiten, von denen weiß ich teilweise, dass ich bis heute daran profitiere, wenn ich einfach an eine Art der Problemlösung rangehe. Wenn ich weiß, wir haben jetzt Punkt A und wir müssen nach B, und wir haben das und das zu lösen, dann fallen mir sehr ungewöhnliche Dinge ein, die mitunter aus dieser Zeit rühren, wo man überlegt hat, was haben wir hier, was können wir bauen? Das ist immer noch diese Robinson-Cruise-Geschichte. Eigentlich ist es eine Insel, es ist verdammt wenig da. Und das, was da ist, was besser geeignet ist, das könnten wir morgen wirklich brauchen. Deshalb nehmen wir jetzt, wo es unproblematisch ist, was wir mit ein bisschen Arbeit noch hinkriegen oder so. Und das polt auch das Denken anders, auf jeden Fall.
Mannschaftskreativität.
Kannst du dich an diese Heff-Praktik erinnern, wo diese teilweise hanebüchen-gefährlichen Dinger drinnen standen, so ganz komische Blechbiege-Arbeiten, und du dachtest, der Leute bringt das bloß nicht auf die Straße. Ich will damit nicht auf der Autobahn konfrontiert werden, wenn ich so einen Dachipack-Träger sehe. Oder all diese komischen Sachen, irgendwelche schönen Geschichten.
Ich hab halt Praktik und wie hieß das andere Heft? Hatt ein bisschen mehr Elektronik.
Jugend und Technik, Technik, was meinst du?
Ich hab's nicht mehr so ganz im Kopf. Eines der letzten überlebenden Beispiele ist die Zeitschrift der Funkamateur. Das ist die DDR-Funkamateur-Zeitschrift. Und da überlebt diese Art und Weise Dinge zu tun auch noch deutlich. Also einfach so nicht irgendwie kaufen, sondern halt selber machen. So, wenn man so irgendwie geht.
Ist ja eigentlich sehr hackerkompatibel.
Ja, ja, deutlich. Du warst halt dazu gezwungen mit dem Hacker-Mindset daran zu gehen, Sachen zu repurposen und zu sehen, was dem was da ist, halt irgendwie den, ja, det Christ, was du machen kannst. Zum Beispiel haben wir damals im Pionierpalast in der Arbeitsgemeinschaft, also meine erste Computer-Arbeitsgemeinschaft. Ah, der Pionierpalast ist das, was heute in der Wohlheide, diese Ding, wie heißt es jetzt? FHZ, genau.
Freizeit- und Erholungszentrale.
Genau, das war halt damals der Pionierpalast. Und was das halt war, war halt so ein großes Gebäude, in dem jede Menge Infrastruktur war, wo halt so nette Arbeitsgemeinschaften stattfanden. Das heißt, du bist da halt einmal die Woche hingegangen und hast da irgendwas gemacht. Meistens, also in dem Fall ging es halt um Computer und Astronomie, war, glaube ich, der Titel dieser Arbeitsgemeinschaft. Was wir da gemacht haben, war ein Empfängerbauen für einen russischen Wetter-Satelliten. Das war halt so, ich glaube, so um die sechste, siebte, achte Klasse weiter. Und das war dann halt so, da hat dann einer von aus der Akademie der Wissenschaften, der hat dann halt irgendwie einen Tag die Woche frei bekommen oder zwei, je nachdem, und hat halt diese Arbeitsgemeinschaften vorbereitet und geleitet. Das war halt so Teil seines Jobs. Also da hat ihn dann sein Institut freigestellt für, wurde halt da weiter für bezahlt und hat dann da diese Arbeitsgemeinschaften geleitet. Das war halt so ein, ja, was ich heute so ein bisschen vermisse, dass es da halt nicht so eine Bildungsinfrastruktur gibt, halt einfach den Kids diese Art und Weise zu denken beizubringen, halt einfach so, wir machen das jetzt mal, und wenn wir die Teile nicht haben, dann beschaffen wir sie halt irgendwie. Und irgendwer wird schon irgendjemand kennen, der irgendwie noch irgendwie dieses Nähne-Ding hat oder so, und den Rest improvisieren wir halt irgendwie.
Und gerade Kinder sind prädestiniert dafür. Also Schularbeitsgemeinschaften sind deshalb ziemlich effektiv, weil du halt Kindern, sofern du sie irgendwie auf das Ziel einschwören kannst, von wegen wir müssen jetzt diese Flugmodelle in die Luft bringen oder so, dann wird denen Kindern schon etwas einfallen. Da kannst du eine große Kiste irgendwie aus der Nägel und noch ein paar Holzteilchen irgendwie oder so hinstellen, irgendwie wird es dazu kommen. Und das ist eine Sache, die hat auf jeden Fall funktioniert. Also die pädagogische Arbeit war auch, wie du das gerade sagst, dass Wissenschaftler frei kriegen, um die Jugend zu erziehen, sozusagen. Das ist eine Sache, also Hut ab vor polytechnischer Bildung. Ich bin relativ dankbar, dass ich das so abgekriegt habe, also in so einem breiten Spektrum.
Das war auch ein Prinzip.
Also das haben sie halt schon verstanden.
Also war man da auch verpflichtet, sozusagen, wenn man da... Also das heißt, das hat man sich erhofft, dass man das tun durfte, oder man könnte sich freiwillig melden und dann...
Nee, das gab es auch an den Schulen.
Also an den Schulen gab es das auch, aber nicht auf dem Niveau. Aber diese PNIPA, diese Zentralen Arbeitsgemeinschaften, das war dann so, dass ich dann da, hatte ich dann das Lehrerkollektiv hin delegiert, so. Also da hatten die sozusagen dann so zwei Plätze oder so für den Stadtbezirk und dann haben die halt geguckt, wer da geeignet sind scheint oder so. Und das war dann teilweise, war das halt auch schon relativ fachlich ziemlich hochgehängt, so. Also wie gesagt, mit dem Satelliten-Receiver, das war halt schon durchaus anspruchsvolle Zeug, was war da gemacht worden.
Ja, also für 6. oder 8. Klasse, das hätte ich auch gerne gemacht.
Und dann, also da war dann halt so, da gab es halt diese Computerkabinette, wo man dann nach hinten noch hingehen konnte, wo dann halt so irgendwie im Informatikunterricht hat, heutzutage halt so 20 KZ 85 standen, also der DDR Homegrown Computer sozusagen, wo man dann noch so ein bisschen Basic machen konnte und seinen Kram dann auf einer Kassette speichern konnte. Und das war auch sehr wertvoll, weil das halt einfach jede Menge Austausch gab. Also einmal die Woche hat man halt da meistens so ungefähr dieselben Leute gesehen. Und konnte halt seine Programme tauschen oder Tricks und Tipps oder was auch immer und solche Sachen. Und bis hin zu irgendwie den Tuning-Parametern für den Kassettenrekorder, um halt seine Daten da wieder von diesen Kassetten zu kratzen.
Von welchem Zeitraum reden wir jetzt gerade?
Nein, 80er.
So kurz vor Schluss sozusagen.
Ja, so 85 war das dann für mich so. 84, 85, ja.
Wie war es denn so mit den Computern im Osten? Wer hatte denn einen?
Es gab halt eigentlich sozusagen drei große Stränge von Leuten, die Zugriff auf Computer hatten. Zum einen waren es halt Leute, die von ihrer Oma einen aus dem Westen mitbekommen haben. Das war dann halt meistens so C64, C plus 4.
Oder Schneider war glaube ich auch verbreitet.
ZX81.
ZX81 war so die andere Fraktion. Später dann halt noch Amiga. Aber das war halt ja schon ganz zum Schluss. Schneider CPC war viel. Und die anderen waren halt die, die halt kein Westconnection hatten. Irgendwoher oder nicht das Ostgeld zusammenkratzen konnten, um sich dann irgendwie einen zum 10 zu 1 Umrechnungskurs irgendwie an einen Verkauf zu kaufen. Es gab einen Gebrauchtgerätehandel, wo es dann typischerweise, wenn es Westelektronik zu kaufen gab, hatte es relativ regelmäßig gehabt, haben sie die dann so 1 zu 10 bepreist. Also wenn man Computer importiert bekommen hat, konnte man schon richtig Geld verdienen.
Als ich meinen C64 verkauft habe, habe ich 7000 Ostmark dafür bekommen. Der Joystick hat 180 Westbracht, jede einzelne Diskette. Diesmal war es nicht die Oma. Heutzutage ist es bestimmt kein Problem mehr. Es hat ein Fahrzeug mit einem CD-Kennzeichen, also einem Diplomatenfahrzeug. Jedenfalls wurde es mir so erzählt, ich hoffe, dass es so hinhaut, aber ich denke mal, das könnte hinkommen. Es wurde also ein Fahrzeug von Botschaftspersonal, das in West-Berlin in der Botschaft gesessen hat und aus Berlin gewohnt hat. Da die Autos nicht kontrolliert wurden, hat so einer das mal rübergefahren.
Okay, und der ist dir also zugekommen, aber du hast den dann verkauft und dann hast du 7000 Ostmark dafür bekommen?
Den Apple II gekauft. Also die vier Rechner, die ich zu Ostzeiten hatte, die habe ich mir jeweils nur dadurch leisten können, dass der Wiederverkaufswert zur Ostzeit so irrsinnig immens hoch war, dass man sich praktisch nicht vorstellen konnte. Der Käufer dieses Gerätes war eine Produktions-Hinossenschaft des Handwerks, und zwar für Bautechnik. Die haben darauf Bauprogramme laufen lassen, bzw. die haben sich für diesen PC 1715, also einer der kleineren Industriecomputer DDR, der irgendwie um die 34.000 Ost gekostet hat, den konnten sie aber nicht kaufen. Und da war ein C64 mit einem damals noch Kassettenlaufwerk, aber mit wenigstens einer Packung Disketten. Und bei denen, die auf die Aussicht einen Diskettenlaufwerk auch noch zu kriegen, war das Gerät nicht nur preiswerter, sondern auch leistungsfähiger. Und vor allen Dingen, irgendwie würde man schon an die Programme kommen. Außerdem ist das Betriebssystem gleich die Programmiersprache. Man konnte sich das also für seine finiten Elemente schichten. Kann man das auch... Lass den doch einen halben Tag rechnen. Dafür haben die überhaupt einen Computer. Die anderen hatten nämlich keinen. Na ja, und hatten irgendwie einen Fünftel des Preises nur ausgegeben. Also das ist eine Sache, die ist so praktisch... Das konnte man damals keinem erklären. Heute scheint das auch sehr merkwürdig, dass das überhaupt möglich war. Also der ZX-81, den hat für zweieinhalbtausend verkauft. Da hat er den zu West-DL getauscht und daraus den C64 gekauft und so komische Aktionen.
Aber es ist eben ein bisschen schwierig, den eigentlichen Wert der Ostmark zu festzulegen, oder?
Das ist ein bisschen virtuelles Spielgeld. Na ja, das war schon sehr real. Aber der Wert fluktuierte halt, je nachdem, um welchen Gegenstand es ging. Also noch mal kurz zur Systematik. Also es gab die Leute, die irgendwie Westcomputer hatten, denn irgendwoher irgendwie, mit diesen besagten Geschichten, dann gab es halt irgendwann im Osten auch DDR-Heimcomputer, also ziemlich zum Schluss dann so. Also da gab es halt so die drei Typen. Das eine war der Z1013, das war halt so eine Platine. Das kann man nicht anders sagen, einfach nur eine Platine mit einem DDR-Z80-Klon drauf. Und den kam dann bestellt und dann musste man da hinfahren nach Erfurt.
Mit seinem Ausweis hinlegen?
In den einen Lagen, wo man den dann bekam. Da kam dann so eine Postkarte, das war die ersehnte Postkarte, wo dann drauf stand, dass du an diesem Tag deinen Computer abholen kannst. Wenn du es nicht geschafft hast, dann kannst du noch eine Postkarte hinschreiben und sagen, ich schaffe es nicht, aber kann ich bitte einen anderen Abholtermin bekommen?
Sonst wäre sie jemand anders zugeteilt worden.
Nach vier Wochen oder so haben sie dann jemand anders zugeteilt. Dann musst du halt da hingegangen, hast sie dann gekauft, verbuggelt. Und wenn du Glück hattest, gab es an dem Tag noch ein bisschen Zubehörkram. Also wie zum Beispiel noch so ein besseres Keyboard dafür. Oder gar den TV-Modellator, aber das waren dann schon irgendwie die höhere Geschichten. Und dann, der Z1013 war halt echt klein, hatte halt einen Kilobyte Speicher am Anfang, also die ersten, das war halt so.
So wie der ZX81.
Ja, war halt de facto ein ZX81. Nachbau. Nie angelehnt. Das Problem war, dass die, die haben halt diese etwas höher integrierten Multi-Io-Bausteine, die Sinclair damals verbaut hat, wo halt irgendwie die PIO und die SIO drauf waren, die mussten sich halt irgendwie nachbauen mit Einzelteilen und das ging halt nicht so gut und deswegen haben sie das so ein bisschen.
Also parallele und serielle Portsmeister.
Genau. Und dann haben sie da halt so einen TTL-Massengrab draufgemacht, um halt irgendwie da so ein bisschen zu emulieren. Und dann gab es halt die, die Z-9001 hießen sie, ne? Und das waren so diese...
Das war ja der KC-87 in den 7er-Häusern.
Diese grauen, Pult-förmigen Dinger mit so einer Art überdimensionierter Taschenrechner-Tastatur. Vor allem mit so schlitzförmigen Tasten, die sich total schwer drückten. Das Problem war, das Ding hatte 1000 Bugs. Das war halt so, dass die irgendwie schlecht geerdet waren. Wenn man da irgendwo an der falschen Stelle anfasst, dann stürzt man das Ding ab. Und wenn man oben an den Speichermodulen rüttelte, dann war das auch schlecht. Das war ein Scheißding.
KC-97 heißt das hier? KC-97.
Das war dann die so ein bisschen refurbished, revampede Version. Das Hauptgerät war der KC-85, die gab es in 1, 2, 3 und 4. Das Betriebssystem darauf hieß Chaos, also C-A-O-S. Es war halt so ein Z80, 1,75 Mhz mit 16 Kilobyte RAM, also war halt irgendwie kein Luxusgerät, aber hatte halt so ein Modularweiterungssystem, da konnte man halt Kram reinstecken und halt Dinge tun. Es hatte halt so ein externes Keyboard, was halt nicht total scheiße war. Also das große Problem bei Computern im Osten war halt immer Keyboards. Also Keyboard-Technologie ist halt schwierig, wenn du halt irgendwie keine Rechte hast. Also das ist halt diese ganze Kontakt und Fehler-Mimik und so. Das irgendwie zu improvisieren ist halt echt schwierig.
Aber bleiben wir noch mal ein bisschen mehr, sozusagen bei den gesellschaftlichen Implikationen. Ich sehe jetzt schon hier so die Computer im Osten, die CRE-Sendung, die könnte man hier glatt nochmal auskoppeln. Aber ich will jetzt hier nicht zu sehr in Betriebssystemen verfangen. Du wolltest drei Sachen aufzählen. Also man kriegt seinen Rechner aus dem Westen, man kriegt seinen Rechner aus dem Osten.
Oder du hattest einen in der Firma.
Genau, oder im Institut oder so. Und das waren dann halt diese DDR-Bürokomputer. Da gab es halt auch so zwei Serien. Die eine war so Z80-basierte. Die hieß dann meistens BC und eine vierstellige Nummer. Oder dann PC und eine vierstellige Nummer. Die unterteilen sich dann halt auch noch. Da gab es dann halt die CPM-Version und die, wie hieß das andere Zeug?
Aber wie groß war sozusagen die Bewegung? Also wie groß, wie viele Leute? Ich meine, erbt euch jetzt mit vier Computern. Ich meine, da ist ja schon fast Rekord, oder? Ich meine, wer hat es in der DDR-Zeit auf viel Skalate?
Na ja, seit Anfang der 18er. Also, das würde man sagen, seit 1983 bis 1989, kurz vor Ende, habe ich mir den Apple II gekauft. Das war natürlich Schwachsinn, weil ein halbes Jahr später nicht mal mehr ein Teil davon wert war. Aber also, das ist schon ein nicht unwesentlicher Zeitraum. Also, über acht Jahre, das ist schon in Ordnung. Also, durch diese Absurdität, dass es im Osten diese Technik nicht gab und dieses Missverhältnis mit diesem Wechselkurs einer nicht konvertierbaren Währung da bestand, habe ich sozusagen an dem technischen Fortschritt teilhaben können, wie es sonst überhaupt nicht möglich gewesen wäre. Und das konnten, würde ich mal sagen, nicht allzu viele. Man ist ab und an so in den Tauschzirkel gekommen oder so, wo man dann mal so ausgedruckte, so Liborello, mit diesem Stachelrad-Walzen-Drucker, mit diesem endlosen Druckpapier und so. Da gab es ab und an so Programmlisten, wo man so so was anbietet oder so. Und wenn du mal auch eine Software brauchst, dann kannst du hier mal gucken, kannst du denen mal anrufen. Aber bevor du den anrufst, sag mir mal Bescheid. Am besten gehen wir das erste Mal zusammen hin. Das sind natürlich auch alles immer Dinge gewesen, wofür sich halt die entsprechenden Sicherheitskreise interessiert haben. Wer so was konnte oder so was hatte, musste auch irgendwie anderweitig für die interessant sein. Und da muss man also auch immer sehr kieken, mit wem man sich da irgendwie nur irgendwie zu einem Gespräch begibt oder einen Software-Austausch begibt.
Also das war halt schon so, gerade so seit Anfang der 80er wurde DDR halt klar, dass mit dieser Computertechnik, dass sie das nicht weiter so auf Sparflamme betreiben können. Und dann fing es halt an mit der großen Halbleiter, Hyper, Hyper, wir müssen jetzt eine eigene Halbleiterindustrie richtig aufbauen, nicht nur so halbherzig und so.
Und der Megabit-Chip.
Oh Gott, du weißt das auch, toll, das finde ich schau.
Ja, das war ja irgendwie so die große Meldung, als sie da ganz rumgeprallt haben.
Genau, dass sie den ersten 32-Bit-Computer gebaut haben und so eine Sache. Also das war halt so, also das hingen halt entsprechend auch in einer gesellschaftlichen Einordnung sehr hoch. Also es war dann zum Beispiel so, dass meine Generation, die eine davor, für die gab es, wenn du einen Informatikstudienplatz bekommen hast, dann musstest du halt nur irgendwie sehr viel kürzer zur Armee. Weil normalerweise war es so, wenn du halt irgendwie studieren wolltest, musstest du drei Jahre zur Armee. Und dann haben sie halt gesehen, so wir haben die drei Jahre nicht, wir können jetzt nicht noch die Leute drei Jahre bei der Armee vergammeln lassen, bis die halt ihr Informatikstudium anfangen. Aber wir können es halt auch nicht komplett lassen. Also haben sie dann so ein, irgendwie so drei Monate oder sechs Monate Training und dann müsste das irgendwann noch mal später machen, Ding gemacht. So dementsprechend begehrt waren dann auch plötzlich natürlich Informatikstudienplätze. Also es war halt so, dass diese Ausbildung, also die Informatikausbildung, wurde dann halt auch sehr hochgehängt. Habt ihr studiert? Also im Osten war sehr lustig. Ich habe einen Studienplatz zugeteilt bekommen an der Universität mit Weider, was halt wirklich so da in der Prärie bei Karl-Marx-Stadt ist, also heutzutage Chemnitz. Und das Positivste, was man wohl darüber sagen kann, ist, dass man da wahrscheinlich in großer Ruhe studieren kann. Und für mich kam die Wende genau zur richtigen Zeit, also ich musste dann diesen Studienplatz nicht antreten und hab dann in Berlin studiert. Aber für mich wäre es halt genauso gewesen, also ich wäre halt sozusagen, wenn die Wende nicht gekommen wäre, wäre ich danach dann halt meine sechs Monate zur Armee gegangen. Ziemlich genau dann ab Frühjahr 1990. Und dann halt, dann hätte ich wohl da mit weiter studiert.
Informatik?
Ich war seinerzeit in der neunten, glaube ich, war das oder in der achten, mit meiner Mutter bei der Berufsberatung. Das hat man ja so gemacht, man wollte sich ja rüber schlau machen, was es so alles gibt. Und ich interessierte mich für ein Meteorologiestudium. Und das war auch alles sehr schön und wunderschön, dass ich da gewesen war. Und mich sehr beeindruckt, die haben wirklich tolle Materialien da gehabt. Und ganz zum Schluss kam dann der große Hammer, den er dann aus der Schublade rauszog, indem er sagte, aber was ich Ihnen noch sagen wollte, als Meteorologe sind Sie dann Auslandskader. Sie haben mit Meteorologen aus dem nicht sozialistischen Wirtschaftsgebiet zu tun. Also Sie sammeln ja zum Beispiel Wetterballons ein, die zum Beispiel in West-Berlin gestartet sind oder so. Und die müssen Sie ja mit den Kollegen im nicht-sozialistischen Wirtschaftsgebiet austauschen. Überlegen Sie sich gut, ob Sie Westverwandtschaft haben. War so sein Spruch. Und guckte mich meine Mutter so an, sie guckte sie zurück. Und naja, das können wir uns ja dann überlegen, war so unsere Reaktion. Er sagte, ne, ne, ne, rückwirkend, drei Jahre rückwirkend. Und damit wartet im Prinzip für uns hier Essen.
Dann sollte er sich überlegen, ob man West-Verwandtschaft hat.
Ob man das sozusagen irgendwo angibt oder ob man sie verleugnet. Aber du hattest auch. Ja, hatte ich. Es war so weit entfernt, dass selbst mein Vater, der irgendwie mit den Verwandten ist, nicht gelungen ist, den Verwandtschaftsgrad zu bestimmen. Aber es war sozusagen West-Verwandtschaft, deren einmal im Jahr oder zweimal im Jahr vor unserer Tür stehendes Autonummernschild sich dann in meinen Chasi-Unterlagen gefunden hat. Also die wussten sehr wohl, dass natürlich irgendwie Kontakt zu irgendwelchen NSW, nicht so statistisches Wirtschaftsgebietleuten, bestanden hat. Und das war also auch ein Grund sozusagen, eine Studieneinschränkung vorzunehmen. Danach hatte ich mich dann nochmal für einen Mathe- und Physiklehrer beworben. Da war dann irgendwie, naja, da bin ich angeblich durch die Stimmprüfung gefallen. Zu der Zeit hatte ich mich allerdings auch schon politisch engagiert. Das kann also auch andere Gründe gehabt haben, dass sie da ablehnend reagiert haben. Nach der Wende habe ich es dann mit dem Studium nicht mehr aufgenommen, ja, also nicht studiert.
Ja, das ist immer ganz gut, wenn man hier auch ein abgebrochenes Studium vorweisen kann bei CRE. Jetzt gehöre ich zum guten Ton.
Wir sind eh die besten Informatiker, die abgebrochenen. Genau.
Ja, ach jetzt habt ihr so viele Sachen genannt, wo mir dann auch immer wieder so kleine, sogar mir, Anekdoten einfallen. Insbesondere so dieses difficile Verhältnis nach außen und was das dann auch für so interessante Wirtschaftsnischen so ergibt. Ich habe auch mal da so Kontakt gehabt zu so einem speziellen Autoschrauber, der es irgendwann mal so ein bisschen geschafft hat, sich sozusagen auf Westmarken zu spezialisieren, was ihm dann einen interessanten Kontakt eröffnet hat in diese Diplomatenkreise, da die alle das Problem hatten, dass sie irgendwie ihre Büchsen irgendwie nicht repariert bekommen haben im Osten und dann wurde er dann halt da herumgereicht. Und was ihm natürlich genau das sozusagen gab, was die eigentliche Währung zu sein scheint, nämlich einerseits Kontakte und vor allem natürlich auch Material. Also er hat sich dann vor allem halt in Zubehör bezahlen lassen. Die haben dann einfach Reparatur, Material, Werkzeuge vor allem aus dem Westen mitgebracht, mit denen man dann sozusagen da voranschaut. Das hat ihm dann aber auch interessante Protektionen auch gewährt in dieser Gesellschaft. Auf der einen Seite bist du natürlich dann auch ganz anders im Blickfeld, nehme ich an. Auf der anderen Seite hat man dann auf einmal auch ganz andere Freunde.
Wenn du diese Freunde auch haben willst, also... Also mit den Diplomaten, das ist schön, dass du das jetzt auch noch mal gerade sagst, da scheint wirklich eine Menge gegangen zu sein, weil das einfach so ein gewisser Freiraum gewesen ist. Diese Kofferräume, die halt kein Volkspolizist, kein Ost-Zoll-Beamter reingucken konnte, das war also ein Eldorado. Ich weiß von Leuten, ich bin durch diese Computertauscherei sozusagen, das war auch nahe an Leuten, denen das also alle völlig egal war, was für eine Rede das war, was da in Osten gelangt ist. Hauptsache, man konnte irgendwie damit Geld machen. Das waren dann also Leute, denen es viel wichtiger war, irgendwelche CD-Spieler oder Hi-Fi-Anlagen aus dem Westen in den Osten zu schaffen und das für viel Geld hier zu verscherbeln mit dem Hintergrund, dass man aus diesem Ost-Delt irgendwie auch wieder West-Delt machen kann. Wenn man hier im Ostgebiet West-Delt hatte, dann stand einem sozusagen das Tor der Welt offen. Man konnte damit zwar nicht verreisen, man konnte damit vielleicht höchstens in Kuba-Palmen sehen oder am Schwarzen Meer, aber man hat sich sonst an materiellen Wohlstand schon eine Menge leisten können. Es gab irgendwann diesen Mazda 323 im Osten zu kaufen. Ich weiß nicht, hat der 6-stellige gekostet oder wurde der alte 5-stellig, diese 80.000. Mir gibt es irgendwie so eine Zahl in meinem Kopf mit 130 und dann noch mal eine mit 80.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, aber das waren absurde Summen.
Das waren absurde Summen, wo eigentlich klar ist, durch normale Arbeit konnte keiner an so ein Geld kommen. Das sind halt so Geschichten. Entweder haben die Leute das... Also ich habe noch 4 zu 1 Westgeldtauschen erlebt. Das war irgendwie Anfang der 80er. Ja, 81 oder so. Das erste, was ich gehört habe, 4 zu 1 tauschen und dann zum Schluss 88 oder so, 6, 7 zu 1. Auf dem Dorf haben sie halt auch höher 10 zu 1 oder so. Das ist ja irgendwie ein Handwerksmeister, der der Einzige war im Umkreis von so und so vielen Kilometern, der Kunstschmiedehandwerk meinen Weg gemacht hat. Und wenn da die Kirche in dem Dorf jetzt dann neue Geländer brauchte, dann war der, der das gemacht hat. Naja, ein bisschen Eisen verbiegen und das qualifizieren und das Wärmetechnisch behandeln, das wird er schon hingekriegt haben, daraufhin hat er Geld bekommen. Aber aus diesem Geld konnte er sich keine Güter kaufen. Sicherlich war er dann irgendwann in der Lage, sich für 7000 Ostmarken einen Kohlermat verabfahren zu leisten oder so. Wenn er aber schon ihn gehabt hat, hat er jetzt keinen zweiten gebraucht. Also zum Ende der DDR hin hatten viele, viele DDR-Bürger eine Menge Ostdelta kumuliert und hatten im Prinzip eine elende Kaufkraft, die sie nicht wirklich zu Werten machen konnten. Deshalb wurden dann irgendwann diese neben den schon erwähnten HO- und Konsumgeschäfte wurden dann irgendwann, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, aber Anfang der 18er fing das auch an mit diesem Delikat und Exquisit wurden zwei zusätzliche komische Handelsorganisationen, nein, vielleicht nicht ganz richtig, also Verkaufsketten eingeführt, diese Delikat für Genussmittel und Exquisit für Bekleidung, Konfektionswaren, in welchem die Geschäfte zeichneten sich durch zwei Dinge aus. Also die Artikel, die es da drinne gab, sahen anders aus als normal, als das, was du normalerweise im Konsum oder in der HO bekommen hast. Sie sahen vielleicht nicht nur anders aus, sondern sie waren vielleicht sogar Westartikel, also zum Beispiel Trumpf-Schokoladenpulver oder so ein ganzes Regal voll von so einem Zeug. Westartikel, die aber, wie man dann so nach und nach erfuhr, in der DDR halt auf Lizenz produziert wurden. Diese Artikel standen dort dann drinne für 12 Ostmark oder so, eine kleine Dose eingeweckte Mandarinen oder so, neun Ostmark. So ein Ding, was hier 30, 40 Pfennig kostet im Moment oder Cent. Das waren die Delikatgeschäfte. Und auf der anderen Seite gab es diese Exquisite-Läden, wo es halt sehr, sehr hochwertige Klamotten gab. Zum Beispiel Salamandaschuhe, die im Osten produziert wurden, aber als Westartikel ausgegeben wurden. Es gab da diesen Witz mit, wie heißen sie, Erich Salamander. Das war letztlich alles dafür geschaffen, Kaufkraft abzuschöpfen. Also Leuten die Möglichkeit zu nehmen, mit diesem Geld Unsinn zu machen. Vielleicht damit Westgelder zu tauschen oder so.
Getauscht? Wie macht der denn das im Osten und Westen?
Ach so, ich wollte gerade noch die Sache mit diesen Forum-Checks erzählen. Irgendwann fand die DDR-Regierung nicht mehr toll, dass die Individuen über Westgeld verfügen. Sie hat dann also sozusagen ihrerseits verfügt, dass man, während man im Besitz von Valuta ist, also von Auslandswährung, von konvertierbarer Währung, man die in so noch wieder andere bunte, bedruckte Papierscheine tauschen muss. Und diese Dinge konnte man nur im Intershop-Geschäft zum Einkauf vorlegen. Der Intershop, das wird denen wahrscheinlich bekannt sein, das sind halt die Sachen, wo man tatsächlich nur die Westwaren hat, und da wurde dann gegen Westhielte gezahlt. Ostbürger durften dann natürlich auch kaufen, aber eigentlich nur mit Forum-Checks, die eigentlich umgetauscht mit Westhieltewesen sind. Na ja, und wie man da rangekommen ist, war halt dann entweder Westverweinschaft oder ja eigentlich...
Wie hat man aus seinem Ostgeld Westgeld gemacht? Also konnte man das problemlos dann tauschen? Nein.
Nein, das ist alles im Bekanntenkreis irgendwie passiert.
Aber wer gibt sozusagen Westgeld für Ostgeld?
Also, die Motivationen sind natürlich immer sehr verschieden. Ich hatte damit irgendwie nicht so viel zu tun. Aber wenn du halt zum Beispiel was gebaut hast, so Handwerksleistungen oder so, dann hast du halt irgendwie nicht nur alles in Westgeld bezahlen können, sondern halt dann irgendwie so ein Gemisch gehabt. Dann brauchtest du halt auch viel Ostgeld, um halt Material zu kaufen oder solche Geschichten. Und in Zweifel hast du halt irgendwie den Umtausch in West-Berlin erledigen lassen. Ging halt auch.
Kennst du das auch mit diesen blauen Fliesen oder so? Diese in allen den Zeitungsannoncen stand ab und an drin eine Suche, was weiß ich, die Zündverteiler hatten wir heute schon mal. Ein Zündverteiler für das Eklader 1600 gegen 200 blaue Fliesen oder so, was der Synonym für West-DL gewesen ist. Du hast sozusagen mit solchen Sachen in der Zeitung gekryptet, angedeutet, dass du in der Lage wärst, dafür auch West-DL drüber wachsen lassen zu können. Und dann gab es natürlich auch ein paar Sachen. Dann gab es natürlich auch andere Gründe, wie Westgeld hergekommen ist. In einigen Branchen, also ich glaube zum Beispiel im Bootsbau oder so, also für kleine Segeljachten oder sowas in Köpenick, da gab es ein paar Betriebe, die waren ganz gut, und ähnliche Nischenbetriebe haben halt Sachen hier fertig, die für einige Westler relativ interessant gewesen sind. Und die sind halt ganz normal hingegangen und haben so etwas gekauft. Bei einem dieser Dinge gab es natürlich Probleme, das auszuführen, und da kann man natürlich mit etwas, was Westgeld hieß an dieser Stelle, die Leute dazu bringen, bestimmte Sachen möglich zu machen, die sonst einfach nicht möglich gewesen wären. Sodass also verschiedenste Mengen von Westgeld durch so einen Weg z.B. rindefundierten. Und ansonsten hast du halt immer den Opa oder die Oma gehabt oder den Opa von einem Verwandten, der an dem Tag bestimmt gerade mal nach West-Berlin gefahren ist. Also die Reisebeschränkungen für DDR-Bürger, davon waren natürlich Rentner ausländernd bekanntermaßen. Die wurden auch nicht so irrsinnig kontrolliert, sodass da vor allen Dingen über Renten eine ganze Menge passiert ist. In meinem Ausbildungsbetrieb war das z.B. so, wir hatten halt die schon erwähnten AC und PC, Bürocomputer von Robotron, beziehungsweise die größeren Dinger von ESA, aber alle brauchten das Ketten, und das waren von den 8 Zoll des Ketten abgesehen, waren das dann irgendwann 5,5 Zoll des Ketten, und da gab es dann immer diesen einen Rentner. Und der ist dann abends, wahrscheinlich war dann eh mal der Beschäftigte dieser Firma, der ist dann halt abends, wenn er einen Anruf gekriegt hatte, zum Firmenteuer gekommen, ist dann irgendwo hochgegangen, hat dann was in der Hand gedrückt bekommen und ist dann nächsten Tag mittags irgendwie wieder da gewesen. Er ist dann halt, muss dann halt irgendwie rüberfahren, hat das Ketten gekauft und hat sie da vorbeigebracht. Also ein DDR-weit und sozusagen im RGV-Rahmen wirklich weit agierender Konzern, damals hieß das Kombinat, war darauf angewiesen, sich seine Betriebsmittel durch einen komischen Rentner-Korea-Schmuggel zu besorgen, weil die Diskette im Osten nicht gab.
Wurden die nicht kontrolliert?
Du hättest halt am Strausberger Platz im An- und Verkauf hättest du auch eine Diskette für 180, 200 Mark der DDR kaufen können. Das heißt so eine Zehner-Packung für 2000 Ost.
Warte mal, eine Zehner-Packung für 1000?
2000, also für 180 und 200 Mark der DDR eine Diskette. Und da geht so ein Mensch dann einfach zu Böder oder was weiß ich, wo es die in seiner Zeit gab, Phobis oder so was, und ruft dann halt einen normalen Preis. Und das bisschen Westgeld, so eine Valutermittel über so was, verfügt dann so ein großer Konzern noch. Das ist die kuriose Situation, dass selbst solchen Firmen zwar das Geld zur Verfügung stand, aber die Ware war im Hintergrund nicht da. Und deshalb haben sie sich halt solcher Sachen bemächtigt.
Der Mangel, da sind wir wieder bei diesem merkwürdigen Zustand. Ich meine, das muss doch eigentlich alle total genervt haben. Ich meine, war man genervt von der. Wann wurde denn überhaupt erwogen, mal Alternativen zu prüfen?
Also mich haben zum Beispiel bestimmte... Also irgendwann kommst du als Jugendlicher natürlich auf die Idee, wie ist denn das eigentlich? Da fängst du an, nicht nur alles zu hinterfragen, sondern du wirst geradezu darauf gestoßen, dass bestimmte Sachen komisch sind. Da gibt es jemanden meinetwegen in der Klasse, der sich ziemlich engagiert, der ja linientreu ist, aber der jetzt zu einem politischen Gespräch auch mal den örtlichen Pfarrer einladen will. Und der kriegt meinetwegen das erste Mal Ehen auf den Hut. Und der ist total engagiert und du wirst, das wird irgendwann mal ein Parteikader, wenn der so weitermacht. Der kriegt trotzdem Ehen auf den Hut, nur für die Frage, warum er denn jetzt eigentlich aber nicht den Pfarrer einladen darf. Sondern man muss doch über das Thema, muss man doch wirklich ein breites Meinungsbild einholen oder so. Das sind so die Momente, wo man das erste Mal ins Nachdenken gerät. Und dann guckt man mal so ein bisschen, dann diffundieren natürlich durch die große Nähe zu Westberlin ab und an nicht nur eine Bravo, sondern auch mal einen Stern oder einen Spiegel nach Ostberlin. Und die sind dann so abgegrabbelte Wesen. Du hast ja gesehen, durch wie viele Dutzend Hände vorher, die schon gegangen sind und wieder die Seiten rausgefallen sind. Und dann stehen da solche Sachen drin, dass an der Charité jetzt Kranke aus Westberlin behandelt werden für 20.000 im Quartal oder so. Oder Blutkonserven nach Westberlin verkauft werden. Und das sind dann so die Sachen, wo du dir denkst, okay, wir haben offenbar einen ziemlich großen Devisenmangel. Aber der Staat macht ganz offenkundig auch nicht davor, halt die Gesundheit seiner Bürger auszuverkaufen. Es ist offenbar relativ schwierig, an Westgeld für den Staat zu kommen. Es ist offenbar sehr wichtig. Und deshalb macht er bestimmte Dinge. Und das sind so die Sachen, damit fängt man einerseits an, nachzudenken und andere Fragen zu stellen oder sich die Antworten woanders zu holen. Auf der anderen Seite aber auch sein Engagement in der Hauptstoßrichtung des Sozialismus einfach einzustellen. Oder zu sagen, das hat nichts mehr damit zu tun, was mal in den Büchern drinsteht. Ihr proklamiert etwas, was ihr selber nicht mehr in der Lage seid einzuhalten. Und sobald man sowas realisiert, sobald man einen linken Staat von links versucht zu kritisieren, kriegt man richtig was auf den Hut. Da muss man sehr schnell gucken, wo man seine Meinung überhaupt noch hinbringt. Das sind Gründe, durch sowas erfährt man automatisch, dass man da besser nichts sagt. In dem Maß mag einen so ein Land vielleicht nerven. Das Kurios ist aber, dass man als Jugendlicher durch sowas auch lernt, sich einzurichten. Das ist eine sehr üble Sache. Ich glaube, sehr viele Leute haben deshalb auch final ihr politisches Engagement verloren. Selbst, wenn sie sich zu Schulzeiten noch richtig für etwas eingesetzt hatten. Dass zum Beispiel der Schulgarten toll wird oder so. Denn dafür waren Mittel da. Es war wichtig, dass alle Leute wussten, wie etwas angebaut wird. Alle waren praktisch bei uns in einem Schulgarten oder so. Ich finde das armselig, wenn so ein Land wie das hier immer erklärt, dass sieben Prozent der Leute von der Landwirtschaft leben. Das Quatsch, 100 Prozent der Menschen leben von der Landwirtschaft. Alle essen, alle müssen essen. Wollen die irgendwie Chemiekramen, der aus Öl hergestellt ist, essen? Oder was ist das für eine Denkweise dahinter? Und dadurch, dass das alle wissen, wurden ursprünglich eigentlich alle mal in so eine Richtung gebracht. Nur wenn wir zusammen an diesem dicken Seil ziehen, dann kriegen wir den Karren auch bergauf gezogen oder so. Und wenn durch solche individuellen Ereignisse die Leute abspringen, dann werden das immer weniger. Das Seil ist genauso dick und der Karren bleibt genauso schwer. Aber wenn die Leute abspringen oder so, die mal mitgezogen haben, dann fetzt das irgendwann nicht mehr. Und in dem Maße, wie du es siehst, dass Leute geschasst werden oder wegen irgendwelchen komischen Bemerkungen zwangsversetzt werden. Oder so ja Fernsehmoderatoren. Wie heißt der OF. Weidling, der Typ, der irgendwann auch nicht mehr im Viertelstadtpalast ist, erzählen wollte, es gab so ein paar Ostkabarettisten, die sich mal ein paar Sachen geleistet haben, wo du mitgekriegt hast, der ist kurze Zeit später, hat ja ein Fernsehverbot gekriegt oder so eine Geschichte. Das sind so Sachen, wo du dir denkst, das passt aber nicht zu dem, was ein sozialistischer Staat programmiert. Deshalb mache ich da mal sehr genau diese Ausnahme Realsozialismus. Eigentlich haben wir keinen Sozialismus erlebt. Das hat damit nicht so viel zu tun. Das war eigentlich auch so dieser Staatssozialismus nach stalinistischer Präung. Das ist ein Bereicherungsmodell gewesen. Bei uns im Osten, also in der DDR und ganz besonders in Ostberlin, war es deshalb entspannt, weil, wie sie immer so schön sagten, an der Nahtstelle der Weltsysteme war natürlich die gelebte Systeme-Auseinandersetzung sehr, sehr groß. Das wurde also so eine Sache wie der Schwarze Kanal. Karl Eduard von Schnitzler, dürfte der auch was sagen.
Ganz großartiges Entertainment. Das kam auch vor einer Kamera.
Genau, der Löwental, den anderen, ein Peitschader. So eine Geschichte hat natürlich dazu gebracht, dass die Versorgungssituation für die Bevölkerung relativ gut war. Zu Weihnachtszeiten gab es schon noch Südfrüchte, wovon die Leute in Cottbus oder die Schweige noch weiter von Berlin entfernt träumen konnten. Die sind dann hierhergefahren und haben sich in den Außenbezirken gekauft. Die sind aber zu mehreren hingefahren, weil jemand anders noch mal reingehen musste, um noch mal was zu holen. Denn sie selber hätten nur dieses eine Kilo oder diese drei Stück bekommen. Eine Situation, wie man sie jetzt vielleicht aus Ländern kennt, wo der Sprachgebrauch unser großer Führer oder so ähnlich ist. Also wenn ich an Nordkorea denke, da ist es ähnlich. Einerseits programmiert der Staat so eine wahnsinnigen Worthülsen und peitscht auf seine Leute damit ein. Auf der anderen Seite fressen sie aber den Kitt aus den Fenstern, weil das effektiv nichts gibt. Und andere Missstände werden halt verschwiegen. Das ist halt was sehr Ärgerliches. Wir haben es dadurch sehr entspannt gehabt, dass wir so dicht am Westen dran waren. Und ich glaube, ganz wichtig waren, sind dabei so der Ständi, Vergleich mit diesen elektronischen Massenmedien. Ohne das wäre in diesem Land vieles anders gewesen.
Mit den elektronischen Massenmedien?
Fernsehen, Fernsehen und Radio. Also sie haben, ganz besonders böse waren sie immer auf AFN, BFBS und BBC, klar. Aber natürlich vor allen Dingen der Rias. Das ist ja die Stimme des US-amerikanischen imperialistischen Revanchismus. Das war ja immer der größte Dorn im Auge. Und du wurdest halt als DDR-Bürger bist du nach Polen oder in die Tschechisch-Slovakie gefahren und wurde es da behandelt wie wir, die unsere Westler behandelt haben, wenn sie uns mal besucht haben. Die haben dich gefragt, was du ihnen mitgebracht hast. Das ist ganz komisch. Die wussten alle, dass es den DDR-Bürgern am besten geht. Das war eine ganz merkwürdige Situation. Die hatten höchstens mal EFN oder The Voice of America, weil zufällig in Österreich mal so ein Ding stand, was da mal ein bisschen rüber gestrahlt hat, auf Mittelwälder oder so.
Wie hat man denn über diese Situation mit West-Berlin nachgedacht? Ich meine, da befand sich so ein Stück Bundesrepublik, Deutschland, Feind irgendwie, mit einer Mauer umgarnt, mitten im Gebiet. So, es war irgendwie mal die andere Hälfte der Stadt. Das war auch irgendwann mal irgendwie alles da und alles eins und gehört irgendwie zusammen. Und es war ja auch nicht so, dass man das nicht sah. Aber wie fühlte sich denn das an? Ich meine, im Westen war das irgendwie ja relativ klar. Da wusste man, das ist irgendwie alles scheiße und doof. Und das wollte man ja auch offiziell nicht so haben und gerne beenden und so. Das war ja auch ein riesiger logistischer Aufwand. Auch ein finanzieller, an dem sich ja Berlin bis heute noch nicht erholt hat. Aber so jetzt, wie war die Perspektive auf der anderen Seite? Wie hat man denn das gesehen? Diese Sicherheitsanlagen, diese Trennstreifen?
Du hast es rausgerinnert?
Du hast es selbst rausgerinnert?
Also es war halt, als wenn da ein Werk ist.
Dadurch, dass das immer präsent ist, wenn die Gewinne in die Stadt fahren mit der S-Bahn, dann ist die S-Bahn zwischen Pankow und Schönaueseallee irgendwie um 20 Stundenkilometer gefühlt. Vielleicht waren es ja auch nur 10 oder 15, schneller gefahren. Also zwischen da, wo jetzt Bahn auf Bornheimer Straße ist, da verlief ja die Grenze durch. Das heißt, die Bahn ist im Prinzip direkt durch die Grenze durchgefahren. Das war sehr kurios. Sie ist nicht mal außen vorbei, sondern halt richtig durch die Grenze durch. Ich denke, irgendwann hat man aus dieser Not auch einen Tugend gemacht und hat an dieser Stelle die Grenzanlagen natürlich auch demonstrativ befestigt, um den Leuten auch zu zeigen, es macht keinen Sinn, hier rauszuspringen. Ihr werdet auf jeden Fall da nicht lebend auf der anderen Seite ankommen, wenn Leichtes natürlich immer so dargestellt wurde, als wenn der antifaschistische Schutzfall, hieß dieses Ding hier, als wenn es dafür da war, dass die bösen Westler nicht den Osten aushungern oder so. Das ist halt auch eine Sache, die irgendwann mein Denken verändert hat. Sicherlich kennen alle dieses Ulbrichting, niemand hat die Absicht, eine Bauer zu errichten. Und zwei Tage später oder bis zum nächsten Abend oder so war der dann irgendwie relativ schnell, fing das an. Das Ausbluten des Ostens, also die 10.000, die jeden Tag irgendwie nach Westen abgehauen sind sozusagen, das war tatsächlich eine Sache, die die DDR, die damals junge DDR, hätte kaputt machen können. Auf der anderen Seite gab es damals schon Noten von den Westalliierten, die gesagt haben, wir sind ja nicht mehr in der Lage, die Leute entgegennehmen zu können. Macht mal irgendwas, wie kommen wir da jetzt beide raus? Ulbricht hat den Schwarzen Peter zugeschoben gekriegt und hat dann sozusagen die stalinistische Lösung wieder gewählt. Okay, so ein Ding wirst du drin gebohren. Du siehst da Hunde lang laufen an komischen Stahlseilen, wo sie also wirklich in ihrer Bewegungsfreiheit eingeschränkt sind. Diese Dinger, die dann später als Selbstschussanlagen identifiziert werden konnten, habe ich als 14. Jahr ja aus der S-Bahn sehen können, in 30 Meter Reichweite oder so. Ich wusste nur nicht genau, was das ist. Die sahen aus, wie sie reden oder so. Diese SM-70-Selbstschussanlage oder wie das heißt. Es ist schon sehr krass, als Jugendlicher sowas sehen zu müssen oder so. Aber da es halt omnipräsent ist, fügt es sich eben auch in deinem ständigen Leben ein. Wenn du halt in der Nähe da wohntest, dann wurdest du halt, außer das hatte zufällig mal der sehr Polizist abends Dienst oder so, dann hat er dich nicht nach einem Ausweis gefragt. Aber ansonsten bist du in Grenzen grundsätzlich nicht nach einem Ausweis gefragt worden. Das hätte ja sein können, dass du da was an und vor hattest. Und das sind so Sachen, die sicherlich säkeln. Nur in dem Maße, also nichts ist so gefährlich für die Menschen, wie halt die Gewöhnung an irgendwelche Zustände. Und das gehört definitiv dazu, wenn dein Bild ausmacht. Wenn die Phobos mit ihren scheiß Bridges-Hosen im Dritten Reich vor dir stehen, dann kannst du die Scheiße finden, wie du willst. Aber du kannst sie maximal jetzt wegdenken. Kannst sie jetzt nicht wegmachen. Insofern, West-Berlin war ein Garant für Juten Fernsehempfang. Da standen ein paar ordentliche FM-Sender. Und wahrscheinlich ein paar unheimliche Abhörstationen der. Amis.
Aber wenn diese ganzen Westmedien auch regelmäßig konsumiert hat, dann müsste ja auch eine ganze Menge Information über die Situation Ost-West.
Das Problem war, dass die Westmedien auch nie vollständig objektiv berichtet haben, sondern die natürlich auch Propaganda betrieben haben. Die hatten halt ein Ziel. Was bedeutet das, dass man deren Meldung natürlich auch nicht trauen konnte. Das war schon relativ klar. Das war auch immer Propaganda, Konterpropaganda und so weiter und so fort. Man musste sich halt versuchen, aus diesem Dschungel von Propaganda und gegen Propaganda halt ein Bild zusammen zu formen. Das war den meisten Leuten auch schlicht zu anstrengend. Die sind davon ausgegangen, der Osten lügt halt und der Westen, naja, wir haben keine Ahnung, der lügt halt nur seltener oder so eh nicht. Rias hat auch nicht...
Man war sozusagen von seinem eigenen System so sehr gewohnt, dass man die Hucke voll gelogen bekommt, dass man dem Westen auch nicht alles abgenommen hat.
Das war ja auch klar, dass sie lügen. Das war ja schon so, dass sie teilweise überzogen haben. Rias hat halt häufiger mal in den Nachrichtensendungen irgendwelche richtigen Räuberpistolen drin gehabt, die sich dann auch später in historischer Betrachtung als Unsinn herausstellen. Weil sie irgendwelche Gerüchte, die sie irgendwo aufgeschnappt haben, einmal durch die Propagandamühle gedreht und dann den Eta gejagt haben. Da haben die sich wirklich Spaß draus gemacht. So wie Twitter heute. Ich habe mal mit einem Ami geredet, der bei Rias eine Weile war als Redakteur. Und der meinte, klar haben sie Spaß gehabt, wenn du weißt, dass die auf der anderen Seite 5 Millionen Leute zuhören.
Da haust du auch auf die Kacke.
Du hast gesicherte Zuhörerschaft an der Stelle. Die kleben einfach am Volksempfänger.
Aber es ist ja auch nicht so, dass gar nichts mehr geglaubt wurde. Dass das eine im Wesentlichen von der DDR betriebene Befestigung war. Ich will jetzt auch nicht so sehr auf dieser Mauer rumreiten. Ich versuche nur, mich diesem Gefühl zu nähern, was man da hatte. Weil irgendwann muss es ja auch gekippt sein. So war es ja nun. Es sind immer mehr Leute geflohen. Es sind immer mehr Leute abgehauen. Als sich die Gelegenheit über Ungarn ergab mit der geöffneten Grenze, nahm das Ganze alles, war das einfach immer mehr. Und irgendwann fehlten ja wahrscheinlich auch einfach Leute. Irgendwann kannte man einfach wahrscheinlich genug Leute, die einfach nicht mehr da waren, oder? War das jetzt in eurem Umfeld jetzt konkret so nicht so?
Also bei mir war es so, dass, ich weiß noch, das war glaube ich in der zehnten Klasse, ja, jedenfalls war es so, dass da die...
Wart ihr denn eigentlich im Widerstand? Wart ihr im Untergrund? Wart ihr irgendwie in der Volksfront von Judea?
Oder in einer jüdischen Volksfront?
Nee, in der Judesphäre in der... Bei mir war es so, ich bin halt irgendwie erst beim Abi halt in dem Sinne politisiert worden, dass ich da halt irgendwie angefangen habe, irgendwas zu tun. Na, das war dann so 1988 so, also ziemlich zum Schluss. Und im Vorjahr hat man halt halt... Naja, wir sind ignoriert. Wenn das Leute abgehauen sind, kam es schon vor, also auch aus einem sehr engen privaten Umfeld. Und das war dann teilweise schon sehr dramatisch so, dass sie dann halt einfach echt nicht mehr da waren. Es war halt wie, als wenn sie tot sind. So, weil weg. Also von denen kam dann halt auch nie Post oder so, da werden dann mal eine Postkarte mitgebracht von irgendjemand oder so. Und das war dann teilweise schon sehr dramatisch so. Und die Menge an Leuten, die abhauten, so gerade 88 und dann 89 natürlich, wurde halt schon merklich so. Also das war halt auch sehr durch alle Schichten hindurch. Also das war halt nicht so, dass du sagen konntest, der wird nicht abhauen oder so. Sondern, ja, also es ist halt irgendwie...
Umarbeiter zum Akademiker.
Ja, war einfach mal so einmal quer Beats. Und auch gerade so die Leute, von denen das Land am Ende abhängen, also halt irgendwie Krankenschwestern, Lehrer und so. Also die Leute, die halt einfach die Arbeit machen so. Und die auch nicht so leicht zu ersetzen waren, die waren halt diejenigen, die dann halt auch in großen Mengen abgehauen sind. Und mit halt so, also 88 oder so, oder 89 gab es halt auch Leute, die dann nochmal eine fette Party gemacht haben, bevor sie abgehauen sind. Dann gab es halt auch schon so. Also sie haben halt niemanden gesagt, warum sie jetzt noch eine fette Party machten, so ein paar Leute wussten es halt. Aber du musstest halt tierisch aufpassen, weil Versuch der Republikflucht hat dich halt direkt in den Knast gebracht. Und das Unterstützern dafür auch, ja.
Wie das mit diesen Ausreiseanträgen ablief, habe ich irgendwann Anfang der Achtzehnt mitbekommen. Da ist aus einem entfernten Bekanntenkreis jemand weg, der wusste das irgendwie zwei Tage vorher. Und der hatte das mir dann mal gesagt. Und ich wusste überhaupt nicht, was das sein soll oder so. Da haben wir damit weggelassen. Ja, wir sind gar nicht fertig da. Ja, irgendwie wechsel siebte oder so. Und das war das erste Mal, dass ich so diesen Thema-Ausreise-Antrag stelle. Also einen Antrag auf dauerhaftes Verlassen aus der Staatsbürgerschaft eines Landes. Das waren so für mich Kategorien. Ich dachte, gibt es so was? Ach, so was gibt es also auch. Okay, jetzt erklärt mir mal jemand. Watt das alles später bedeuten würde, dazu brauchte ich dann irgendwie noch, weiß ich nicht, sechs, sieben, acht Jahre, bis das dann so richtig zündete. Da ist ja der Rest weitestgehend bekannt. So die Sachen mit der Botschaftsbesetzung in Prag und Genshars Intervention und so das ganze Zeug, was viel in eine Gänge gebracht hat, kurz danach in Ungarn. Ich hatte irgendwann begonnen, mich politisch zu betätigen und habe dann auch ein Reiseproblem in Richtung Osten bekommen. Also ich wollte dann irgendwann mal wieder an die Tschechoslowakei und durfte dann nicht mehr, wurde halt einfach wieder zurückgeschickt.
Was heißt denn politisch betätigen?
Na du, du stellst fest, dass auf einer Müllkippe Westmüll abgekippt wird. Aber offenbar nicht nur irgendein Hausmüll, sondern offenbar auch Chemieabfälle. Und dann fängst du an, in der Kirchengemeinde Fragen zu stellen, die nebenan ist. Und dann machen sie dir erstmal die Türen zu, weil sie dir natürlich nicht trauen. Und dann ist dann doch mal einer da, wie mein Kirchenrat, der sagt, kommen sie mal dann und dann wieder, dann können wir reden.
Weil die Kirchengemeinde traut dir nicht, weil sie Angst haben, dass es nur so ein Thema ist.
Na ja, zunächst mal, klar. Ja, sicherlich. Wenn jemand von der Sicherheit ist, dann könnte er ja auch mit solcher Frage herausbekommen, wer ihm darauf hin antwortet, muss ja offenbar ein Interesse daran haben, unseren Staat schlecht zu machen oder all das, was da dran hängt. Und da gab es dann irgendwann, jetzt mal in Detail, was da schon sehr weit fortgeschritten ist, kurz vor Ende zu erwähnen, da gab es dann etwas, es organisierten sich innerhalb der Kirchen ganz viele Ausreisergruppen. Wir haben sie immer Ausreisergruppen genannt. Leute, die also weder mit dem Glauben noch mit irgendwelchen Inhalten, die die unabhängigen Gruppen innerhalb der Kirchen betrieben haben, so gut wie gar nicht identifiziert haben, die einfach im Prinzip nur ihren Ausreiseantrag voranbringen wollten. Das führte zu ganz komischen Verwerfungen. Das brachte zum Beispiel auf dieser Rosa Luxemburg, Luxemburg-Liebknecht-Demo in 1987, im Februar war das Ding, ganz komische Festnahmen. Die haben da Plakate hochgerissen, ohne Ende, weil sie wussten, dass da West-Kameras sein würden. Also so eine Sendung wie Kontraste oder Monitor. Also haben sich da immer sehr, sehr stark gemacht. Da reichte denn bei Berner damals ARD-Kospondenten ein kleiner Anruf. Sie haben also überall schnell ein EB-Team aufgebaut. Und schon haben die Ausreiser irgendwie ihre Transparente aufgezogen. Die haben also versucht, durch irgendwelche Hanebüchen in Aktion, irgendwie ihren Ausreiseantrag zu bewilligen.
So hat der Motto, dass sie lästig genug fallen, um raufzuschauen.
Du hast genauso lange gewartet wie auf dein Auto. Wenn du einen Ausreiseantrag gestellt hast, manchmal dauert das auch nur halb so schnell. Bei einigen wusste der Außenbekanntenkreis, dass es ganz schnell ging, als sie sich richtig exponiert hatten, ob im Betrieb oder in der Öffentlichkeit. Das Schlimme daran waren die Sachen, dass die Leute ab 1987 begonnen haben, zu singen wie die Vögel, wenn die festgenommen wurden. Die wurden nicht nur zum Phobos geholt, sondern auch gleich zur Sicherheit geschickt in der Normandenstraße. Die haben jede Gruppenstruktur kaputt gemacht, weil die alle Möcke erzählt haben. Die haben ihr Logen wie die Viecher, nur weil sie jetzt irgendwas für sich wichtig machend erzählen oder so, können sie ihren Ausreiseantrag beschleunigen. Und das ist natürlich was, als Sicherheitsmensch kannst du sagen, schön Dank. So, ja, das war's jetzt? Ja, natürlich war's das. Also warum soll da was passieren? So einen Menschen kann man noch mal eine Weile melken. Machen sie mal noch weiter in der Gruppe, das hört sich gut an. Das ist Wahnsinn. Aber witzig war die Leute, die halt einfach nur Schnauze voll hatten von diesem Land, die Macht haben. Ich glaube, dass der Anteil der Berliner, die Ausreiseanträge gestellt haben, vergleichsweise kleiner war als derjenige der restlichen DDR-Bürger, eben aufgrund der relativen Bevorzugung bei Versorgungsgängen.
Nein, nicht nur das. Die Ausreiseanträge waren halt im Teil der Ahnungslosen. Die hatten dann noch ein realistisches Bild davon. Das war halt auch so eine soziale Erleihung schwierig. Wenn die Leute beschlossen haben, dass sie jetzt gehen, dann waren sie plötzlich in diesem Kreis von diesen anderen Leuten, die ausreisen wollten. Das hat dann schon einen Selbsthilfegruppen-Charakter. Das entwickelt sich dann 88, 89, als ich anfing, mich ein bisschen mehr politisch zu betätigen und zu interessieren mit neuem Fonds und dergleichen Dingen. Bei uns an der Schule gab es auch ein bisschen politische Diskussionszirkel. Die Kinder, wo klar war, dass die ihren Familien-Ausreise-Antrag stellt, sind halt auch sofort von der EOS geflogen.
Die wurden dann halt in das Gymnasium. Eine der beiden Möglichkeiten, Abitur zu machen in der DDR.
Es gab halt entweder EOS, zum Beispiel Gymnasium, 11. oder 12. Klasse, oder Berufsausbildung und Abitur. Das war das, was du gekriegt hast, wenn du nicht so parteizuverlässig warst. Das habe ich gemacht, die Platze voll waren.
Ich hatte eine Anmerkung dazu. Ich hatte das A in der Klassenbuchspalte. Im Klassenbuch im Osten gab es eine Spalte für Herkunft. Da war ein I oder ein Intelligenzkind oder ein Arbeiterkind. Wenn zum Beispiel eine Zensur auf der Kippe stand oder eine Beförderungsentscheidung anstand, wurde bei einem Überhang von Intelligenzkindern ein Arbeiterkind genommen. Das ist bei mir auch der Grund, weshalb EOS, also nur weiterführende Schule, nicht so das Ding war. Bei mir klar war, als Berufsarztwirkung mit Abitur heißt es 3 Jahre Ausbildung, technische Abitur, und einen Facharbeiter zu haben. Mir war klar, das, was ich an Studenten erlebt habe, wusste relativ wenig von der Materie, weil sie noch nie in irgendeinem Betrieb gearbeitet haben. Für mich war das völlig normal. Bei PR war das was anderes, genau.
Produktive Arbeit. Im Osten der Schule hatte man zwei Fächer, die sozusagen Produktionsbezug hatten. Das eine war PR, das andere war produktive Arbeit, das andere war ESP, Einführung in die sozialistische Produktion. Und die sollten halt dazu dienen, dass du halt auch als normales Schulkind zumindest mal einen VEB, also einen Betrieb von innen gesehen hast, und da irgendwas gemacht hast. Das war halt die reine Beschäftigungstherapie. Man hat da nie irgendwas Sinnvolles gemacht. Wir haben also Stecker zusammengebaut, die dann an einem anderen Betrieb, wo die Kabel wieder angelötet wurden, wieder auseinandergebaut wurden. So völlige Beschäftigungstherapie. Dabei haben wir noch ein bisschen stanzen und drehen gelernt und feilen. Das war ganz okay, aber es war wirklich nur sehr rudimentär. Bei ESP hat man halt irgendwelche Theorie über Fertigungsverfahren und technisch Zeichnungen gelernt. Das hat aber niemand wirklich interessiert. Das war halt irgendwie so völlig vergebens. Das führt aber hin dazu, dass du schon mal so einen Volksheimbetrieb von innen gesehen hast, was dann in mir die deutlichen Motivationen bestärkte, da nie wieder hinzumüssen.
Ab in die Produktion ist eher ein Strafbegriff.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also diese Ten Stasi in die Produktion war schon so gemein.
Uns haben sie bei produktiver Arbeit mit einem Tiefbaubetrieb in Berlin genervt mit dem Reparieren von Bremszylindern von großen LKWs, von diesen krassen LKWs und von dem Reparieren von Presslofthämmern. Das heißt natürlich auch, dass du im Winter als Jugendlicher, APA war ein Dreiviertel-Tag, wir sind in der 8. und 9., sind wir noch mal 2 Stunden danach, in eine Schule gefahren und alles andere war bis dahin, ich glaube in der 7., ich fing das an und da war dann, glaube ich, frei. War eigentlich ein ganzer Tag oder ein halber Tag. Das heißt, dass du als Jugendlicher, als heranwachsendes Kind sozusagen, in eine komischen Wattejacke im Winter in irgendeinen Bauwagen kommst, wo halt wirklich wie in einem Manne-Krug-Film aus den 60er Jahren oder so irgendein Boller rufend in diesem Wagen steht und der Meister hat noch die Flasche Korn auf dem Tisch oder so. Und dann, weißt du, Paul, jetzt hier da, komm, jetzt können wir nochmal anfangen. Was ist denn los hier? Man dauert wieder, aber es ist nicht so schlimm. So, und das ist also natürlich auf der anderen Seite präglich das Ganze genauso. Das ist sowas, das hätte ich sonst nie wieder gesehen. So, oder überhaupt nie, nicht wieder. Ich wollte das danach, wenn ich das gesehen habe, da wollte ich da auch nicht hin. Das ist klar.
Frühwarnsystem.
Ja, bleibt beim Frühwarnsystem.
Wo es hier ja doch eine Intelligenz kennt, war. Ach, die Arbeit, nee. Was wir jetzt die ganze Zeit so ausgeklangert haben, bevor wir dann vielleicht noch kurz auf diese Wendezeit kommen sollten, aber so dieses, dieser Moloch Stasi, dieses Gegenseitige überwachen und befragen und aushorchen. Also ich weiß noch genau, als ich das erste Mal Stasi-Geruch um mich herum hatte, ich habe mal die Gelegenheit genutzt, auf die Leipziger Messe zu fahren. Das war also eine dieser wenigen Möglichkeiten, ohne lange Visa-Beantragungen in die DDR zu reisen. Da konnte man halt einfach an die Grenze fahren und sagen, ich will auf die Messe. Dann gilt das als Messegast, und dann kriegst du direkt an der Grenze da deinen Stempel und durftest halt hin. Du musst natürlich sagen, wo du irgendwie unterkommst und blabla. Aber das war irgendwie alles organisiert. Ich kann es nicht mit Sicherheit sagen, aber es war sehr wahrscheinlich. Ich hatte dann das lustige Ereignis, dass wohl offensichtlich die Karawane von Erich Honecker, der gerade diese Messe eingerichtet hat, an mir vorbei fuhr. Weil auf einmal halt eine lange Karawane von schwarzen russischen Autos an mir vorbei fuhr.
Na damals wahrscheinlich schon die Volvos, die großen Pullmans, 244 und so weiter. Dunkelblau, aber egal.
Das kann gut sein, das weiß ich jetzt. Das war definitiv keine Trabant- und Wartburg-Aufreihung. Alles schön schwarz. Es hatte so ein bisschen was von Sonnenfinsternis. Als ich mal meine Sonnenfinsternis erlebt habe, war das auch ähnlich. Es wurde so ein bisschen dunkel und dann kommt so ein bisschen Wind auf. Es wird so die Vögelhörn aufzusingen. Dann wird es so ein bisschen frischer. Dann zieht da so ein bisschen der Wind durch und dann ist auf einmal auch wieder alles weg. In dem Moment war es halt einfach so, dass auf einmal diese Leute da auftauchten. Auf einmal standen so im 50-Meter-Abstand überall so Leute.
Welcher siebte Sinn hat dich eigentlich dazu veranlasst, zu wissen, dass es sich dabei umso handelt? Das ist eine rhetorische Frage. Natürlich erkennt man diese Leute an ihrer Hosennad, an der Bügelfalte.
Ich hatte keinerlei Kenntnisse damals, muss ich sagen. Keine Erfahrung und ich habe mich auch nicht damit irgendwie beschäftigt und so weiter. Ich konnte mir das danach erst nur selber zusammen, aber erst einmal tauchten diese Leute auf. Alle sollen so blazern oder Windjacken oder ich weiß nicht ganz genau. Und danach waren sie dann auch irgendwie alle wieder weg. So und das war dann offensichtlich dieses Stasi-Spalier, was da irgendwie so den Honika durch die Stadt kutschiert hat. Das heißt, wo der auch lang fuhr, wurde da so ein virtueller Begleiteppich da irgendwie noch mitgefahren. So und das war sozusagen meine erste reale Begegnung mit diesem System. Ich hatte nicht so viele danach. Aber jetzt, wie präsent war das? Also ich meine, dass es so etwas gab, das wusste ja jeder.
Also es war halt schon insofern präsent, als wenn du dich halt, also wenn du irgendwie was getan hast, was außerhalb der Norm war oder irgendwie davon gehört hast, dass das irgendwas außerhalb der Norm war, dann war das halt nie fern. Also die waren ja überall drin, also auch in den Betrieben drin, in den Bildungseinrichtungen drin und so. Und es war halt auch immer so ein bisschen absichtlich blurry, die Trennlinie so zwischen Partei und Stasi. Und ob du jetzt irgendwie von der Partei irgendwie, oder von der sozusagen nicht Sicherheitsstruktur oder von der Stasi halt so da herangenommen wirst, das war halt, oder Polizei war halt absichtlich immer so ein bisschen, die haben sich auch nie vorgestellt mit guten Tag statt Sicherheit, das war sehr selten so, sondern meistens gar nicht so. Also das war halt auch immer so ein...
Wir sind irgendwie der Staat und du weißt es und du fragst es.
Wenn so jemand beim Zeichenunterricht in der Schule so, wir malen unsere Eltern im Beruf oder so, dann hat aus der Parallelklasse der eine, von dem wir das wussten, der hatte halt immer einen Volkspolizisten, der für seinen Vater nie so ein Ding anhatte. Aber das war halt so einen, die zwei, wenn irgendwann drauf gekommen sind, das muss was anderes sein, was der meint.
Also es war halt so, dass der, also bei mir in der Schule, weil ich war halt im Friedrichshain in der Schule, das heißt, das war schon so der Ernstungsgebiet von einer Mannstraße. Da waren halt ein paar auch Kinder von Stasi-Eltern, also die halt hauptamtliche Stasis waren.
Die haben da auch viel gewohnt.
Ja, die haben einfach gewohnt. Die haben da irgendwo gearbeitet, da wollten sie halt irgendwo in ein Fahrrad, ne, klar. Und das war dann, da stand dann im Klassenbuch, da stand immer was Angestellter, war halt irgendwie so der Standard, also die Bezeichnung, die Berufsbezeichnung der Eltern war halt Angestellter. Das ist noch eine ganz andere, keine nähere Bezeichnung des Betriebes oder so. Normalerweise war es halt immer so, dass das schon wichtig war, zu welchem Betrieb die Eltern gehörten, weil davon hingen ab, in welchen Ferienlager man fuhr. Weil die Ferienlager waren halt in der Regel alle irgendwie vom...
Betriebsferienlager.
Betriebsferienlager, so ne.
Das war aber bei denen auch so.
Naja, die mussten sich dann halt immer irgendwas ausdenken, weil es gab halt keine Betriebsferienlager der Stassicherheit. Nicht? Die haben dann halt immer die Plätze bei irgendwelchen anderen requiriert und denen die Ressourcen, die ihre Ferienlager hatten, zugeschoben, damit die Kinder damit unterkamen. Das war dann halt so das Spiel, was die da gespielt haben. Die haben halt auch immer versucht, das nicht so raushängen zu lassen im Alltag. Die Neubauten waren aufgangweise wundende, die Stasi-Mitarbeiter, alle unter sich, weil die dann halt einfach, naja, hat irgendwie so den Soziotrop.
Der Freundeskreis ist dann auch Stasi.
Ja, das war dann halt häufig auch so, dass dann auch häufig beide Elternteile bei der Stasi waren, weil deren Soziotrop halt eben auch relativ abgeschlossen war. Also die waren halt, die kannten halt wie nicht andere Leute. Weil die konnten halt nichts sagen, die konnten halt nichts erzählen. Und wenn sie erzählen sollten, was bei sich im Betrieb war, mussten sie halt an der Welt ausdenken, das geht halt nicht lange gut.
Und am Ende findet man auch seine Lebenspartner am Arbeitsplatz.
Ja, genau. Das war keine offizielle Politik, aber das war halt schon durchaus gewünscht. Also es gab dann halt auch irgendwie Tanzveranstaltungen und dergleichen Dinge mehr, um halt irgendwie sicherzustellen, dass die dann jemand aus mit dem hinreichenden Zufall der Sicherheitsgrad, der irgendwie versteht, wieso sie am Ambrutz nichts von der Arbeit erzählen dürfen und so. Also das war halt durchaus, also du musst ja so verstehen, dass das halt so ein, also nicht nur im Sinne der, die waren da halt so, sondern das war halt auch relativ abgeschlossen und abgekapselt.
Okay, und die waren dann bei dir im Einzugsgebiet der Schule. Und wie hat sich das geäußert?
Na, wir hatten halt glaube ich fünf oder so oder sechs Angestellte, ohne Betriebsbezeichnung im Klassenbuch halt in der, so im Umkreis.
Wie groß waren die Klassen?
25 waren wir.
Also davon fünf Stasi?
Der Klassenstufel, das waren halt zwei Klassen. Also zweieinhalb pro Klasse zusammen. Naja, ich meine, das äußerte sich dann halt auch schon in solchen Kleinigkeiten, wie das sie den ganzen Tanz mit irgendwie den Parteiversammlungen und so und den Appellen und so ein bisschen ernster genommen haben, weil man dann halt immer riskieren musste, dass dann irgendwie das Kind von einem Straßengeneral damit in der Klasse ist. Und wenn das dann zu Hause erzählt, dass das halt irgendwie mit der Appell heute wieder total sloppy war und halt irgendwie niemand sich irgendwie da ernsthaft um die Fahnen gekümmert hat und so, sondern... Was ist das? Zu Anlässen gab es halt einen Appell. Also meistens zu irgendwelchen Jahrestagen oder so. Da traten dann halt alle in Klassenblockweise im Karree hinten auf dem Schulhof an. Dann wurde Fahnen gehisst, dann wurde noch ein bisschen gesungen oder Trompete gespielt. Irgendjemand hat eine Rede gehalten, dann hat noch jemand eine Rede gehalten, dann hat noch ein bisschen Fuh gemacht und dann wurde die Fahne gehalten.
Und so, halt Appell.
Fahnen-Appell.
Nicht mal ohne Trompete?
Da gab es halt verschiedene Ausprägungen. Es gab halt Schulen in Arbeit dagegen, wo niemand interessiert hat. Das war mehr so ein 5-Minuten-Grüßen und alle wieder nach Hause, bzw. zum Unterricht. Und dann gab es halt welche, wo der Anteil von Kindern aus solchen Bevölkerungsschichten, die wiederum staatstreuer sein mussten, höher war. Und da haben sie das dann richtig ernst genommen und durchgezogen. Weil wiederum die Lehrer und der Parteifolge einer Schule nicht riskieren wollten, dass irgendjemand über sie petzt, dass sie viel sloppy sind.
Womit der Cyberspace natürlich auch gleich wieder bestärkt wird und sie das Gefühl haben, dass ja dann auch alle mitmachen. Oder haben die sich da keine Illusionen gemacht?
Ich glaube, die haben nicht viel Illusionen gemacht.
Das ist im Nachhinein dieses ganze Quatsche von wegen. Was wusste Honecker eigentlich wirklich und so weiter? Das ist alles Unsinn. Mein Alter hat mir glücklicherweise mal irgendwann mit einer Aktion die Augen geöffnet. Wir sind irgendwann mal nach die B2, glaube ich. Ist das die, die nach Bernau fährt oder so? Also ein Teil der Strecke, die Honecker damals nach Wandels zurückgelegt hat. Da gibt es ein paar Orte, oder gab es, wo man sehen konnte, dass die Renovierung der Fassaden genau bis in den zweiten Stock vorangeschritten ist. Das ist genau die Höhe, die du, wenn du aus dem Wolbrow-Fenster nach oben rausguckst, noch sehen kannst. Bis dahin hat die Farbe erreicht und dem Honecker musste ja ein blühendes Land gezeigt werden. Und da hatte ich irgendwann verstanden, mein Gott, wir haben Potemkinche-Dörfer in unserem eigenen verdammten Land. Hier spielen sie also genau denselben Kram. Okay, es gibt bestimmt ein paar Triseln in dieser Regierung, die einen jetzt so nicht wussten. Ansonsten kann man aber, wie man durch Sichtung von Stasi-Unterlagen oder so sehen kann, dass einige Lageeinschätzungen verdammt präzise und verdammt genau sind. Besonders an Stellen, wo es sie wirklich interessiert hat, wo sie glaubten, dass die Ausstrahlung auf den Westen oder auf die Ausstrahlung auf noch mehr DDR-Bürger sehr groß ist oder nicht gewünscht ist oder unbedingt zu verhindern ist, da haben sie natürlich relativ viele Leute hingeschickt. Und da gab es dann auch so Mr. und Mrs. Smith Situationen, also Ehepaare, die halt beides, IEMs oder IEMBs waren, bei der Sicherheit. Und das voneinander nicht wussten, die also über den anderen erzählt haben. Also die Verifikationsmechanismen haben sie also mit in dieses System eingebaut. Kontakt hatte ich, oder um das exemplarisch an Ihnen klarzumachen, ich wollte irgendwann mal Modellsegel fliegen, und da gab es eine Schularbeitsgemeinschaft bei uns. Da konnte ich dann ab der 7. mit teilnehmen und habe dann irgendwie ein Jahr lang ein bisschen Segler gebaut und so. Der Agit-Leiter hat uns immer gedrängt, ihr müsst doch mal auf einen Wettbewerb fahren. Wir können doch hier nicht immer nur Beißerholz verbrauchen, da müssen wir doch Valut dafür ausgeben, also Westdelt letztlich. Wenn es vielleicht auch nur nach Kuba geht und das eigentlich auch mit Maschinenteilen aus der DDR, wo die DDR ins Juht war, bezahlt worden ist. Aber ihr müsst es verstehen, wir müssen dafür Ergebnisse zeigen. Wenn du da weitermachen wolltest, länger als ein Jahr mitmachen, musstest du da irgendwann mal mit deinem kleinen Sehler auf einem Wettbewerb gewesen sein. Diese ganze Sache ist in der GST, in dieser Gesellschaft für Sport und Technik, einer vormilitärischen Organisation organisiert gewesen. Diese ganzen Massenorganisationen, ob das der Frauenverband war oder die Gesellschaft für deutsch-sowjetische Freundschaft und all diese Dinge, das waren im Prinzip so Kaderabschöpfungssachen. Wenn irgendjemand sich besonders exponiert hat, oder zum Beispiel nicht wie Ecke Modellsege fliegen, sondern richtig Sege fliegen machen wollte, oh, ganz schlimm, der könnte ja mit dem Ding nach Westen abhauen. Dann wurde so ein Verein oder so, wurde natürlich noch mehr durchsetzt, ist klar. Richtig Sege fliegen konntest du nur, wenn du wirklich voll Mitglied in der GST geworden bist. Das heißt also auch eine Ausbildung mit dem Kleinkaliber AK-47 und so ein Kram alles. Was ich damit sagen will, ist, dass diese in dem Maße, wie diese Pyramide aufgebaut ist, haben die, also wurde ihnen erschienen, dass es wichtig ist, dass man darüber Bescheid weiß, wie da einzelne Details laufen, haben sie das durch sozusagen eigene Sicherungsbolzen genügend durchsetzt gehabt oder so. Man hat also so eher die, wie soll man das sagen, so die eher peinlichen Sachen, so die Leute, die da aufgrund ihrer schlechten Kleidung oder wie du vorhin gesagt hast, mit den Blazern oder Trenchcoats oder so erkennst oder so. Viele solcher Sachen wären einfach auch so gemacht worden sein, dass man sie wirklich erkennt oder so. Während die Leute, die wirklich wichtige Informationen weitergegeben haben oder so, das waren halt Leute, denen du das leider nicht angesehen hast, die auch noch mitten in der Nacht in irgendwelchen Diskussionsgruppen gesessen haben und sich über die weltpolitische Lage mit dir unterhalten haben und noch nachts irgendwelche Pamphlete mit unterschrieben haben oder so. Dass in solchen Gruppen solche Leute auch anwesend sind, das war etwas, wie gut die sich verstecken können hinter einer Menge Heuchelei und Lüge. Das ist eigentlich, was ich im Nachhinein sagen muss, das habe ich sehr lange unterschätzt, das hätte ich so nicht gedacht. Das habe ich erst durch das Studium der Stasi-Unterlagen, durch eine Forschungssache, konnte ich um ein paar andere Sachen reingucken, erst nachdem ich das gelesen habe, habe ich einen Eindruck davon bekommen, wie stark solche Sachen durchgesetzt waren. Also wo sie gemerkt haben, dass es eine Ausstrahlung geben könnte, oder wir hatten irgendwann noch die Möglichkeit, mit Radio 100 zusammenzuarbeiten, und dann hatten wir Kassettenbeiträge, Radiosendungen produziert und rübergeschickt. Und so was lief dann da. Und so Sachen finden sich natürlich in den Stasi-Unterlagen. Da wussten sie sehr genau, Öffentlichkeit und Gottes Willen bloß nicht. Im Umkehrschluss hieß das für uns oder für mich an der Stelle, unser Schutz ist Öffentlichkeit an der Stelle. Was auch immer wir herausfinden, wir dürfen es nicht für uns behalten. Das ist also, was aktuell WikiLeaks angeht, für mich eine sehr wichtige Parallele davon.
Also tatsächlich schützt dich die Öffentlichkeit. Bei den 100 muss man vielleicht mal kurz erwähnen, dass so ein West-Berliner Radiosender, der sehr alternativ geprägt war, sich dem Politischen da sehr viel mehr zugewendet hat, als man das heute so kennt. Und ja, du bist ja sozusagen einer dieser Sendungszuträger, weil das war ja dann sozusagen lange Zeit so ein Ding, dass die halt Originalaufnahmen, Mitschnitte oder eben auch Berichte von Amateuren aus der DDR ausgestrahlt haben.
Also die Tiefe der Durchdringung halt mit den informellen Mitarbeitern, mit den offiziellen Mitarbeitern bei Gruppen, die halt irgendeine Art von Relevanz haben könnten, war halt schon teilweise enorm. Also bis hin zu einer Gruppe in Berlin, die hatten sie, wie sich dann hinterher beim Strömen der Akten feststellte, die hätten sie per Mehrheitsbeschluss auflösen können. Mehr IM als andere Leute drinnen. Also das sind halt einfach so Sachen, die da braucht man dann auch eine Weile zu realisieren und damit klarzukommen sind. Häufig genug wartet es auch so, dass die Grenzen dann halt auch sehr schwimmend waren. Also wieso die Leute dann halt Sachen erzählt haben. Häufig genug waren deren Motivationen halt auch sehr unscharf. Es war halt nicht immer, dass die böse waren oder so, sondern dass die möglicherweise deine politischen Ziele teilten, aber halt irgendwie erpresst wurden. Oder dass sie halt möglicherweise halt dachten, dadurch, dass sie halt mit der Stasi reden, können sie halt sozusagen die Position näher bringen. Also so ein Dialog waren. Die Stasi natürlich alles fein kategorisiert und irgendwie aufgeschlüsselt, was die Motivationen sind und die dann halt entsprechend in den richtigen Knöpfen gedreht. Und die, also am Ende war dann halt immer so, dass sie halt auch immer die Materialienmittel hatten, dadurch, dass der Alltag halt so kontrolliert war. Und du zum Beispiel dann deinen Arbeitsplatz zugeteilt bekommen. Also du hast nicht viel Einfluss darauf, was dein Arbeitsplatz war, sondern du hast ihn halt zugewiesen bekommen. Du konntest natürlich versuchen, über Freunde zu gucken, dass sie dich, dass du dahin kommst oder so. Da gab es auch manche, auf die man sich bewerben konnte, aber das endete halt zum Beispiel damit, dass ein gemeinsamer Freund von uns, der war halt Fördner. Also ein intellektuell hochkalibrierter Mann, der halt einfach viele Jahre seines Lebens als Fördner verbracht hat, weil er halt irgendwie in der Position tätig war. Und das haben sie dann abgeschoben. Und Martin Neuer hat teilweise seine Uhr abzulesen. Und so ging es halt vielen Leuten, die halt einfach dann, dadurch, dass die Kontrolle über den Alltag so total war, konnten sie dich halt auch erpressen. Das war halt dann auch so, dass zum Beispiel in Berlin hier gab es einen Ableger vom VW-Möbelkombinat, den haben sie benutzt. Die haben sie genutzt, um ihre eigenen Leute, wenn die ihnen politisch unzuverlässig wurden, also Stasi-Leute, die haben sie alle dahin gesteckt. Die haben dann da Möbel produziert. Der Abteilungsleiter war halt irgendwie ein ehemaliger Stasi-General, der halt in Ungnade gefallen war, weil er halt irgendwas falsch gemacht hat oder irgendwie seine Meinung nicht opportun war oder was auch immer.
Möbel aus den Händen, unzuverlässiger Ex Stasi-Mitarbeiter.
Genau. Also das war so, eben genau diese Alterskontrolle erzeugte eben auch so viel Erpressbarkeit. Also du warst halt, wenn du in den Fokus der Aufmerksamkeit geraten bist, warst du von deren Gnade abhängig. So und wenn du dann halt nicht gesagt hast, ja Gott, dann bin ich halt fördner und verbringe den Rest meines Lebens mit lesen, weil es war ja nicht klar, dass die Wende kommt. Die Perspektive war ja, das geht immer so weiter. Also bis irgendwie 88 war die Perspektive die Ewigkeit, nicht irgendwie, sind noch zwei Jahre. So, da muss man sich immer wieder vergegenwärtigen so. Ich meine, es war ja auch nicht so, dass irgendwie, als dann die Wende kam, klar war, dass sie nicht schießen. Das war überhaupt nicht klar. Also es war mitnichten so. Also irgendwie, als dann im Oktober halt die Demonstrationen waren und sie da halt losgeknüppelt haben und die Leute eingeknastet haben und in irgendwelchen Garagen eingefärcht haben und so. Ne, vorher.
Achso, du meinst, nach 6. oder 7. Oktober hat das große Ding, die Knüppelei auf der Schönhause, und da fahre eine Menge los. Ansonsten vorher die Sachen in, ne, doch, das war Berlin, nicht Leipzig.
Die erste große Geschichte war ja nicht die Demos in Leipzig. Das war ja nicht so. Das war eben die Demonstration, um die geht es immer in die Kirche da, wo sie halt echt zugelangt haben. Und nach heutigen Maßstäben des 1. Maies war das wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie eher...
Ja, ansonsten war es ja alles sehr sicher, in Anführungsstrichen. Es war ja keine besonders gewalttätige Atmosphäre jetzt in DDR vorherrschend auf den Straßen.
Nee, das nicht. Es gab halt Ausnahmen, bei den Fußballspielen. Das war halt so, dass bei den Fußballspielen, das entglitt ihnen zusehend so.
So ein Hooliganismus oder wie?
Da hat sich das halt sehr entladen. Und das war halt für die Stasi auch ein großer Sorgenpunkt. Und wenn es halt kleine Demonstrationen gab, meistens aus dem Kirchenkontext raus, wenn gerade kein Westreporter-Team da war, oder selbst wenn da eins da war, dann haben sie halt immer mit massiver Übermacht agiert. 20 oder so waren dann gleich 200, um so 50 Leute einzusacken oder so. Sie haben halt immer versucht, mit einer großen massiven Einschüchterung die Situation gar nicht erst zu einer längeren Auseinandersetzung eskalieren zu lassen, sondern ging halt immer darum, die möglichst schnell von der Straße zu kriegen, bevor es irgendwie öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit erregt. Also spezifische Westmedien-Aufmerksamkeit. Darum ging es eigentlich immer nur so. Innerhalb der DDR gab es ja eben keine Informationsverbreitungsmöglichkeiten.
Ja, naja, bis auf die kirchliche Information mit diesem schönen Ding immer nur zu innerkirchlichen Informationen. Als wenn da mit der Freibrief verteilt worden wäre, dass man das jetzt rumreichen kann. Aber immerhin wurde damit klargemacht, also das, was da drinne steht, wer selbst findet nicht nach Presserecht der DDR möglich ist, ist ja nur zu innerkirchlichen Informationen. Also dieser Stempel war so ein kleiner Freibrief. Und da findet man selbst in den von der offiziellen Kirchenleitung herausgegebenen Sachen und noch nicht mal in den von Gruppen herausgegebenen Pampleten, findet sich so ab 1987 Hinweise darauf, dass DDR auf jeden Fall auch mit Skins-Erfahrungen gemacht wurde. Und das ist eine Sache, da hat sich die Sicherheit auch bemüht. Also die Ostpunks haben einerseits zwar auch gelitten, aber das waren immer eher so ein bisschen verirrte Jugendliche, die den Flausentrem bei den Langhaien mal noch aus. Das gab es ja irgendwie in jedem Zeitalter. Das mit den Rechten fanden sie gar nicht gut. Denn die DDR ist ein per Definition anti-faschistischer Staat gewesen. Das heißt also alle, die nach dem 7. Oktober 1949 auf Ostdebit gewesen sind, sind per Verfassung, denn wir hatten ja eine anders als ihr, anders als wir. Wir haben ja leider keine. Wir haben ja nur ein Grundrecht, ein Grundgesetz. Die Verfassung der DDR hat also sozusagen alle Bürger entfaschistisch, entschuldigung, genau, richtig. So, dass man sich also darüber keine Gedanken machen musste. Und umso komischer war das oder umso merkwürdiger war das, dass auf einmal solche auftauchten. Und getreu dem Motto, wie schon erwähnt, was nicht sein darf, das nicht sein kann, gab es natürlich so was nicht. Also sie versuchten sehr, das klein zu halten. So die Stadien-Szene, da habe ich nicht so den Einblick. Aber Dynamo und Unionwissig waren dann schon immer doch eher so die ganz kurze Schorenden. Und halt natürlich auf den Dörfern, ach ja, Schwermut und wenig Aussichten in der Landwirtschaft zu arbeiten. Es sind überall dieselben Gründe, ökonomische letztlich, die halt irgendwie zu so was führen, um so was aufkeimen lassen zu können.
Na ja, heute stimmt es. Die Sachen mit den Nazis, gerade in Ostberlin, die wurde so 88, 89 dann schon ziemlich akut. Das war dann auch so, dass es da immer wieder auch Übergriffe gab, auf ausländische Arbeiter, weil es gab ja eine Menge kubanische Arbeiter zum Beispiel hier.
Und Vietnamesen.
Genau, die hatten dann schon teilweise unter den Nazis echt zu leiden. Die Stasi hat dann auch wirklich zugegriffen, das kann man nicht anders sagen. Sie haben das halt massivst unterdrückt. Aber das hat natürlich auch nicht erholfen. Die waren halt auch nicht wirklich überall. Wir haben natürlich versucht zu unterwandern, also die ganzen Standardmethoden anzuwenden, aber sie waren glaube ich auch sehr verwirrt darüber, dass in ihrem antifaschistischen Staat sich da plötzlich Neonazis tun würden.
Jetzt hast du gesagt, die Stasi waren nicht überall.
Sie waren halt schon sehr flächendeckend da, aber in bestimmten Szenen, die abgekapselt waren, war halt schwer reinkommen. Die Nazis untereinander, du hast ja gesehen, wie die Leute zur Wende gekleidet waren. Das war ja doch eine relativ uniforme Angelegenheit. Die Bandbreite von Kleidungsvarietät war jetzt nicht besonders groß.
War halt dieses chemische Stonewashed-Jeans-Jacken-Ding zum Beispiel.
Domestos, das gab es ja noch.
Die komischen Blazer und diese ganzen Sachen. Und wenn du dich dann als Skinhead verkleidest, was ein ziemlicher Aufwand war, im Osten an die Sachen ranzukommen, dann bist du schon mal krass exponiert. Du bist dann schon mal per Definition Außenseiter, genauso wie du als Punk im Osten per Definition schwer diskriminierter Außenseiter warst. Du hast dich dann damit weitaus mehr als jetzt, wenn jetzt ein Punk in der Stadt rumläuft. Na ja, Gott, interessiert halt niemand. Damals war das schon so ein echter Hingucker. Das passierte halt. Du hast halt über Kleidung sehr viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit erregt. Und bei den Nazis war das halt auch nicht anders. Und da gab es dann halt, kann ich mich noch erinnern, gab es so eine Phase, so 87, 88, gab es eine Menge, die sich richtig so Bilderbuch-Skin-mäßig angezogen haben oder versucht haben, was halt schwierig war, mit irgendwie, also versuchte die Ost-Arbeitsschuhe so auf Hochglanz zu polieren, damit sie irgendwie aussehen wie Doc Martensboots und so. Und die wurden dann halt echt innerhalb von Wochen alle einkassiert. Und waren dann mal eine Woche weg, so irgendwie bei der Stasi oder so. Und danach haben sich dann halt alle wieder die Haare wachsen lassen und waren dann so ein bisschen unerfälliger. Und haben dann dann irgendwie so mit einer Weise Schnürsenkel und so die ganzen Kurzzeit versucht, sich sozusagen noch erkennbar zu halten für ihresgleichen, aber eben nicht mehr so auffällig zu sein, dass sie halt... Also da gab es halt auch eine Menge Subzenen, die sich dann da etabliert haben.
Wie sind wir denn jetzt dahin gekommen?
Du hast gefragt, ob die überall waren. Oder du hattest Frank zurückgeholt?
Ich bin da vorhin so ein bisschen abgelitten bei dieser ganzen Sicherheit. Und ich wollte eigentlich auch noch mal so ein bisschen verstehen, was für Aspekte es sozusagen gibt, wie diese Stasi wahrgenommen wurde und welchen Einfluss sie wirklich hatte und wie das eben auch zusammenhängt mit diesem Sättigungsgefühl, dass es allen so ein bisschen reicht, dass es von allem so ein bisschen zu schlimm ist. Was ist denn mit diesem Film hier? Das Leben der anderen. Ihr habt ja das sicherlich gesehen, oder?
Ach, ich hab mir den nicht gegeben.
Kannst du den gesehen haben?
Ja, ich finde ihn interessant, weil die Ausstattung ist sehr detailliert.
Wahrscheinlich die er noch auch gedacht hat.
Die Ausstattung ist extrem liebevoll und sehr präzise, also bis hin zu den Messgeräten, die er dann da auf seinem Dachboden stehen hat und so. Also die Geschichte ist natürlich sehr dramatisiert und fiktivisiert. Aber was er gut tut, ist eine Stimmung wiedergeben. Man merkt halt an vielen Stellen, dass er inhaltlich nicht stimmt, dass er teilweise auch einfach nicht ging, so was die da gemacht haben. Das sind dann so Details aus bei Filme, über Sachen, wo man sich auskennt. Aber diese Stimmung, wenn du dich exponiert hattest, dass du dann halt in dieser permanenten Ungewissheit warst, das bringt der Film sehr gut rüber. Also dass die Leute dann einfach nicht mehr ruhig schlafen konnten, weil die halt auch fertig gemacht haben, nur die Stasi ausgespielt hat. Die haben dann halt mal eine Woche lang die observiert und sie dann acht Wochen in Ruhe lassen und dann wieder observiert.
Und sie spülen lassen.
Oder halt, weiß nicht, wenn das Telefon mal abgehört war, die haben sich halt häufig nicht die Mühe gemacht, das so anzuzapfen, dass es halt nicht knackte. Keine Ahnung, die Verwandtungen haben sie halt durchaus auch gemacht. Der Aufwand ist halt relativ hoch. Deswegen war das jetzt nicht Flächendecken, sondern mehr so...
War dann die Stasi mehr ein Einschüchterungswerkzeug oder ging es eigentlich wirklich noch um Informationsbeschaffung? Oder hatten die auch schon dieses Problem, dass ihre Informationen dann nicht mehr so richtig...
Die haben die nicht mehr vollständig verarbeitet und ausgewertet bekommen. Die haben ja da ein Monster-Computer-Projekt nach dem anderen angeschoben, um halt irgendwie da ihre Sachen verarbeitet zu bekommen. Das hat auch irgendwie ihr Denken beeinflusst. Also die Geschichte müssen wir vielleicht nochmal erzählen. Also hier im Umfeld bleibt der Telegraf, also die DDR-Oppositionszeitung. Da haben sie natürlich massiv beobachtet. Und irgendwann suchten sie dann einen Amiga 500, der, glaube ich, von den Grünen in Westberlin kam. Und auf dem halt irgendwie die Umweltblätter hergestellt wurden, in einem lustigen Verfahren.
Was heißt Umweltblätter?
Also de facto würde man heute sagen eine Zeitschrift, die aber halt so aussieht. Also halt so eine Loseblattsammlung, die halt auf einem Ormic-Kopierer hergestellt ist. Das ist halt so ein Tintenlöseverfahren, wo so eine Wachsmatratze eingespannt und dann so durchgedudelt wird.
Die man früher so kopieren gemacht hat.
Genau, und die Wachsmatratze wurde in einem P6-Nadel-Drucker eingespannt, sodass halt die Nadeln in die Wachsmatratze reingehämmert haben.
Das waren denn die hier, also das war noch richtig Ormic, also Spiritus.
Das war noch Spiritus-Ormic-Drucker, genau. Das hier war, ja, das war dann schon richtig gedruckt.
100er-Auflage, 1000er-Auflage etwa.
Was war denn hier jetzt das Umweltblätter?
Na, die Organisation, die hier rausging, war die Umweltbibliothek und war halt eine kirchliche, ursprünglich eine kirchlich organisierte Umweltschutzgruppe. So was daraus entstandet halt.
Der Hintergrund war einfach der, dass Umweltinformation, also vor allen Dingen quantifizierte Umweltinformation, Messwerte praktisch nicht erhältlich waren, sondern eigentlich nur für die Leute, die in den Messstellen gearbeitet haben. Wenn man sowas flächendeckend hat, dann kann man natürlich über den Zustand von bestimmten Sachen sehr gut Aussagen treffen. Oder wenn man auch nicht flächendeckend arbeitet, sondern nur den Grundwasser-Messstand und Nitrat in der Nähe einer Müllkippe hat, dann weiß man auch ziemlich genau, ob man das Trinkwasser zu Säuglingsnahrung verarbeiten kann oder nicht.
Oder Tschernobyl war zum Beispiel auch ein Riesentreiber für die ganze Bewegung.
Ganz auf jeden Fall. Da haben sich auch hier eine Menge Sachen geändert. Von wegen welchen Standard haben wir denn eigentlich? Wir verwenden doch offenbar auch sowjetische Atomkraftwerke, wie müssen wir denn jetzt davon ausgehen? Was ist denn hier mit unseren Forschungsreaktoren und so?
Und wie viel Redaktivität kam denn hier tatsächlich an? Also weil irgendwie Riechornicke, meine Mutter, den Salat auch immer gewaschen hat und wirklich niemand beruhigt so. Und wenn sie halt, ich meine auch im Osten wurde klar, wenn sie sagten, es besteht keine Gefahr für die Bevölkerung, erst mal Fenster zu machen und möglichst zu sehen, dass man wegkommt. Und das hat natürlich eine Menge bewegt.
Also Umweltbewegung war sozusagen kirchlich getragen und dort haben sich dann überhaupt politisch Aktive dann auch gesammelt, weil sozusagen über Umwelt, das war noch so halbwegs akzeptabel, da konnte man jetzt nicht so ohne weis was sagen.
Ja, das war, also Umwelt- und Friedensbewegung waren halt beide zu Sachen.
Wie auch im Westen.
Ja, hier hat man sie bei der russischen Bewegung, so derzeit wahrscheinlich alle ähnlich entstanden. In der DDR hat das halt in der Kirche häufig, vor allen Dingen in der evangelischen Kirche ein Dach gefunden, weil das mit dem Anspruch der einiger aufgeklärter Pastoren oder so zusammenkam. Die also wollten, dass bestimmte Sachen einfach von ihrer Kirchengemeinde ausgehen. Bewahrung der Schöpfung ist für die Kirche, sofern sie sich ernst und regelmäßig, ein Thema gewesen. Und Leute, die ein bisschen aufgeschlossener sind, gerade so Junge wie Kare, die danach gewachsen sind, die die junge Gemeinde geleitet haben oder so, die hatten auf jeden Fall für solche Sachen ein Ohr, haben dann unter Umständen auch die Infrastruktur der Kirche für solche Sachen zur Verfügung gestellt. Naja, und uns war irgendwie klar, es ist notwendig, dass man die unterdrückten Umweltinformationen der DDR irgendwie mal zusammenfasst und in andere Richtungen hinaus posaunt oder so. Und da sind über die Jahre dann eine ganze Menge Sachen hochgekommen, so zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, wie in den Tagebaugeschichten. Also die DDR hat sehr wenig Rohstoffe gehabt, aber zum Beispiel Braunkohle. Aber diese Braunkohleförderung war halt eine unglaubliche Umweltsauerei, wie sie in der DDR durchgeführt wurde. Dann gab es halt so in Bitterfeld, wir haben immer gesagt, das Todesdreieck, also Bitterfeldhalle, Leuna, wo ein Teil unserer petrochemischen Industrie stand, da gab es halt diesen Silbersee, also ein See, der im Prinzip, naja, da kann man gar nicht sagen, Wolfen, was da alles für Umweltsauereien passierte. Und wenn man so was zusammenträgt, dann passieren ganz komische Effekte. Durch diese Exponierung bin ich dann irgendwann auch sehr ins Schussfeld gekommen. Das ist also der Hintergrund, letztlich so der Idee der Umweltblätter und die Kirche. Einerseits war ich zwar daran interessiert, andererseits hat es aber auch überhaupt nur die Möglichkeit geboten, sich regelmäßig zu treffen. Oder in eine Privatwohnung sowas zu machen, war immer so eine schwierige Sache. Du konntest den Kreis nicht mal eben so erweitern, jemand Neues in eine Privatwohnung einzuführen, der als einem heiklen Thema arbeitet, von dem alle wissen, dass man das jetzt doch lieber nicht so öffentlich trägt, weil es auch morgen noch nicht in der Zeitung steht, sondern man ja selber dafür sorgen möchte, dass es überhaupt mal bekannt wird. Das hat auch immer die Möglichkeit geboten, dass sich ein U-Boot mit einschleust. Und dann natürlich so eine Arbeit nach relativ kurzer Zeit kaputt gemacht wird.
Na gut, um noch die Geschichten abzuschließen. Die Herstellung von diesen Umweltblättern war natürlich immer problematisch, weil es gab keine Kopiertechnik im Osten. Normale Fotokopierer waren halt streng reguliert. Das gab es eigentlich fast nie. Und wenn, dann war das halt mit Seitenzähler und abgeschlossen und in einem separaten Kabinett und so. Und was man halt bekam, waren halt so diese Ormik-Kopier-Dinger und noch so ähnliche Sachen. Das ging halt dann im Wesentlichen mit Technik aus dem Westen, die halt irgendwie gespendet wurde so ein bisschen. Und einer dieser Spenden war halt ein Amiga 500, auf dem mit WordPerfect damals war, haltet das Layout stattfand und um es dann halt eben auf diese Wachsmatrizen, Ormik-Geschichten dazu portieren.
Wie schreibt sich das mit dem Ormik?
Ormik, O-R-M-I-K, glaube ich.
Oder mit G, mit G hinten.
Ja, G stimmt ja richtig.
Durch das Spiritus-Umdruckverfahren heißt das. Mit Wachsmatrizen ist richtig, mit schwarzer Druckfarbe.
Aber wie wurden denn diese Ormik-Vorlagen gemacht? Ach stimmt, die wurden mehrfach ausgedruckt und dann jeweils mit dem Spiritus rausgelöst.
Genau, du hast halt dieses Eiweißpapier, diesen Träger, dieses Beschichtete und dann hast du diese Blaufolie, wo du immer mit der Schreibmaschine rumgedonnert hast.
Jedenfalls suchten sie dann halt nach diesem Computer und sie vermuteten, dass es der Zentralcomputer der DDR-Position sei.
Ein Amiga 500. In gewisser Hinsicht war das natürlich auch, wenn er diese ganzen Postillen hier produziert hat.
Wenn er eine solche Funktion erfüllt, war er es letztlich. Im übertragenen Sinne war es natürlich ein gewisser Zentralcomputer. Das ist richtig sehr interessant, dass die natürlich vor so einem Gerät und der damit verbundenen Infrastruktur so eine große Angst hatten.
Ich habe gerade mal eine Ausgabe hier geblättert. Das ist ja irgendwie 89, aber früh ist 89. Ist das irgendwie noch so Juni oder so was?
Da geht es schon an ganz schön zur Sache hier. Na ja, selbstverständlich. Da war es uns zunehmend egal, weil einfach, weil irgendetwas passieren musste. Das lag halt einfach so seit zwei Jahren.
Das heißt, wann ging es los? Also wann war, also eigentlich, wann hatte man so das Gefühl, die Dinge werden jetzt dann anders?
Also es gab halt ein paar Kerneeignisse. Also der eine war auf jeden Fall die Pirstreuker in der Sowjetunion. Also dass halt GoaTof ran kam und klar war, dass jetzt da irgendwas passiert. Da kamen halt auch Leute wieder aus der Sowjetunion, die halt irgendwie...
Ihr könntet euch nicht vorstellen. Also alle Reihe oben, da passieren gerade Dinge, das könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen.
Leute haben wieder angefangen, Russisch zu lernen, damit sie sowjetische Zeitschaften lesen können. So, weil die halt völlig anders waren. Es gab halt diese Geschichte mit dem Sputnik, das ist halt so eine Adridas Digest aus sowjetischen Zeitungen, die halt in verschiedenen Sprachen gemacht wurde. Und den haben sie halt irgendwann, wann war das? 1988?
Zum Doc-Film-Festival in Leipzig 1988 oder 1987? Scheiße, ich weiß nicht.
Aber 1988 haben sie ihn dann hier aus dem Vertrieb genommen. Also es gab ihn dann nicht mehr. Und man bekam ihn dann noch im Haus der sowjetischen Wissenschaften und Kultur so unter der Hand irgendwie. Die haben ihn dann manchmal noch im Verkauf gehabt. Dann haben wir ihn dann teilweise fotokopiert. Man muss sich vorstellen, wir haben eine sowjetische Zeitung fotokopiert. Also mit Foto, mit Fotoklack, mit Filmen und so. Weil da halt Artikel drin waren über die Massaker unter Stalin und so. Also Sachen, die wir nie gehört haben. Und die halt einfach so an den Grundfesten des sozialistischen Überlegenheitsanspruches rüttelten. So war dann schon die Geschichte halt so. Und das war ja auch das große Thema zu der Zeit in der Sowjetunion. Einfach, dass sie halt überhaupt mal ein bisschen in die Archive geguckt haben und einfach Artikel publiziert haben über diese ganze Zeit, von der wir halt nur die Legenden gehört haben. Und mal hier und da so ein paar Kleinigkeiten. Also die Massaker von Kartün zum Beispiel. Oder die ganzen Deportationen. Oder wie sie halt irgendwie mit den deutschen Kommunisten umgesprungen sind, die nach Moskau geflohen sind. Oder was sie halt im Spanienkrieg gemacht haben, wo sie halt ihre eigenen Leute massenweise masakriert haben. Nur weil die halt ein bisschen linker waren, als irgendwie gerade Stalin dort. Wollte.
Also man muss sich das auf der Großen Runde zergehen lassen. Da ist also ein sozialistisches Land in Konfrontation zu dem viel Wichtigeren, zu dem ganz Großen, zu dem Hauptsozialistischen Land gegangen, in der Anschauung über bestimmte Dinge. Also es wurden Presseorgane, also Zeitschriften aus diesem Land, in dem einen Land verboten. Obwohl noch bis kurzer Zeit zuvor gesagt wurde, von der Sowjetunion lernen heißt siegen lernen. Also alles, was von da kommt, ist auf jeden Fall gut und richtig. Und a priori immer richtig. Das wurde mit solchen Sachen das erste Mal öffentlich in Frage gestellt.
Das hat eine Menge bewegt. Ich kann mich erinnern, das muss Dezember 1988 gewesen sein, weil ich bei einem Ensemble in einem Theaterstück war. Und da gibt es dann so eine Szene, wo sie irgendwie in die...
Also drei Groschen Opa...
.sitzen halt irgendwie da in ihrem Keller und machen da irgendwas so. Und dann kommt einer rein und sagt, ja, die Polizei kommt. Die denken, hier wird der Sputnik gedruckt. Und der ist halt tot, natürlich. Weißt du, so völlig unzusammenlänglich in so einem Stück. Und dann neben uns saßen ein paar Vespa-Lieder.
Der Sputnik wird gedruckt? Ich dachte, der fliegt.
Und das war so klar für diese Atmosphäre, dass ab da war, irgendwie ging es halt nicht mehr so weiter. Wir mussten halt irgendwas tun. Und es gab auch eine Generation innerhalb der Partei von jüngeren Leuten, die damals um die 40 waren, die halt einfach gesehen haben, dass es nicht mehr geht. Da gab es dann auch schon Bestrebungen, auch teilweise innerhalb der Stasi. Also die halt versucht haben, irgendwie Möglichkeiten zu finden, an diesen alten Herren vorbei, irgendwas zu verändern. Es lag halt schon in der Luft, dass Dinge passieren werden. Nur was und wie war völlig unklar. Und ob die Sowjetunion dann nicht doch noch die Panzer aus der Garage holt, wenn jetzt hier irgendwie die Sachen anders kommen. Weil klar war in der DDR halt anders als zum Beispiel in Polen oder so, wo sich nach dem Kriegsrecht die Sachen anders etablierten, war halt immer dieses Gespenst der Wiedervereinigung da stand. Und das war halt so völlig unklar, dass die Sowjetunion dem zustimmen wird. Das war halt überhaupt nicht klar. Es war schon so, dass viele bei uns davon ausgegangen sind, dass der, wenn hier ein Umschwung, was auch immer kommt, dann wird die Sowjetunion den verhindern oder zumindest eindämmen, damit es nicht zu einer Wiedervereinigung kommt.
So Prager Frühling mäßig.
Deswegen war es halt auch so, dass viele in der DDR-Opposition von einer Wiedervereinigung eigentlich nichts wissen wollten. Und auch lange später nichts wissen wollten. Weil klar war, wenn Wiedervereinigung gleich oben auf der Überschrift steht, von den Forderungen nach einem Umschwung, dann werden die Sowjets halt auf jeden Fall nee sagen. Das war halt völlig unrealistisch. Dann war halt eher so ein, lass uns mal ihr eigenes Ding machen, eine Konfederation, irgendetwas so, eine Lösung finden, dass es hier mal anders wird. Aber es muss nicht gleich die große ganze Wiedervereinigung sein. Das erklärt halt auch so ein bisschen diese Konsterniertheit, kann man schon so sagen, als es dann 89, 90 halt alle so brutal schnell ging. Es ist dann halt nicht mal der Ansatz mehr da war, noch mal als eigene Entität zu versuchen, sondern sofort allen klar war, da geht die Reise hin.
Also wenn du fragst, wann geht das los, ist es natürlich immer die Frage, wie viele Schichten haben wir gesehen, oder wie viele Menschen der Bevölkerung haben überhaupt festgestellt, dass hier gerade was in Bewegung ist oder so. Die Anzeichen davor gab es bestimmt seit Mitte der 18er. Weißt du, wann dieser Strauß-Kredit gewesen ist, diese 14 Millionen oder so? 84. Da hat Franz-Josef Strauß irgendwie noch mal einen großen Kredit der DDR geben, vergleichsweise großen, selbst wenn sich solche Zahlen heute lächerlich ausnehmen. Was aber für die DDR essenziell gewesen ist? Du hast vorhin die Sache mit dem 1-Mega-Bitschip erwähnt. Das war eine Sache, wo die mikroelektronische Forschung der DDR versucht hat, am Weltmarkt ein Produkt zu platzieren. Wir wissen, wie schnell die Bewegung bei Speichern ist, wie überhaupt die weiter technische Weiterentwicklung und wie der Preisverfall heutzutage bei den Dingern passiert ist. Das hat sich ja damals angedeutet. Das heißt, die DDR hat diese Time-to-Market-Geschichte überhaupt nicht beherrscht. In der Zeit, wo sie das hätten massenproduzieren können, wäre es schon wieder die nächste Generation dran gewesen. Es sind also eine ganze Menge Probleme dazu gekommen, die das verhindert haben. Gleichzeitig bedeutet das aber wieder, dass außer in Berlin, überall in der Republik, haben die Leute das gespürt, dass dieses Ding gerade entwickelt wird. Das heißt nämlich, noch weniger Angebote in den Geschäften, noch weniger Schokolade. Und wir sehen all die Sachen, die nicht zum täglichen Bedarf gehören. Solche Projekte haben natürlich immer wieder die Versorgungssituationen noch schwieriger gemacht. Dazu kommen solche Sachen, der schon erwähnte Mazda 323, der in der DDR in drei- oder vierstelligen Stückzahlen rumfuhr. Da haben sie einen Fünftel der Stückzahlen, jedenfalls die Gerüchte, eingekauft, die sie nur deshalb eingekauft haben, um sie auseinanderzunehmen, damit sie Ersatzteile dafür haben. Also chronische Knappheit an allen möglichen wichtigen Sachen. In dem schon erwähnten Werk, wo ich gelernt habe, standen ein paar große Fließreihen, also riesengroße Produktionsreihen. Die sind von einer japanischen Firma gekauft worden. Die DDR konnte die natürlich nicht bezahlen. Die DDR hat sie also teilweise mit einem, ich kenne nicht die Fachbezeichnung dafür, aber mit einem Vertrag aufgekauft, der der DDR dazu verdonnerte, dass ein Teil dessen, was diese Dinger pro Monat produzieren, auf dem westeuropäischen Markt mit Dummy-Marken verkauft wird. Man konnte dann also die Produkte, die von diesen Fließreihen kaufen, als Privileg oder als, gab es noch Sylvana oder so, gab es noch andere Namen, unter denen diese Produkte auf dem Westmarkt durch die DDR vertrieben werden mussten. Ich weiß nicht, ob Japan selber einen Embargo hatte, die eigenen Produkte auf dem Westmarkt zu verkaufen, aber immerhin konnten sie, selbst wenn es so gewesen wäre, konnten sie es mit solchen Sachen umgehen. Das war aber sehr üblich, so eine Kompensationsgeschäfte, dass der Osten regelmäßig nicht mit Geld bezahlen konnte, sondern gesagt hat, aber wir haben noch einmal im Jahr richtig viel Paprika. Und das könnte er doch dann haben, oder so, wie es sich jetzt wieder andeutet.
Die internationale Tauschperse.
So ist es, genau. Und das wurde also immer häufiger. Und irgendwann erhalte mich dann mal diese Ziffer, dass der Teil des Rat für gegenseitige Wirtschaftshilfe, also für das RGW, das ist sozusagen der wirtschaftliche Verbund der sozialistischen Staaten, dass ein Handelsvolumen am Weltmarkt irgendwie ganze 3% Betrug im Anfang der 18er Jahre. Und zwar jetzt ohne um konvertible Währung zu denken oder andere Schichten, sondern nur reiner Warenaustausch. Und da ist es natürlich, ich kann so viel Sozialismus predigen, wie ich will, aber ich werde überhaupt nicht in der Lage sein, irgendwie ein ökonomisches Gewicht da drinnen zu spielen, wenn ich nur so wenig da mitreden kann. Und genau das ist das, was dann irgendwann wahrscheinlich mehr und mehr Leuten in ihren eigenen Betrieben auffiel, dass also wichtige Ersatzteile nicht mehr gekauft werden konnten, weil dann allen Ecken und Enden fehlte und solche Sachen.
Und sie haben halt auch tierisch viel Kohle in Rüstung gepulvert, muss man auch sagen.
Die Russen, die Russen.
Also in realen Zahlen waren das richtig so zweistellige Anteile vom Rote Sozialprodukt, so 14 Prozent, die tatsächlich in Rüstung gingen. Bei den Russen natürlich noch viel mehr, weil sie natürlich noch die ganze Raketenatomgeschichte, die ja noch exponentiell viel mehr aufwendiger ist. Aber auch in der DDR wurde halt ja auch Rüstungsentwicklung, also Forschung an Rüstungsgütern und so war ja sehr hochpriorisiert. Und es gab ja so eine Arbeitstellung innerhalb des RGW, also des Ostwirtschaftsverbundes. Welche Länder was machen so? Wo halt versucht wurde, so ein bisschen die Ressourcenknappheit dadurch zu mindern, dass sich ein Land spezialisiert und dann halt ein Land welche Sachen macht. Und das ist irgendwie nur die, diese Welt haben halt Flugzeuge gebaut zum Beispiel. Oder zum Beispiel die Rumänen haben PDP-11-Nachbauten gefertigt, weil sie irgendeinen Deal mit Nordkorea hatten, über den die wiederum Chips von irgendwoher bekamen, mit denen sie dann diese PDP-11s bauen konnten und so. Also das war halt alles so ein Stückwerk. Und dann haben sie halt immer noch Sachen geschmuggelt und so. Aber dieser Eklatante Mangel an allen Ecken, wenn es halt darum ging voran zu kommen, also um mal irgendwie neue Sachen zu bauen oder Infrastruktur zu erneuern, auch nur am Laufen zu halten, der fiel halt den Leuten schon extrem früh auf. Also das war überhaupt nicht zu übersehen, dass es halt irgendwelche Sachen nicht gab oder die irgendwoher beschafft und organisiert werden mussten und so. Das ist ein Praktikum gemacht in einem größeren Schwermaschinenbetrieb, so ein Schülerpraktikum im Sommer, im Rechnzentrum. Und dann wurden wir dann irgendwann eines Tages runtergerufen, sagen wir mal, Kram ausladen, standen auf dem Hof Wagen von einer österreichischen Theaterkompanie. Und da wurde dann halt eine Vex ausgeladen, und die war halt irgendwie nicht im Originalverpackung, sondern halt so mit so Tie-Wraps auf so großen Paletten, an denen noch so Tannennadeln irgendwo in den Lüftungsschlitzen stecken, weil sie offenbar irgendwo im Wald umgeladen worden waren. Das war halt so, das war normal. Also das war halt so ein Standard-Ding, irgendwie kam halt irgendwo her, so wie in einem anderen Betrieb, habe ich an einem Computer gearbeitet, das ist so ein Terminal-System, wo ich halt nie den eigentlichen Computer zu sehen bekam. Der stand halt in einem Nebenraum, der halt irgendwie mit drei Schlössern abgeschlossen war. Den habe ich nie gesehen, wenn ich den Computer booten musste, weil er ja mein Programm mal wieder gerissen hat. Dann musste ich halt den Verantwortlichen anrufen, der dann halt durch diese Tür, so eine Doppeltür reinging und dann dahinter den Computer bootete. Später habe ich mir dann erschlossen, dass das halt eine alte HP-Kiste war, die da stand, aus dem, was ich auf meinem Bildschirm gesehen habe. Das waren halt diese ganzen Einzelteile von isolierter West-Hardware oder so, oder gerade West-Software ganz viel, die dann halt kritische Sachen am Laufen hielten, die dann irgendwie noch möglich machten, dass es halt irgendwie noch geht.
Aber es war sozusagen alles nur noch Flickwerk und alles nur noch Gaffa-Tape?
Ich meine, bei den Sowjets halt noch sehr viel mehr als bei uns, weil die halt das bisschen, was sie an Hightech hatten, haben die halt alles in die Rüstung gepulvert. Das war ja so in der Sowjetunion der Abstand zwischen der normalen Industrieforschung und der Rüstungsforschung war halt so zwischen Dritte Welt und uns hier jetzt so brutal. Also die haben da echt modernes Zeug entwickelt und intelligente Lösungen entwickelt, aber halt alles für die Rüstung, alles für die Atomrüstung und so. Und Luft abwertet waren so die drei Geschichten. Und dementsprechend haben sie halt nichts mehr gehabt für den Rest. Also wenn du schon eine Scheißwirtschaft hast, die nicht besonders leistungsfähig ist und dann noch mit den Amis mithalten willst, die halt unendliche Ressourcen im Vergleich haben. Und selbst die glauben zu haben, wenn du die Infrastruktur in Amiland anguckst, selbst die hat es ja reingeritten. Also selbst die, als sie angefangen haben, Atomroketen zu bauen in großen Mengen und Atomrobote, mussten sie ihre Infrastruktur vernachlässigen. Du kannst dir vorstellen, wie es in der Sowjetunion war, wo sie nicht mal die Ressourcen hatten. Und dementsprechend...
Und im Kleinen halt auch in der DDR.
Anders als bei der Sowjetunion oder in Russland denke ich, von denen ich glaube, dass sie praktisch durch die USA totgerüstet worden sind, das ist bei uns so nicht der Fall gewesen, würde ich sagen. Ich wusste zwar nicht, wie hoch tatsächlich der Anteil der Rüstung bei uns ist, aber die Tatsache, dass es an vielen Stellen ökonomisch einfach gebröckelt hat, hat denke ich mal, ab Mitte der 18er auch die wohlmeidendsten Leute einfach von dem Ding weggebracht. Frank erwähnte das vorhin mit Motivation von Sicherheitsmitarbeitern. Da sind relativ viele dabei gewesen, wenn man nachträglich so deren Lebensläufe liest oder Stellungnahmen. Ich habe da auch privat jeweils was zugespielt bekommen von Leuten, die über mich erzählt haben. Da sind einige dabei, die tatsächlich mit dem festen Glauben an den Sozialismus die Macht haben, aber nicht weil sie uns einen einberaten wollten, sondern weil sie sagten, wir müssen diesen Menschen zuhören. Um es kurz zu machen, letztlich hat auch eine sinnvolle Kritik an so einem Staat eine systemerhaltende Funktion. Das war also für viele von den Zuträgern auch eine ganz wichtige Geschichte der Sicherheit. Insgesamt war das natürlich egal. Da ging es nur um die Informationen. Wenn man jetzt im Nachhinein die Dossiers liest oder die persönlichen, einbetreffenden Dokumente und da so irgendwelche zusammenfassenden Meldungen liest, dann merkt man sehr genau das, was auch andere Heimdienste betrifft, nämlich dass irgendwann die Menge der Informationen nicht mehr sinnvoll ausgewertet werden kann. Sie edeln sich an vielen Bereichen. Ich habe dabei auch Sachen, wo mehrere Meldestrukturen die jeweils übergeordnete Struktur wieder zusammenfassend weitermelden. Da sieht man immer, dass er sich Mühe geben, festzustellen, welche Meldungen in den verschiedenen Stadtbezirken oder Landesteilen ähnlich sind. Da gibt es überall Zusammenrottungen. Immer abends vor den Kirchen gibt es Mahnwachen. Okay, das sind gewisse Ähnlichkeiten, die kann man schon mal feststellen und zusammenfassend melden. Viele Details, die dann so passieren, die in den Betrieben spontane Demos vom Werk oder dass die Arbeiter mal eben nach dem Tag nicht gearbeitet haben, weil das Material sowieso nicht da war und weil auch ihnen keiner sagen konnte, wann es kommt. Und dann natürlich einer dafür aufs Maul gekriegt hat, weil er gesagt hat, na dann können wir doch erst mal heute nach Hause gehen, wenn du noch nicht mal weißt, ob das morgen da ist. Das kann natürlich auch nicht sein, dass die halbe Belegschaft nach Hause geht. Das sind Sachen, da merken das auch bislang unpolitische Leute. Also eine Politisierung setzt sehr stark ein, ist für mich klar geworden, durch diese selber erlebten Sachen, kann an so einen Stellen auf jeden Fall einsetzen. Da verlieren Leute auf jeden Fall den Glauben an das, was da gerade das Wirtschaftssystem darstellt.
In dem Zeitraum dann so von, also ich unterstelle jetzt mal, dass es so gegen Ende 88 quasi sich alles so sehr verdichtete, dass einfach die Einschläge irgendwie näher kamen.
Also interessant war, es war halt klar, dass irgendetwas passieren musste. Es war halt nur in keinster Weise klar, was passieren würde. Es war nicht so, dass wir das Gefühl hatten, dass dieses System so blitzartig in sich zusammenbrechen kann. Das war eigentlich, da kennt niemand, der da nicht überrascht war eigentlich. Auch im Nachhinein? Selbst als ich mit Leuten geredet habe, die halt innerhalb des Apparats...
Es gab die Internierungslager. Wir hatten alle, wesentlich rundherum um die Städte, große Teile, wo sie irgendwie pro Zelt mit Zaunen drumherum, da hätten sie pro Zelt 200 oppositionelle Rinnen und Lager, was zehnmal so viele aushält, und rundherum hätten sie gestanden. Es war alles vorbereitet. Es waren sehr defizile kleine Entscheidungen, die dazu geführt haben, dass er zum Schluss nicht mit dem Wald abgelaufen ist.
Also es war wirklich nicht so ein Zufall. Nee, also ich denke, das sind mehrere Sachen, die zusammenspielen. Zum einen war so, dass den entscheidenden Leuten ab 85, 86 klar war, dass das halt wirtschaftlich nicht mehr weitergeht, dass das halt einfach nur noch irgendwie Live-Support ist und irgendwie etwas systemisch nicht mehr funktionieren kann. Selbst mit noch einem Kredit gibt es noch mal drei Jahre, aber halt mehr nicht so. Das eine war, dass die persönliche Motivation, das System zu supporten, die bricht halt in dem Augenblick weg, wo es so aussieht, als wenn das System fällt. Der entscheidende Augenblick war halt in dem Augenblick, wo die ersten Leute angefangen haben zu sagen, ich mache erst mal zumindest nichts. Ich müsste jetzt eigentlich die Entscheidung treffen, die Panzer aus der Garage zu fahren und die Knüppel gerade loszuschicken, aber ich mache es einfach mal nicht. Ich gucke mal erst mal, was mal passiert. In dem Augenblick änderte sich dann auch die Motivation von vielen anderen. Aha, der lässt seine Panzer in der Garage. Machen wir auch mal erst mal gerade mal nichts. Und das gab dann eben den Freiraum, dass diese Demonstrationen größer wurden und dass mehr Leute gesehen haben, aha, da passiert gerade nichts.
Also eigentlich eher so eine Verkettung von Zivilcourage.
Ein wichtiger Katalysator dafür, kann man ja nicht hoch in die Luche einordnen, ist Gorbatschow selber. Er hat es bei seinem letzten Besuch, wie sich im Nachhinein durch die Aktenlage feststellen ließe, dass er eben nicht helfen wird, wenn es hier losgeht. Damit war klar, es wird hier keinen 17. Juni 1953, keinen Prager Frühling, keinen Ungarn 1957 geben. Von den Russen werden hier keine Panzer hingefahren werden. Das wussten wir natürlich nicht, aber offenbar musste die Partei- und Staatsführung oder die Zwischenschichten, die jeweils entschieden haben, wir lassen jetzt die Panzer stehen, mit motiviert haben.
Mir haben Leute erzählt, die damals in relativ entscheidenden Positionen waren, dass sie informell wiederum von ihren Freunden aus dem Apparat gehört haben, dass es Gerüchte gibt, dass die Russen nichts tun werden. Das passte auch zu dieser ganzen Perestroika-Geschichte. Das passte auch zu den Kontakten, die sie hatten in die sowjetische Armee hinein. Bei denen war die Motivation auch nicht da, hier noch einen 17. Juni zu veranstalten. Ich denke, das war ein ziemlich entscheidender Punkt, dass klar war, wenn jetzt hier was passiert, also die Demonstrationen größer werden, bleiben die Sowjets in ihren Granitionen. Das heißt, wenn, dann müssen wir das alleine wuppen. Dann müssen wir alleine mit den Volkspolizisten. Das ist ein Unterschied, ein dramatischer Unterschied, weil das sind halt die Nachbarn. Die sowjetischen Soldaten, die interessiert sind in Scheißdreck, auf wen sie gerade schießen, im Zweifel. Das sind halt nur die doofen Deutschen da draußen. Aber halt irgendwie Nachbarn auf Nachbarn schießen zu lassen, ist eine ganz andere Sache. Also das war halt dann schon klar, dass das dann durchaus zu einer bürgerkriegsähnlichen Situation eskalieren kann. Und das war halt so ein Ding, was die Leute, die dann die Entscheidung gefällt haben, nichts zu tun, gesagt haben, nee, das machen wir jetzt nicht so. Also die demonstrieren dann, es gibt jetzt keinen Grund, die sind da nur auf der Straße und tun nichts. Es gibt jetzt wirklich keinen Grund, auf die zu schießen.
Damit war ja nicht das System an seine Belastbarkeitsgrenzen gestoßen.
Es gibt ja so ganz gute Werke darüber, wann halt eine Revolution oder so ein Umschwung passiert, also was halt die kritischen Bedingungen sind. Und das ist regelmäßig so, das hat man jetzt auch bei den ganzen farbigen Revolutionen und Konterrevolutionen in der E-Mining-Sowjet-Region gesehen, dass der kritische Punkt ist eben, wenn die Demonstranten bzw. die Opposition in eine moralische Position kommt, dass signifikante Teile der Sicherheitskräfte daran zweifeln, dass es jetzt wirklich ihr Auftrag ist, die einzudämmen. In dem Augenblick kippt die Lage halt, dass genau das, was passiert ist, dass halt größere Teile der Sicherheitskräfte gesagt haben, also, naja, kriegen wir nicht hin, machen wir jetzt mal nicht so. Sie mussten nicht mal aktiv irgendwas tun, sie mussten einfach nur Befehle ignorieren oder mal das Telefon ausstellen oder so. Sie konnten sich immer noch damit rausreden, dass der Telex gerade kaputt war, wenn es halt irgendwie andersherum gekommen wäre. Das persönliche Risiko war begrenzt, nichts zu tun. Hingegen das persönliche Risiko zu schießen, war dann immer größer. Also die größte Demonstration war, desto schlechter fühlte sich das natürlich dann auch an. Weil es sich dann schon anfühlt, es könnte auch andersherum kommen, vor dem Hintergrund, dass die Wirtschaft sowieso im Arsch war und alle wussten, dass irgendwas passieren muss.
Die gefühlte richtige Wende wurde ja dann eigentlich durch diese Pressekonferenz, diese Merkwürdige eingeleitet. Hattest du den Eindruck, dass es schon der Wendepunkt war? Diese Mauer war natürlich auch die Mauer in den Köpfen. Und deren Wegfall hat dann auch den letzten Zweifel beseitigt, dass es jetzt soweit ist.
Also eigentlich war zumindest so, dass das jetzt, was größer passiert war, vollkommen klar in dem Umblick, wo Honecker zurückgetreten wurde. Diese merkwürdige Übergangsregierungsgeschichte, da gab es schon klar, dass das jetzt nur noch Gezappel sein wird.
Wann ist das nochmal?
Das war im Oktober, oder? Dann gab es die große Demonstration, die noch vor dem Mauerfall war, am 4. November. Und diese Demonstration am 4. November, dann war halt klar, jetzt ist vorbei. Dann gab es noch genau die Geschichte mit der Mauer. Es könnte sein, dass jetzt, wenn wir alle zur Mauer gehen, dass sie dann doch noch schießen. Das war durchaus noch im Rahmen des Möglichen. Es war nicht so, dass das auszuschließen war. Aber die Demonstration am 4. November war halt so groß. Es waren so viele Leute, dass es keinerlei Chance gegeben hätte, irgendeine Chance gegeben hätte, die einzudämmen. Dafür hatten sie einfach schlicht die Manpower, nicht ohne die Russen. Und in dem Augenblick war klar, dass das der wirkliche Wendezeitpunkt war. Und dass die Mauer dann fiel.
Na ja, spätestens für mich geht das ein bisschen weiter. Der Zeitpunkt, den hast du vielleicht richtig benannt, mit dem Al-Shabowski, wie zufällig den Zettel noch umdreht. Ach, hier steht noch irgendwas, da hat noch irgendjemand was hingekritzelt. Ach so, ach ja, jetzt schon. Ja, und dann fragt noch mal dieser Reporter nach, was gilt das jetzt? Ja, so weit ich informiert bin, gilt das ab sofort. Und dann stehen sie eigentlich praktisch alle schon auf. Und da eine interessante Sache, Wirkung wieder der Massenmedien. Da konnte man das auch sehr schön sehen, wie Fernsehen bestimmte Sachen forcieren kann. Ich weiß nicht, Radio habe ich zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht verfolgt, aber ich habe im Fernsehen gesehen, wie die Teams an den Brücken standen und sagten, da hinten sehen wir schon ein paar Trabanten. Nein, sie kommen noch nicht näher. Wir rechnen aber jeden Moment damit. Wir melden uns wieder, sobald es so weit sein wird, zurück in die Studie, bitte. Und dann der nächste Reporter von einer ähnlichen Grenzübergrenze mit einer ähnlichen Sache. Das sehen natürlich all die DDR-Bürger, die einen Kilometer, zwei, drei, vier, fünf Kilometer davon entfernt wohnen. Die fahren dann mal hin. Diese Rückkopplung wäre ohne Fernsehen so nicht möglich gewesen. Es wäre auch am nächsten Tag nicht möglich gewesen, dass die Leute zuhauf nicht auf Arbeit erscheinen, sondern gleich früh erst mal nach West-Berlin fahren. Wir waren einfach da hin und gehen mal rüber.
Habt ihr diese Pressekonferenz live mitbekommen?
Nein, ich war in einer Diskussion im heutigen BCC.
Wie ist das damals offiziell? Kongresshalle?
Da ging es um die Zukunft der Bildungspolitik in der DDR. Wir sind zurückgelaufen, Frau Duttick, mit einer Flasche Rotwein, die wir uns noch irgendwo besorgt hatten. So ein billiger Bürgerhaushalt, dann lassen wir das.
So aus dem Konsum.
Nee, ich weiß nicht, wo die herkamen. Jedenfalls war sie irgendwie da. Und dann sind halt irgendwie die Frankfurter Lekamachsallee nach Ferdishain zurückgelaufen. Und uns kamen halt so Gruppen von Leuten entgegen. Haben das aber irgendwie nicht so richtig mitgeschneppt. So, naja, sind halt andere Leute, die da auch unterwegs sind.
Wann war diese Pressekonferenz? Also so an dem Tag?
Na, so früher Abend, so 18 Uhr.
Irgendwie ist es auch so wie 18 Uhr, ja.
Und haben das irgendwie nicht so richtig ernst genommen. Und dann haben wir schon ein bisschen angetwittert, als ich dann nach Hause kam. Und sah dann noch irgendwie die Ente Wiederholung im Fernsehen, aber bin halt ins Bett, weil es halt auch spät war. Und irgendwie wollte ich nicht nochmal los. Am nächsten Morgen bin ich dann tatsächlich zur Schule gefahren, weil ich weiß gar nicht warum, weil irgendetwas Wichtiges war. Und dann hielt der Busfahrer, Bus zur Schule gefahren, hielt der Busfahrer auf freier Strecke an, neben einem Zeitungskiosk. Und sagte, ja, hier irgendwie guten Morgen und so, wir halten jetzt nochmal kurz neben dem Zeitungskiosk an, damit irgendwie alle irgendwie auch die Nachrichten mitbekommen. Und geht mal alle raus und kauft euch eine Zeitung, weil die werdet euch noch irgendwie aufheben für eure Enkel. Und alle draus gestiegen aus dem Bus, haben sich eine Zeitung gekauft, und waren es tatsächlich noch nie mitbekommen. Wir sind alle wieder eingestiegen in den Bus, und dann als ich nicht zur Schule gefahren bin, da war halt nix, da war halt niemand, da bin ich halt auch wieder nach Hause gefahren. Ich bin dann tatsächlich erst ein paar Tage später...
Wo war denn niemand? In der Schule war niemand.
Also waren halt ein paar Leute, aber klar, passiert heute nichts mehr. Und ich bin dann tatsächlich erst ein paar Tage später nach Berlin-Weil-Med, ehrlich gesagt, ganz schön abgestoßen von diesem unglaublichen Menschenauflauf und Rummel. Und mit diesen Bananen und irgendwie... Das fand ich alle so dermaßen abstoßen. Und wieder, ich wollte mir natürlich keine angucken.
Ja, das war echt Ballermann. Volles Programm. Und du, wie hast du das mitbekommen, bevor wir nämlich den Aufschlag sozusagen im Westen... Oder wolltest du vorher noch irgendwas...
Da gab es noch diese Verunsicherung mit den Reisepässen und Personalausweisen. Dass man irgendwie nur, wenn man einen richtigen Reisepass hat und da einen Stempel drin hat, kann man wieder einreisen und so. Da gab es ja noch so ein bisschen Verunsicherung, ob man dann wieder zurück kann und so.
Stunden. Ich glaube, innerhalb von ein paar Tagen war das dann auch erledigt. Tobi, wie hast du das... Einen, den die Ausreiseanträge sowieso viel wichtiger waren, den war das auch egal, ob sie mit diesem Ding jemals da wieder hin können. Also, denen reichte die einmal die Ausreise und das ist halt fertig. Die Schabowski-Geschichte war halt ursprünglich darauf gemünzt, als es sich um Privatreisen handelte. Also, Privatreisen nach dem Ausland sollten nunmehr möglich sein. Ohne Antragstellung.
Das ist auch dieser schöne DDR-Witz, ne?
Du hast als Privatmensch ja kein Visum bekommen. Wenn sich ausweisen?
Was, kann man das jetzt schon selber haben?
Auch nicht schlecht. Bei Verwandtschaft ersten Grades hast du mal eine Westreise für einen halben Tag oder sie bewilligt bekommen, wenn die 60 oder 65 wurden. Ansonsten war das praktisch nicht möglich. Der Schabowski-Tag, wo er erzählt von Wegenjahr, nach meiner Kenntnis tritt das sofort in Kraft, da ging es um die Reisemöglichkeit. Da war ja noch gar nicht angesagt, naja, Wiedervereinigung oder so. In dem Moment, wo das alles offen war, war für viele Leute das eigentlich im Prinzip auch schon gegessen, das Thema. Der dritte Weg hört sich immer ein bisschen komisch an, aber die Möglichkeit für die DDR, irgendetwas zu machen, was jenseits von dem ist, was wir da gerade machen, war für mich spätestens vorbei, als dann die skandierten Sprüche auf den Demos in Leipzig von wir sind das Volk auf wir sind ein Volk um Schwappen. Und ich habe so im Gefühl, das sind so drei Wochen gewesen, da tauchten dann irgendwann diese LKWs auf aus dem Westen, so mit Shibo-Packungen und diesen DSU-Aufklebern in derselben Typo, wie halt CSU-Aufkleber, die haben halt diese Rom-Förmchen-Aufkleber da verteilt und von den LKWs, wir haben das ein Volk runtergebrüllt. Und die Leute haben das willfährig aufgenommen. Und da habe ich gemerkt, denen ist das hier völlig egal. Es geht denen nicht darum, dieses Land zu erhalten oder irgendwie, sagen wir mal, diesen sozialen Zusammenhalt, der bei uns bestimmte Sachen überhaupt erst möglich gemacht hat, irgendwie zu retten. Das ist völlig egal. Das ist völlig egal. Die Anwesenheit von Bananen und Beate Use ist viel wichtiger. Und der Ruch, der gerade über diese frischen Mauerlöcher quasi schwappt oder die greifbare Entfernung davon, das war den meisten wesentlich wichtiger. Ich war am neunten, ich habe wieder mal hier Sammi Stadt, also Oppositionsliteratur gedruckt und kam irgendwie um sieben Uhr früh nach Hause. War eigentlich ein schöner Tag, die Sonne ging auf. Heute war aber ein bisschen neblig. Ich habe in der Bornholmer Straße gewohnt, ohne Quatsch, und jetzt etwa 200 Meter vom Grenzübergang weg. Und in diesem Nebellauf, also das ist eine kleine Kleingartenanlage, dadurch relativ viele Bäume und ohnehin mehr Luftfeuchtigkeit, das war also in Erinnerung ist es tatsächlich wirklich wie so ein Traum im Nebel. Aber tatsächlich waren diese Traube von Menschen vor diesem Grenzübergang, der war im Nebel drin. Das war ein ganz, ganz merkwürdiges Bild, was ich da in Erinnerung habe. Und jetzt, wir haben, nachts hat mich jemand angerufen, wir haben mit mehrere Stunden nicht geglaubt, haben uns dann viele, viele Dinge versichert und wussten dann, dass das also stimmen muss, was uns da wartet. Ich war aber von einer nächtlichen Arbeit Knülle und hab dann irgendwie erst mal bis Mittag gepennt und musste mir das dann ansehen. Und hatte allerdings wirklich nur diese 200 Meter, bis ich dann feststellte, Mensch, der Straßenbelach sieht ja genauso aus wie bei uns. Und die haben ja dieselben Gehwegplatten. Na ja, was sollte im Westen noch anderes an Gehwegplatten liegen? Unsere Vorstellung aber immerhin kannte ich so nicht. Daher tatsächlich erst mal mit diesem naiven Ding dahin gegangen. Na ja, und zu dem Zeitpunkt war natürlich alles vorbei. Da ging es nicht mehr darum zu überlegen, welche assoziierte Zusammenarbeit können diese beiden Staaten pflegen? Wie macht man das mit einer Währung? Wie geht man damit um? Das war für die Allermeisten überhaupt kein Thema mehr. Niemand wollte sich darum kümmern, wie bauen wir eine Regierung auf? Und das ist halt auch ein Problem der Opposition zu diesem Zeitpunkt gewesen. Die DDR-Opposition hatte verpasst, die Machtübernahme klarzukriegen, also die Machtfrau zu stellen. Viele wollten überhaupt nicht, ging nicht um die Macht an der Stelle, sondern nur um eine Korrektur und eine Veränderung bestehender Verhältnisse. Zum Besseren hin, jetzt sage ich das mal so profan. Aber wenn es dann schon so weit fortgeschritten ist, und selbst die Gruppen, die sich nur mit bürgerlichen Rechten, also Pressefreiheit, Versammlungsfreiheit, all diesen Sachen beschäftigt haben, die haben solche Fragen nicht gestellt. Beryl Bohler ist vielleicht danach bekannt geworden, Vera Wollenberger, also Lengsfeld, später dann bei den Grünen nochmal und danach in der CDU Karriere. Na ja, hat aber bitte bei den Grünen angefangen. Wie wir jetzt seit Hamburg wissen, oder wie? Da gab es doch schon noch ein paar Koryphäen. Das sind aber die Leuchttürme, die in die Analen der Geschichte dafür eingehen werden. Ansonsten wird von dieser Sache mit der DDR-Opposition nicht in Erinnerung viel übrig bleiben. Genau, weil sich der Machtfrage an dem Moment nicht gestellt hat. Es gab so ein Machtvakuum an irgendeinem Punkt, aber es wurde praktisch nicht besetzt. Deshalb war es halt Kohls blühenden Landschaften relativ einfach. Sein Will-Ferien-Erfüllungsgehilfen zu Leuten wie Peter Diestl, dem Innenminister, oder Dimissier, irgendwie.
Im Real betrachtet hätte es die Möglichkeit nicht gegeben, weil die Leute einfach in den Westen wollten. Die haben das ja auch einfach so gesehen. Das funktioniert doch, was reden wir noch? Das einzige, was da noch dazwischen hätte stehen können, wären halt die Alliierten gewesen. Wenn halt einfach einer von den Alliierten gesagt hätte, wir wollen nicht, dann wäre halt auch so eine Konfirmationsgeschichte hinausgelaufen. Aber das wäre halt auch nur dem Namen nach so gewesen. De facto wären halt irgendwie so wie BRD und West-Berlin formal getrennte Entitäten, aber de facto das selbe gewesen. Es gab da halt eigentlich keine ernsthafte Möglichkeit. Die Frage war halt nur, ob die Bedingungen des Beitritts so scheiße sein mussten, wie sie gelaufen sind. Das war halt am Ende noch die Frage. Frappieren war dann halt auch, wie schnell die Kungel da anfingen zwischen den Westbehörden und dem Zugriff auf zum Beispiel die Stasiakten. Schäuble war damals dafür zuständig, sich herzustellen, dass die Westdienste an die Akten kommen. Der hat damals den Zugriff auf die Akten organisiert. Da haben wir noch die Mahnwache vor einer Mannenstraße gemacht. Das war halt schon alles eine sehr graue Zeit. Es ist auch viel passiert, wenn wir Mäusere besetzen und gegen die Partys gefeiert Spaß gehabt haben. Das war nicht im Sinne von rechtlos, sondern so undefiniert. Es gab so absurde Szenen, dass er in einer Kastanerlei ein Haus besetzt. Der war direkt nebenan in einem Stadion. Da zogen immer die Hooligans jeden Sonnabend, wenn das Spiel war. Wir schmissen halt Steine auf das Haus. Dann hatten wir eine lustige Reihe Ostpolizisten mit ihren Blechschilden, die unser besetztes Haus vor den Nazis verteidigen. Der kurze Sommer der Anarchie.
Jetzt ist die DDR schon ein bisschen vorbei. Was euch so einfällt, ich fand ja diesen Unterschied immer sehr interessant. Da haben sich zwei Deutschlands vor sich hin entwickelt, schön getrennt. Wenn man mal so rüberkommt, dann waren einfach die Unterschiede, gerade das, was einem als erstes auffällt. Du hast gesagt, die Gehwegplatten waren jetzt genauso. Mir sind vor allem ein paar Sachen aufgefallen, die waren einfach anders. Da war zum Beispiel weniger Licht. Es war ganz schön dunkel. Dunkeldeutschland war zum Beispiel auch immer eine schöne Formulierung.
Stimmt, habe ich schon mal gehört und konnte mir nie erklären, was zu bezeichnen ist.
Ich war mal wieder in Dunkeldeutschland. Da ist nicht so viel Straßenlaternen-Attacke. Oder vor allem auch diese ganzen Werbungen. Man kennt ja alles. Was war in der ersten Zeit der wesentliche Unterschied, den ihr festgemacht habt? Gab es etwas, was euch besonders aufgefallen ist?
Am besten, dass alles mit Geld zu tun hatte. Was auch sehr schnell im Osten passiert ist, dieser informelle Auf-Gegenseitigkeits-Austausch, dass der so wenig verbreitet war. Lustigerweise habe ich den dann an einem Chaos-Computer-Club wieder gefunden. Das war mir die letzte sozialistische Bastion. Das wurde einfach völlig selbstverständlich. Mein Schlüsselerlebnis war da, ich glaube, beim Kokon, als noch DDR war, hat der CCC da heute Pulliwilder einen Konkurs gemacht. Genau, und da hat mir Jürgen Christ halt ein Modem geschenkt, einfach so. Weil er hatte ja noch rumliegen und war halt irgendwie 2-4 oder so, schnarcht langsam mit Büchse, aber ging halt so. Und das fand ich total sympathisch. Das war halt so eines der ersten Erlebnisse mit Wessis, die mich nicht doof fanden oder hinterrückständig, sondern die das total cool fanden, dass wir da den Hacker-Spirit im Osten aus Mangel herausentwickelt haben. Und die halt einfach diesen Freiraum, der da plötzlich entstanden war, zu schätzen wussten und das halt nicht irgendwie doof und abschaffenswert fanden, sondern das halt einfach als Chance begriffen haben. Und ansonsten war da aber schon, gerade West-Berlin fand ich, also gerade die Kudam-Gängen und so fand ich echt ziemlich abstoßend. Also das war halt so klar faszinierend, aber man sieht dann auch sehr schnell die schatten Seiten und die Ecken, die halt eben nicht so glitzern. Und naja, gut, und dann war natürlich dieser ganze, nach dem Mauerfall und sind da mit Aussie abzocken und so, war ja dann doch sehr dramatisch so. Man ist dann halt schon noch sehr lange rübergefahren. Also noch viele Jahre ist man halt dann nach West-Berlin rübergefahren.
Jetzt ist es nicht mehr so, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Na, weniger, ja.
Bei mir war das immer so, in den ersten Tagen, da gab es, wenn ich nach West-Berlin gefahren bin, da habe ich es wieder, genau, gab es diese Sachen mit dem Geruch, wie aus dem Westpaket. Wenn wir vor Weihnachten irgendwie ein Westpaket bekommen haben, dann war das so, wie wenn man in den Intershop gegangen ist. Wo haben wir eigentliche? Eine komische süßliche Mischung aus Parfüm und aromatisierten Getränken und den Fruchtsäure-Istern, die in den Haribo-Erdbeeren drin sind. Man riecht das nicht mehr. Die ersten Tage riechen das noch, wenn ich da in die Geschäfte ging. Selbst bei Wohlwort hat es so gerochen. Natürlich riecht man das heute nicht mehr. Unser Organ hat sich leider auch an diese Sachen sehr gewöhnt. Mir passiert es ganz selten, vielleicht ein, zwei Mal im Jahr, wenn ich außerhalb der Stadt bin und ich komme abends, wenn relativ ruhiges Wetter ist, ohne so viel Windbewegung, komme ich in die Stadt gefahren und steige irgendwo in der Innenstadt mit der S-Bahn aus. Da gibt es manchmal noch diesen Moment, dass ich solche Sachen rieche.
Als ich in der Ukraine war und wir eine Weile oben in den Bergen waren und dann zurückgekommen sind, roch der erste Laden wie in der Schauber, stimmt.
Ich hatte das auch lange in Tschechien noch länger, dass es noch ein bisschen ausgeruchte und das ist ja auch, wenn man aus dem Westen oder der Osten, erstmal die Trabants, diese Zwei-Tag-Mischung und natürlich dann auch die Kohleheizung. Das werde ich auch nicht vergessen. Es war so zeitlang so, dass ich in Berlin, obwohl ich dann teilweise schon manchmal gar nicht mehr wusste, wo jetzt genau die Mauer verlief, wenn man dann sozusagen so einen gewissen Straßenzug passierte.
Also die Bronkohleheizung hat da sehr viel zu beigetragen. Und dann fand ich, dass der Westen irgendwie nach Döner stinkt.
Das stimmt, es gibt auch jetzt noch so bestimmte Bezirke, die einfach so ein bisschen... Tja Leute, das haben wir aber viel geredet, war wieder eine schöne lange Sendung. Aber die drei Stunden haben wir wieder nicht gesprengt. Oder?
Ja, es ist schade, dass das Entwicklung aus, deshalb mag ich halt auch die Chaos-Nerd-ähnlichen Zusammenhänge, weil dieses Denken entwickeln aus Beschränkungen heraus. Dieses Horizont erweitern durch Minimalisierung für mich eine sehr wichtige Denkschule ist.
Genauso wie ich selbst die politische Bildung aus dem nicht grundsätzlich scheiße fände, weil sie mich unter anderem politische Ökonomie gelehrt hat. Und politische Ökonomie ist bis zum heutigen Tag für mich ein ganz wichtiges Analyseinstrument, um eine Politik irgendeines Staates zu verstehen. Für mich ist Ökonomie immer politisch. Und deshalb kann man das auch jenseits von marxistischen Kategorien immer noch auf Politik von Staaten oder von großen mächtigen Bevölkerungsgruppen anwenden. Was deren ökonomische Interessen bestimmt, wird deren politische Tandeln sein. Das haben viele für sich auch einfach mit bei der Erlegenheit aus dem Boot gekippt. Zuzüglich der Tatsache, dass natürlich durch die Desavoyierung des Begriffs Sozialismus, durch unsere alte Staatsführung, das Wort geworden ist, was man auf die nächsten 100 Jahre wirklich nicht mehr richtig einsetzen kann. Das ist das eigentliche Verdienst von diesen Krippeln, die ein Wandlitz gehaust haben. Das ist etwas sehr Ärgerliches. Das heißt, man kann also auch nicht mehr, ohne in den Verdacht zu geraten, mit den Leuten etwas zu tun haben, sich mit solchen Gedanken beschäftigen. Man muss sie geradezu konspirativ betreiben. Das ist etwas sehr Ärgerliches. Insofern finde ich es sehr interessant, wie so einige linke Tendenzen, wenn ich so Spiegelkommentare lese, wie zum Beispiel ihre Kapitalismus-Kritik aktuell äußern, wie solche Sachen da auf sich wieder... Die Inhalte sich wieder finden, aber die Begräblichkeit sehr vorsichtig drum herum. Genau, ja.
Also die Computersession müssen wir wahrscheinlich dann doch nochmal nachführen. Da hätte man jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nochmal drei Stunden mitfüllen können. Schön, dass noch ein Thema übrig ist. Ja, mir fällt jetzt auch nichts mehr zu ein. Nicht, dass man ja nicht tausend Sachen noch weiter verdienen könnte, aber so ist es ja immer. Aber ich denke, das war mal eine ganz interessante Reise hier so in die Welt des Ostens, der wilde Osten. Ich muss sagen, ich habe diese Zeit extrem genossen. Im Nachhinein ärgere ich mich sehr, dass ich nicht noch viel früher nach Berlin gekommen bin. Gerade so diese wilden 90er-Jahre. Also ich bin ja eigentlich hier erst 1995 richtig dazugestoßen. Und da war es schon immer noch verrückt. Und die Jahre davor war ich aber nur so oft auf Besuch und das war einfach irre. Also was hier ging, das kann man sich, glaube ich, so richtig gar nicht mehr vorstellen, wenn man das nicht live mitgemacht hat.
Was noch über Köln oder den Pazio-Norherplatz gefahren sind?
Da war nix. Na gut, jetzt wollen wir ja auch nicht in alten Zeiten rumschwimmen, sondern ich sag Danke, Schramm, Frank. Und ja, danke fürs Zuhören. Ich hoffe, es war mal wieder interessant hier bei Chaosradio Express. Bleibt uns treu, wir machen jetzt hier einfach mal Schluss.
Auf Wiedersehen!
Ich bin die Nama, die Damen und Herren. Und hier ist wieder live aus dem Schlagerstudio des Fernsehens der DDR. Atlas Hof mit unserem beliebten Schlagerstudio. Und Platz 1 diese Woche ist die Gruppe Automobil und Du hast den Farbfilm vergessen.